Ich weiß glaube ich nicht, wer ich bin. Ich weiß, wofür stehen, ich weiß, was ich mache, aber wer ich am Ende bin, denke ich, wird man am Ende sehen.
Das Ende, es ist zu früh gekommen von Kay Bernstein, aber wir wollen jetzt genau diese Frage versuchen zu beantworten. Wer war Kay Bernstein? Was hat er dem Fußball überlassen? Das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Harald Lange, Fanforscher von der Universität Würzburg und mit Marc Schwitzky, Journalist. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich aus dem Rasenfunk und von hertha-base.de.
Ich möchte ein Präsident sein, der für alle Hertha-Rinnen und Hertha-Ner da ist. Ich möchte ein Präsident sein, der Abschiedskultur ernst nimmt. Und da werden wir schon bei dem Punkt, dass wir Werner Gegenbauer, Michael Prez, Benny Weber, Arne Friedrich und Lena, die Hertha TV jetzt wahnsinnig toll gemacht hat, dass wir die Gebühren verabschieden, dass wir sagen danke für die Zeit, die ihr uns geschenkt habt, die ihr Hertha geschenkt habt. Und ja, jeder Weg geht mal zu Ende. Aber man muss sich in die Augen schauen und sagen, danke für eure Zeit und die erbrachte Leistung. Und das wäre wichtig, dass wir das in den Verein reinbekommen, dass wir uns ordentlich verabschieden.
Das Tribünengespräch Ordentlich verabschieden wollte sich Kay Bernstein und das wollen wir jetzt auch von ihm tun, auch wenn der Anlass natürlich ein sehr trauriger ist. Schön, dass ihr dieses Tribünengespräch hört und schön, dass ich zwei Gäste hier bei mir habe. Marc, du darfst mal anfangen. Wie geht es denn jetzt der Hertha aktuell? Es sind ja noch nicht mal zwei Wochen vergangen seit dem Tod von Kay Bernstein.
Wie geht es Hertha? Ich glaube, man sammelt sich immer noch. Ich glaube, dass natürlich sowohl die Fangemeinschaft als auch die wirklich organisierte Szene, als auch der deutsche Fußball, als auch die Geschäftsstelle in Schockstarre standen. Und dass alle kollektiv in einer ähnlichen Schwere der Schockstarre standen, spricht auch schon für den Typen, Kay Bernstein, der da, glaube ich… Also du musst es erstmal schaffen, dass Aki Watzke dir ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis bescheinigt und gleichzeitig aber alle Kurven an dich denken. Und dementsprechend, ja, waren die ersten Tage einer kollektiven Schockstarre unterlegen und danach fing es an, dass man sich gegenseitig aufgefangen hat. Da war das Heimspiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf mit dem vorjährigen Trauermarsch ein ganz großer Punkt, eine Art Trauerfeier für 40.000 Menschen mit sehr viel Stil, sehr viel Würde. Und genauso, finde ich, geht es bislang weiter. Ich glaube auch, dass es den Hertha-Fans und den Mitarbeitenden hilft, zu sehen, wie groß die Anteilnahme in Fußball Deutschland allgemein auch ist, dass man damit nicht allein da steht. Und aktuell, würde ich behaupten, versucht man, einen Weg ohne Kay zu finden, über den wir jetzt natürlich auch viel sprechen werden, aber wo sich jetzt auch schon ein Stück weit abzeichnet, was Kay hinterlassen hat. Also der Samen von Kay Bernstein ist so schlimm, das Ereignis auch ist. Es zeigt sich genau in diesem, dass der ein Stück weit schon aufgegangen ist und dass diese Hertha-Familie wirklich eine Familie ist. Und ich weiß nicht, wie das vor Kay Bernstein abgelaufen wäre. Und so fühlt es sich aber sehr einigend und sehr herzlich an. Und da befindet man sich gerade. Es ist immer noch die Phase der emotionalen Aufbereitung, aber auch eine Phase der, wir machen es jetzt für Kay.
Harald, ich habe dich oft nicken sehen. Was sind deine Gedanken dazu?
Ja, also ich nicke bei jedem Gedanken, den Marc gerade so formuliert hat. Weil mir zu jedem Gedanken zwei neue eingefallen sind. Was ich jetzt rausnehme, da alles erörtern könnte. Oder was mir zu diesem Ereignis, zu diesem tragischen Todesfall, doch zum Wirken von Kay Bernstein so einfällt. Das erste war gleich der erste Einspieler, den du gebracht hast. Das erste Zitat von ihm, wo er dann sagte, naja, er weiß nicht, wer er ist, aber das, was er ist und wer er ist, wird man dann am Ende sehen. Das hat ja schon eine richtige philosophische Tiefe, dieser Satz. Und genau darüber reden wir ja heute. Und darüber, deshalb haben wir uns ja heute auch getroffen, weil man das tatsächlich nach dem Tod innerhalb weniger Stunden, innerhalb weniger Tage so nach und nach erfasst hat, was Kay Bernstein für den deutschen Fußball, für die Fan-Kultur, für die Fußballkultur letztlich für einen Meilenstein gewesen ist. Marc hat gerade eben so ein paar Hinweise gegeben, was er intern für Hertha gebracht hat, am Klima, an der Atmosphäre, am Miteinander im Verein dort gewirkt hat. Ich habe eher so die Perspektive, was bedeutet das für die Fan-Kultur in Deutschland, in Europa, wenn man so will, in einer Zeit, die ja tatsächlich geprägt ist von permanenten Auseinandersetzungen zwischen der Kurve und der Chefetage, wo man tatsächlich sehr gut polarisierend agiert, beziehungsweise wo man diese Polarisierung zwischen Kommerz und Tradition gut nachvollziehen kann. Und wenn ich mich jetzt so an seine Amtszeiten zurück erinnere, war das natürlich schon – es hat eingeschlagen – wie eine Bombe, der wird ein ehemaliger Ultra, wird der Präsident eines so großen bedeutenden Bundesliga-Vereins. Und anfangs hat es dann natürlich die Menschen auch, die Öffentlichkeit ein Stück weit gespalten nach dem Motto, das klappt gar nicht. Andere fanden das als richtiges Zeichen, als Vorbild für andere Vereine. Und dann konnte man die Hertha eben beobachten und konnte in diesem ganzen Prozess sehr schön sehen, dass es im Fußball eben tatsächlich nicht nur auf den sportlichen und oder wirtschaftlichen Erfolg ankommt, sondern dass das, was Marc eben auch angeführt hat, was man Zusammenhalt, Familie, Heimat, Fußball-Eimat nennt, dass das letztlich das tragende Element des Fußballs, der Fan-Kultur ist. Und das würde ich so sagen, spontan aus dem Bauch heraus sind so meine ersten Gedanken, wenn man jetzt mit etwas Abstand beruht, das Wirken von Kay Bernstein als Hertha-Präsident jetzt nicht auf den Punkt zu bringen, aber zumindest ein Stück weit zu reflektieren, einzugrenzen und bestimmte Dinge hervorzugeben.
Und gleichzeitig ist ja fast der tragische Fakt, dass man das oft erst im Nachhinein alles erkennt. Also manche Legenden werden erst nach ihrem Tod geboren und erst dadurch zu Legenden. Man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Marc, dass viele Menschen sich erst jetzt so richtig damit auseinandergesetzt haben, was eigentlich so im größeren Ganzen passiert ist, durch Kay Bernstein. Und da gibt es jetzt zwei interessante Lager, nämlich das eine Lager, das sind die Hertha-Fans. Hertha-Fans haben mir das schon damals, als er kandidiert hat, gesagt, schon direkt nach der Wahl hieß es, ey, hier hat sich die Stimmung verändert. Ich weiß noch, dass die erste Rückmeldung auf Besprechungen im Rasenfunk der sportlichen Situation bei Hertha BSC, die ja von dem Abstieg dann geprägt wurde, dass da immer wieder kam, ja, aber was ihr vergessen habt, ist, hier hat sich die Stimmung schon total verändert und es gibt ein ganz neues Miteinander und so weiter. Wir werden das alles jetzt dann gleich nochmal ausführlich dann nachzeichnen. Aber hast du das Gefühl, dass durch diesen Tod jetzt die nicht-Hertha-Fans fast ein bisschen dazu gezwungen wurden oder dazu gebracht wurden, das jetzt auch zu sehen und anzuerkennen und zu reflektieren?
Schon. Also ich war, wie gesagt, ich war auch, man hat ja schon mitbekommen, damals als Kay Bernstein gewählt wurde, hat man ja das nationale Interesse an ihm und dieser neuen Situation bei Hertha mitbekommen. Da war aber auch sehr viel Argwohn dabei, vor allen Dingen von den Etablierten, sei es den etablierten Medien oder den etablierten Personen im Geschäft selbst. Und da war viel Argwohn und viel Skepsis dabei und viel, na nun warten wir mal ab. So ist ja erstmal eine schöne Geschichte, aber der soll jetzt auch erstmal beweisen, dass er es kann. Und ich glaube, dass dieses abrupte Ende seines Lebens, seiner Amtszeit dazu geführt hat, dass man eben jetzt diesen, ein Fazit ja auch irgendwo ziehen muss, denn es geht nicht weiter. Und dieses Fazit konnte man in unendlichen Anekdoten nachlesen, in vielen Nachrufen, die ich allesamt sehr, sehr schön fand, ob das von Stefan Oesfeld bei NTV war, ob das ein Jan Grosetzky war, der für 11 Freunde noch mal gemeinsame Anekdoten aufgeschrieben hat, wie man gemeinsam in Gelsenkirchen war. Viele Nachrufe, die ich jetzt alle aufzählen könnte, Anekdoten und so weiter, haben dazu geführt, dass Leute sich damit auch mehr auseinandersetzen mussten. Ich glaube, dass das im Tod ja auch immer ein Innehalten ist. Und im schnelllebigen Fußballgeschäft dringt das eben oft nicht durch. Da kriegt man Dinge am Rande mit. Oder ja, ja, bei Hertha soll es jetzt irgendwie laufen. Aber es sind ja doch nur Zweitligist. Und wie gut kann das schon gewesen sein? Ich glaube, dass das im schnelllebigen Fußballgeschäft dann eben schnell eine untergeordnete Rolle spielt. Jetzt mit diesem abrupten Ende waren alle dazu angehalten. Einmal zu reflektieren, was in diesen anderthalb Jahren Kay Bernstein passiert ist. Und das ist ein Kurswechsel, den ich im deutschen Fußball selten in dieser kurzen Zeit und vor allen Dingen von einem Präsidenten, nicht vor einem Manager, nicht vor einem Geschäftsführer, nicht von einem Trainer heraus in einem Verein gesehen habe. Und das schlägt sich in den ganz vielen Reaktionen gerade nieder.
Vielleicht auch Harald, weil man ja im anderen Verein auch immer den eigenen Verein sieht. Ich habe das Gefühl, immer wenn bei anderen Teams etwas Positives passiert als Fan, denkt man sich gleich, wäre das bei mir auch möglich. Und wir werden jetzt gleich ausführlich über den Werdegang von Kay Bernstein sprechen. Aber erstmal hat er ja gezeigt, dass gewisse Dinge möglich sind, an die man vorher gar nicht zu glauben gedacht hätte. Also dass eben der Vorsänger einer Ultra-Gruppierung Präsident werden kann.
Ganz genau. Und dieser eigene Verein im Spiegel des anderen Vereins, das ist ein wunderbarer Filter. Deshalb finden wir eben hier auch die Geschichten anderer Vereine so spannend, weil wir da immer etwas suchen, von denen wir lernen können, indem wir uns auch ein Stück weit selbst entdecken. Und das Beispiel Hertha, der letzten Jahre ist insofern diesbezüglich hoch spannend und hoch interessant, weil das ja ein ganz rasantes Wechselbad der Gefühle gewesen ist, was die Strukturen anbelangt. Also quasi innerhalb weniger Jahre von diesem klassischen Investorenverein, dieses Image hatte man ja da mit Lars Windhorst und diesen vielen, vielen Millionen, wo man aus der Ferne immer nur staunen konnte, boah, was machen die denn da, wie geht denn das? Und plötzlich war das ganze Geld weg und der Verein war trotzdem nicht vorne. Berater gingen ein und aus, die skurrilsten Leute tauchten da auf. Das war ungefähr wie ein Theaterstück des dunkelsten Kommerzfußballs, was man da so erlebt hat, mit all den Facetten, die man so als traditioneller Fan in seinem Verein auch gar keinen Fall haben will. Und dann plötzlich kommt genau das Gegenprogramm. Da kommt einer aus der Kurve und der wird da Präsident, übernimmt diesen Scherbenhaufen, den dieses Investorenmodell bei Hertha da hinterlassen hat und macht genau das Gegenteil mit der Hypothek, dass im Grunde kein Geld mehr da ist und dass er um die Zweitligalizenz bangen muss, wo er noch den Abstieg verkraften muss und und und. Und er schafft es genau in dieser Phase des Abstiegs, dass dann plötzlich die Mitgliederzahlen gestiegen sind bei der Hertha. Und das fand ich gigantisch, weil es nochmal genau diesen Punkt unterstreicht. Im Fußball, in der Fußballkultur ist natürlich das Gewinnen und Verlieren der Anlass dafür, dass man sich trifft, dass man ins Stadion geht, dass man auch über das Spiel spricht. Aber der Zusammenhalt, das Gefühl von Heimat, das Gefühl von Zusammengehörigkeit, das ist wesentlich stärker. Und dass man so ein Zeichen in der aktuellen Fußballkultur, die ja weltweit von noch dramatischeren Investoren geprägt ist, als das, worüber wir in Deutschland gerade reden und diskutieren, dass man in dieser Zeit so ein Zeichen, so ein Ausrufezeichen setzen kann, das halte ich für bemerkenswert. Und deshalb denke ich, diesen Fall, diese Präsidentschaft, diese letzten Jahre von Hertha und auch das, was jetzt passiert, das müssen wir uns ganz genau angucken, weil da können wir für unsere Gesellschaft, aber auch für unsere Fußballkultur enorm viel ausziehen, enorm viel auslernen.
Also hätte es noch eine Begründung gebraucht, warum es dieses Tribünengespräch gibt. Harald hat sie gerade geliefert. Eine kurze Nachfrage noch, bevor wir dann mal starten wollen mit seinem Werdegang. Und ich erkläre auch noch kurz, wie ich diese Sendung konzipiert habe. Diese Identifikation, die man findet in einem Verein, also das Spiel ist der Anlass, hinzugehen, aber nicht der Grund, warum man hinzugeht zu seinem Verein. Dieses Heimatgefühl. Hast du das Gefühl, Harald, auch aus deiner Forschung heraus, dass das noch an Bedeutung gewonnen hat, weil vielleicht andere identifikationsstiftende Räume in unserer Gesellschaft am erodieren sind?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich befasse mich ja, jetzt sage ich mal nur in Anführungszeichen, wissenschaftlich, das heißt sehr distanziert mit dem Thema Fans, mit dem Thema Fußball, Fußballkultur, bemühe mich da mehr oder weniger objektivierbare Fakten herauszufinden, Thesen zu finden, Positionen zu finden und das steht mir insofern immer dann ein Stück weit im Weg, wenn ich mich selbst dieser Leidenschaft so hingeben will, wenn ich da selbst mein fußballerisches Zuhause identifizieren will, da aufgehen will, dann kann ich grad sagen, je länger ich mich wissenschaftlich damit befasse, desto größer wird die emotionale Distanz. Ich gehe da vergleichsweise persönlich kühl, relativ kühl mit WUM, aber gleichzeitig habe ich manchmal Tränen in den Augen, wenn ich mit Fans spreche oder auch mit Studierenden spreche, die in ihren jungen Jahren sich dann einen Bein angeschlossen haben von ihren Auswärtsfahrten berichten und dann denke ich mir, man ist das was Tolles, das habe ich jetzt so nicht, da beneide ich die, da geht mir richtig das Herz auf und denkt natürlich dann auch an andere Settings in unserem Leben, in unserer Gesellschaft, wo ich mir denke und überlege, gibt es sowas Vergleichbares noch irgendwo anders? Das große Thema Religion, das ist im Grunde Geschichte, wo sich die Menschen früher in dieser Art und Weise gebunden gefühlt haben und Beziehung oder Familie, das sind alles so Identifikationspunkte, die erodinischen, wohingegen die Liebe zu einem Verein, die Liebe zum Sport im Allgemeinen, zum Fußball im Besonderen, das ist etwas, was bei all den Turbulenzen, die wir in der Gesellschaft auch gegenwärtig so haben, das ist etwas, was hervorsticht, was aufleuchtet und was man in vielen vielen Gesprächen und Beispielen Ich glaube, das ist ein Gewinn für mich persönlich in meiner Arbeit, dass ich damit quasi jede Woche so zu tun hab, ganz gleich ob ich jetzt mit Journalisten spreche, die darüber berichten oder aber auch mit Fans im Interview bin oder eben mit den Studierenden, die zu mir kommen, die natürlich aus einer gewissen Motivlage und Leidenschaft kommen. Und das ist super interessant, immer wenn ich dann mit einem Studierenden, mit einem Doktoranden oder so mehr zu tun hab, der zu einem bestimmten Verein gehört, dann baut sich bei mir sofort eine Beziehung zu diesem Verein auf. Im letzten Seminar war tatsächlich ein Fan von Bayern München. Die habe ich bisher immer so ein bisschen, naja, ich würde schon sagen, randständig von oben herab betrachtet. Aber jetzt, seitdem der Student da war und im Seminar so sagenhaft gute Beiträge geleistet hat, ja, seitdem sehe ich auch die zumindest aktuell ganz anders und bin da wesentlich aufgeschlossener, was so meinen persönlichen Fußballbezug betrifft. Also das wirkt, dieses Identifikationsthema, das ist was ganz herausragendes, genialisches und das ist es wert, untersucht zu werden. Da müssen wir verstehen, woran liegt das, damit wir vielleicht auch für andere gesellschaftliche Themen daraus lernen können.
Wenn ich da einhaken darf, ist es ganz interessant, weil genau das war mein Thema für mein Artikel zum Trauerspiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf. Warum gehen wir zum Fußball und was hat Kay Bernstein wieder dazu beigetragen? Denn auch ich stelle fest, dass gesellschaftliche Lagerfeuer immer seltener werden. Das war auch, wenn man die vielen Interviews von Kay Bernstein gelesen hat, auch seine These, dass man umso mehr sich im Fußball daran erinnern muss, worum es eigentlich geht. Und ich glaube schon, dass zwischenzeitlich – wir haben die Lars-Vintors-Zeit schon angesprochen, da fallen ganz viele Namen. Da fällt auch der Name Friedi Bobic und Co. wirklich tatsächlich nur an das Verlieren und Gewinnen gedacht haben und an nichts anderes. Und alles andere war eher störend und hat eher aufgehalten. Und es gab eine Zeit bei Hertha-BSC in diesen Jahren, die sich so kalt angefühlt hat, da hat Corona natürlich auch sehr viel zu beigetragen, dass die Fans sich physisch vor Ort sein konnten. Das war natürlich auch ein ganz großer Faktor und ein Brandbeschleudiger in dem Ganzen. Und trotzdem, glaube ich, auch ohne Corona wäre es so gewesen, denn nachdem Corona, was heißt, vorbei war, aber nachdem die Stadionsperre aufgehoben wurde. Ich war zum Beispiel beim Derby gegen Union, dass Hertha zu Hause verloren hat. Und nach dem Spiel mussten die Spieler ihre Trikots in die Kurve legen. Das ist ja, diese Bilder sind ja auch durch die Republik gegangen. Und das war mit einer der Tiefpunkte. Und in der Zeit, glaube ich, wusste niemand mehr so ganz genau, was er hier eigentlich zu suchen hat. Warum macht man das noch? Warum geht man hin? Das war dann irgendwie, weil es Lebensinhalt ist, aber eine intrinsische Motivation gab es nicht mehr. Und was Kay Bernstein, den Hertha-Fans und vor allen Dingen natürlich der organisierten Szene zurückgegeben hat, ist soziale Teilhabe. Ist sich gesehen zu fühlen, den Raum zu bieten, Dinge gestalten zu können, mitbestimmen zu können. Und ich glaube, wir werden auch noch mal später tiefer darüber reden, wenn wir über seine Wahl und seine Kandidatschaft reden. Aber Kay Bernstein ist eigentlich letztendlich das Paradebeispiel dafür, warum es 50 plus 1 geben muss. Denn er ist von den Mitgliedern gewählt worden. Das ging nur über 50 plus 1. Da gab es keine Seilschaften, kein Wir-hiefen-dich-mal-dahin-weil-man-kenn-sich-ja-oder-ähnliches, wie man es auf Fußball auf anderer sportlicher Ebene oft ja auch kennt. Das ist von den Mitgliedern entschieden worden. Und wir wissen mittlerweile, was in diesen anderthalb Jahren danach passiert ist, wie sich das Bild gewandelt hat, personell, wie sportlich, wie atmosphärisch. Und das wäre ohne 50 plus 1 nicht möglich gewesen. Und da ist Kay quasi eine Art Galleonsfigur für.
Und gleichzeitig interessant, das Beispiel, das du nennst, das Abgeben der Trikots an die eigene Kurve oder das Fordern der Trikots. Das hat zum Beispiel Kay Bernstein später mal als Fehler bezeichnet. Er hat gesagt, er versteht, warum das in der Emotionalität nach diesem Spiel passiert ist. Aber das hätte nie so sein dürfen. Das wäre ganz schlecht für alle gewesen, für alle Beteiligten. Also auch wenn er aus der Kurve kam, war er nicht immer so, dass er alles der Kurve unterstützt hat. Das werden wir gleich noch aufarbeiten. Und ich freue mich dann über das Anschlussgespräch. Das muss dann bei Deutschlandfunk Kultur stattfinden, Harald, wo du dann erklären kannst, ob es auch deswegen so viele Swifties gibt, weil wir eben neue Identifikationspotenziale und neue Familien suchen, an die wir uns heran anschließen. Aber das ist etwas für ein anderes Thema. Wie soll diese Sendung hier funktionieren? Leider kann ich Kay Bernstein nicht mehr interviewen. Es war für den Rasenfunk immer geplant, hatte terminliche und andere Gründe, dass es noch nicht stattgefunden hat. Stattdessen habe ich mich jetzt für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, durch, ich glaube, 15 Stunden Audiomaterial mit ihm durchgehört, habe viele, viele Interviews mit ihm gehört, viele Artikel über ihn gelesen und sehr viele Schnipsel mitgebracht. Weil ich dachte, das wäre doch ein schöner Ersatz, dass wir Kay Bernstein hier zu Wort kommen lassen, obwohl er es nicht mehr selbst tun kann. Das heißt, wir hören jetzt viele O-Töne. Die Quellen der O-Töne findet ihr alle in den Show-Notes. Sie sind, grob gesagt, vom Hertha BSC YouTube-Kanal, vom Gespräch mit Hertha Bass. Er war bei Felicio, das ist ein anderer Hertha-YouTuber und Twitch-Streamer. Da hört man manchmal im Hintergrund Thomas Doll. Das liegt da dran, glaube ich, wenn da jemand ein Abo, also ein Sub abgeschlossen hat. Lasst euch davon nicht irritieren. So ist das einfach bei Twitch. Ich habe sehr gerne die Folge Hörba Rust mit Kay Bernstein auf Radio 1 gehört und dann gab es noch verschiedene andere Nachrichtenbeiträge. Das ist alles verlinkt. Daher kommen diese O-Töne und wir wollen dann davon ausgehend seinen Werdegang beschreiben, wie er zum Präsidenten wurde, was seine Vision war, was auch die Realpolitik war, mit der er konfrontiert wurde. Da gab es durchaus einige Clashes, kann man sagen, sowohl beim Thema Sportwetten, als auch beim Thema Investoren. Er war erst noch der Gesprächspartner von Kay Bernstein. Dann wollen wir aber auch darüber sprechen, was mit seinem Tod und nach seinem Tod passiert ist. Das ist so grob unsere Herangehensweise. Wir beginnen mit seinem Werdegang. Kay Bernstein ist im September, am 8. September 1980, geboren in Dresden. Er hat dort bis zu seinem 8. Lebensjahr gewohnt. Dann ist er nach Berlin Marzahn gezogen. Seine Eltern sind dort hingezogen, er und seine Geschwister natürlich mit. Das heißt, noch vor der Wende hat er dort gewohnt. Wir werden gleich hören, was da eigentlich so die fußballerischen Alternativen waren. Aber Marc, du als echter Berliner, kannst du mir einen Einblick geben? Berlin Marzahn – was muss ich mir darunter vorstellen? Ich kenne nur Cindy aus Marzahn und hoffe, das ist nicht komplett repräsentativ.
Nicht komplett, aber in jeder Überzeichnung der Realität steckt ja dann auch ein Stück in Wahrheit. Berlin Marzahn ist schon sozialer Brennpunkt, Plattenbau. Menschen, die von dort kommen – da generalisiere ich jetzt einfach mal kurz – haben, ist nicht einfach. Und haben nicht gerade den vorgezeichneten Weg, der in die Unis führt und in die hochbezahlten Jobs. Das ist so. Und rein geografisch ist Berlin Marzahn so einer der unwahrscheinlichsten Orte, um Hertha-Fans zu werden, muss man auch sagen. Also es könnte eigentlich nicht weiter weg sein vom Westen Berlins, von Charlottenburg, von West End, wo ja das Hertha-Herz pocht. Das heißt, es war eigentlich auch eine sehr unwahrscheinliche Liebesbeziehung, die dadurch zustande gekommen ist, dass einfach ein Freund ihn mal mitgenommen hat. Und das ja aber auch in sportlich eher düsteren Zeiten, muss man sagen. Also das gehört auch zur Geschichte dazu. Aber dementsprechend, ja, wir reden vielleicht noch über seinen weiteren Werdegang. Der zeichnet ja auch nach, dass der ist nicht gerade verlaufen. Der hat Ecken und Kanten und da eine Narbe und da irgendwie eine Ritze. Und dadurch steht Kay auch ein bisschen stellvertretend für diese Region in Berlin.
Also er hat später in Interviews erzählt, dass als Kind nimmt man das natürlich nicht wahr. Als Kind hat er auch schon vorher in Dresden in einem Hochhaus gewohnt. Immer im vierten Stock, hat er erzählt. Und das war eher eine Verbesserung in Marzahn, weil man da einen Müllschlucker hatte. Und man konnte vom Badezimmer aus zum Beispiel, da gab es ein Fenster im Bad. Deswegen hat er es als Kind anders wahrgenommen. Was aber wichtig ist für seine Prägung, ist die Liebe zum Fußball. Viele Fußballplätze in Berlin-Marzahn. Kay Bernstein hat selbst immer Fußball gespielt, hatte auch, so wie wir wahrscheinlich alle, immer noch die Hoffnung, Profi zu werden. Die wurde dann auch bei ihm irgendwann zerstört. Aber wir hören uns jetzt vor allem mal an, wie er zu Hertha gekommen ist. Denn wenn man in Marzahn aufgewachsen ist in dieser Zeit, gab es eigentlich die folgenden Optionen.
Man hatte die Wahl zwischen die coolen Leute vom Schulhof, haben alle die Bomberjacke getragen und die BFC-Nadel getragen. Und die, die ein bisschen dagegen waren, sind zur Union gegangen. Und wenn man sich beide Sachen nicht hat vorstellen können, ist man dann irgendwie auf was anderes ausgewichen. Und bei mir war es eher ein Zufall, dass ein Klassenkamerad, ein Kumpel gesagt hat, ey Samstag spielen die im Olympiastadion, hast du Bock mitzukommen. Und dann bin ich mitgefahren. Und ich denke, das war – mit 14 ist es – ich finde, man hat zwischen 10 und 14 ist so eine Prägungszeit. Und wenn man da diesen Erstkontakt zu einem Fußballverein hat, wo man ein Interesse hat, wo man eine Begeisterung entwickelt, dann ist das ab der Stelle deine Prägung und dein Verein. Weil den suchst du dir nicht aus, sondern der wird dir gegeben. Und der wird dir durch so ein Zufall gegeben oder wird dir klassisch durch den Moment gegeben. Der Vater nimmt den Sohn mit, der Opa nimmt das Enkelkind mit. So ist es im klassischen Sinn. Und bei mir war es der Kumpel und dann war es der Verein.
Und dann war es der Verein. Harald, du hast sehr genickt, als er gesagt hat, zwischen zehn und 14 Jahren, das ist die prägende Zeit. Da finden viele ihren Verein. Warum ist denn das so?
Ja, das ist ja quasi in der Pubertät oder zehn Jahre halt knapp davor. Da sind wir auf Identitätssuche. Da interessieren wir uns. Da bilden wir auch sowas aus wie Geschmack. Da finden wir Sachen gut oder nicht gut. Da merken wir das Vorbild der Eltern, das Gerät hier und da mal ins Wanken, weil wir es in Frage stellen. Das sind alles so Prozesse, die auch schwierig sind, die auch manchmal anstrengend sind. Da lernen wir viel über uns kennen. Da lernen wir viel über andere kennen. Und da spätestens dann sind wir quasi berufen, unseren Platz irgendwo zu suchen und einzunehmen, um uns auch ein bisschen von der Sicherheit des Elternhauses zu lösen, wenigstens so ein bisschen. Wir akzeptieren natürlich nach wie vor die Selbstverständlichkeiten, die das Elternhaus so bietet, aber so gedanklich, philosophisch wollen wir uns davon ein Stück weit lösen und suchen unsere eigenen Orientierung. Das macht sich in der Musik, im Musikgeschmack, in der Peer Group, das macht sich in der Schule bemerkbar, aber eben auch im Sport beziehungsweise im Fan-Tun, dass wir dann bestimmte Musikgruppen toll finden oder aber bei manchen ist es dann auch so, dass wir dann bestimmte Fußballmannschaften voll finden und uns auch entscheiden müssen. Da ist es super spannend, in so einer Schulklasse, 6. oder 7. Klasse, 5. Klasse, da ist dann so, die meisten sind dann immer gerade Fan der Mannschaft, die gerade vorne spielt, egal wo man wohnt. Die meisten sind jetzt Bayern-Fans, einfach des Erfolgswebens. Das ist einfach, sich auch anzuschließen. Und meine These dazu ist, diejenigen, die wirklich die Spur für Geschmack haben, die fallen dadurch auch auf diesen Mainstream-Abweichen. Und da endlich auch ganz, ganz, ganz viele Beispiele. Dann interessiere ich mich auch als Sportleiter, wo wir sehr dafür, für diese Abweichler, die dann in einer Klasse, wo eigentlich alle Bayern-Fans sind, oder Dortmund-Fans, oder was auch immer, wie die dann abweichen und plötzlich einen Verein haben, wo niemand weiß, wie kommst du denn darauf? Bei Bernstein war es klar, dann ist der Kumpel und dann, oh ja, wir machen das mal zusammen. Da hat er richtig gut gehabt.
Ja, wobei andererseits in seiner Region war es, glaube ich, auch so, dass dann eher die Leute gesagt haben, warum gehst du denn nicht zu BFC oder wenigstens zu Union?
Ja, ja. Also es war dann schon im Sinne von, der sucht etwas, um sich auch abzugrenzen vom Mainstream, weil beim Mainstream machen halt alle mit, auch wenn sie den Fußball gar nicht so sehr mögen, sondern man macht da einfach mit, weil es opportun ist. Da schwimme ich mit. Und diejenigen, die dann hinter das Spiel gucken, denen irgendetwas auffällt, die sich die Spieler genau angucken, den Trainer, den Verein, die Fanszene und so, die merken, das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir nicht. Und wenn man dann das Glück hat, dass man in irgendeinem Club irgendeinen Anker hat, wo man sagt, das ist für mich interessant, dann beginnt die große Liebe. Dann vertieft man sich immer mehr. Von Spiel zu Spiel wird diese Bindung fester. Und irgendwann mit 13, 14 ist die so fest – und das ist ein gigantisches Phänomen – dass die nie wieder aufgemüsst wird, egal was bei diesem Verein passiert. Das einzige, was passieren kann, ist, dass man aus irgendwelchen Gründen so betäuscht ist oder sich abwendet und dann einfach sein Fan sein zurückschraubt. Vielleicht auch, weil man andere Sachen zu tun hat, beruflich familiär oder wo auch immer. Und dann sein Fan sein ein bisschen auf kleiner Flamme kocht und immer mal vorbeischaut. Aber was man niemals machen würde, ist dann den Verein zu wechseln und zu sagen, okay, mit der Hertha, das hat jetzt wieder nicht geklappt. Ach Gott, jetzt gehe ich doch zu Bayern München. Dann habe ich wenigstens jedes Wochenende ein oder fast jedes Wochenende ein Erfolgserlebnis. Das ist so ziemlich das Sinnloseste, was man als Fußballfan tun kann. Und das gilt ja auch deshalb in Fankreisen als absolut verböhnend, wenn da jemand ist, der da mit zwei Vereinen ankommt oder den Verein dann wieder wechselt. Da kannst du auch Briefmatten sammeln oder was anderes machen. So eine Leidenschaft muss ausgelegt werden. Und da ist tatsächlich diese Phase super spannend, weil da tun wir was für unser Selbst, für unsere Identität. Die bildet sich da aus.
Und das in einer Zeit, Marc, in der Karsten Heine Trainer von Hertha BSC war. Keine Angst, wir gehen jetzt nicht tief in die sportlichen Details, denn du bist ja noch jünger als Kay Bernstein. Das dürfte dir noch entgangen sein. Aber wegen des Spektakls ist er dich hingefahren. Wenn ich mir angucke, in der Saison 93, 94, 37 zu 39 Tore. In der Torbilanz knapp mehr als ein Tor pro Spiel. In der nächsten Saison 94, 95 natürlich alles zweite Liga. Damals noch 32 zu 36. Also das riecht alles überhaupt nicht nach Spektakel.
Gar nicht. Das Lustige ist – ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das schon mal im Podcast erzählt habe – mein Onkel war in dieser Zeit Teil der organisierten Szene, wenn man sie so nennen kann. Sie war ja eben nicht so organisiert, wie man das heute kennt. Harlikans und Co. bei Hertha, diese Ultragruppierung, sind ja dann erst mit Kay Bernstein und seinen Freunden entstanden. Aber natürlich gab es auch schon davor. Es gab als Allererstes in den 70er Jahren die Hertha-Frösche. Ganz altes Eisen, Gewalt. Wenn ja, dann macht man es auch gerne mal mit. Sehr auf den eigenen Stand, auf das eigene Ranking in der Kurve bedacht. Da musste man sich überhaupt erst mal durchkämpfen. Und ich weiß noch, wie mein Onkel davon erzählt hat, wie trostlos das war, weil Hertha in der Zeit ja einmal sogar Dritteliga gespielt hat. Das war absolut trist. Und man war mit 8.000, 9.000 Leuten in diesem weiten Olympiastadion. Und in diese Zeit ist dann Kay Bernstein in den Verein gekommen. Es hätte ja eigentlich keinen unattraktiveren Zeitpunkt gegeben, Hertha-Fans zu werden und sich davon anzünden zu lassen, was da passiert ist. Und das zeigt vielleicht noch mehr, was für ein exquisiten Geschmack, wenn man Haralds These folgt, keiner bewiesen hat.
Wenn alle Bayern-Fans da draußen abgewatscht hat. Ganz fantastisch, Harald.
Bayern in dem Fall einfach McDonalds und Hertha dann die Fünf-Sterne-Küche. Aber das war die Zeit, das war so ultra trist. Und in die Phase ist er reingekommen. Und ich glaube, ab da zeichnet sich er dann auch ab, wie Kay Bernstein geprägt oder gestrickt sein sollte. Nämlich jemand, der einen ganz, ganz krassen Gestaltungswillen mitbringt und total Bock hat, Dinge zu starten, mit Leuten etwas zu machen, Gruppierungen zu bilden und Identifikationen zu stiften.
Ich würde sagen, das hören wir uns mal an. Das ist jetzt ein längerer O-Ton. Da erzählt er, wie er vom Fan zum Ultra wurde.
Der Fußball hat ein bisschen sein Übriges dazu getan, in Marzahn dann eben nicht auf die schiefe Bahn zu geraten, sondern den ganzen Tag zu kicken und Fußball zu spielen. Also ein kleiner ballverliebter Junge mit 14, das erste Mal ins Olympiastadion gedackelt, was von Marzahn aus schon eine kleine Weltreise ist mit der S-Bahn. Damals noch bis zum Zoo und dann mit der U-Bahn. Das war 14 Jahre ja bängel-wahnsinnig aufregend. Das hat einen dann auch schon gefesselt im O-Block. Dann ging das so ein bisschen vor sich her. Mit 16 wurde es dann schon ein bisschen mehr fesselnd. Man ist dann zu jedem Heimspiel gegangen, hat sich die Dauerkarte geholt und hat angefangen, sich so ein bisschen zu vernetzen in Fanclubs und in anderen Dingen. Also so der ganz normale Weg mit Trikot, Schals, rechts Schals, links Schals, in der Hose Schals, im Gürtel. Also es gab auch Zeiten, als man so ein bisschen als Weihnachtsbaum rumgelaufen war. Das änderte sich dann, als dann die ersten Luftheule, also früher im O-Block war das auch noch gang und gäbe, dass sämtliche Luftheuler durch die Gegend flogen und irgendwann landete einer im Rücken. Also hat man sich eine Kutte geholt und aufnäher aufgemacht und ist sozusagen vom Fan zur Kutte geworden. Dann kam so ein bisschen die Ultramentalität und man hat angefangen, ein bisschen am Alex-lich die Super-T-Bowl zu kaufen und sagen, okay, was ist denn da in Italien los und was machen die denn verrücktes da? Und dann nahm der Irrsinn schon so ein bisschen seinen Lauf. War ab 18 bis 32, 14 Jahre, Hertha, Lebensmittelpunkt von alle Spiele in der Saison, jedes Auswärtsspiel, Trainingslager, Trainingslager in Teneriffa, in der Türkei, Europa Cup Spiele. Das war dann schon Lebensmittelpunkt, Lebensziel. Und die Eltern haben gesagt, um Gottes Willen, was macht der Typ da? Dann so mit jedem Auswärtsspiel ab 18 bist du freitags Blutspenden gegangen, hast dir dein Geld geholt und hast ein bisschen Plasma abgegeben, hat einen riesen Vorteil, musstest nicht mehr so viel trinken, um ein bisschen angeschossen zu sein. Und konntest dann mit dem Geld, mit dem Wochenenticket, meistens Freitagabend schon losfahren. Du hast in Brandenburg dann noch mal so drei Stunden Aufenthalt gehabt, weil kein Zug fuhr und saß auf einem Bahnhof rum und bist dann mit dem Wochenenticket weiter in NRW oder Stuttgart und warst Sonntag wieder zurück. Und das waren so die ersten Jahre, erste Liga, jedes Spiel fahren und mit dem Wochenenticket durch die Republik reisen. Und dann so 1998, 1999, wo schon die Fanszene sich ein bisschen organisiert hat, wo wir mehr angefangen haben, mit Bussen auswärts zu fahren. Und war das dann halt Wochenende für Wochenende im Bus, im Bus, im Bus. Und das war unser Jugendclub, unsere Diskothek und unser Partyhort.
Und ich glaube, der Schluss, Harald, der ist sehr interessant zu wissen. Wir werden später auch noch ein bisschen drüber sprechen, welches Bild Ultras in der Öffentlichkeit haben, weil der Kay Bernstein logischerweise interessante Sachen zuzusagen hatte. Aber dieser Fußball als Ersatz für soziale Konstrukte, die es sonst zum Teil dann eben gar nicht mehr gibt, den Jugendclub, die Diskothek und so weiter.
Auf jeden Fall. Also, als ich jetzt eben die Zeilen so gehört habe, die auch die Leidenschaft, die da dahinter steht, dann wird man so ein bisschen wehmütig und denkt sich, boah, das hätte ich auch gern erlebt. Jungsweise, man fühlt sich auch erinnert an ähnliche Situationen, die man in seiner eigenen Biografie, die einem dann da plötzlich so spontan einfallen.
Aber Harald, warst du schon mal drei Stunden nachts auf einem Bahnhof im Brandenburg? Ich weiß nicht, ob man das nicht auch romantisiert. Mir reicht ja schon drei Stunden tagsüber an einem Bahnhof im Brandenburg.
Ja, also wenn ich mal drei Stunden irgendwo Aufenthalt hatte, dann definitiv nicht geplant. Und das ist hier das Bemerkenswerte, wegen des Deutschland-Tickets und der weiten Fahrt, musste man das von vornherein in Kauf nehmen. Also ich war mal auf Rügen gestrandet und hatte den letzten Zug verpasst und musste dann da drei, vier, fünf Stunden länger bleiben, als ich das eigentlich wollte. Aber das war dann halt ein verpasster Zug. Und hier ist das Wochenende und Wochenende Teil des Plans, Teil des Konzepts. Also gewisse Schwierigkeiten, die man da so auf sich nimmt und gleichzeitig die Zuversicht, dass man diese Schwierigkeiten in der Gemeinschaft – er ist ja nicht allein da auf diesem Bahnhof gewesen – dass man das in der Gemeinschaft gut aushält, dass man auch weiß, die Zeit zu füllen und dass man in diesem abenteuerlichen Unterwegssein auch tatsächlich etwas erlebt, über das man dann die ganze Woche noch erzählen kann oder im nächsten Jahr, wenn man wieder dort ist, fallen ein bestimmte Geschichten ein. Das ist etwas, wo man auch, sagen wir mal, aus einer pädagogischen Sicht draufschauend sagen kann, das hat durchaus eine erlebnis-pädagogische Abenteuer, pädagogische Qualität, was da sich abspielt. Und das Besondere ist, da stehen keine Erwachsenen, keine Sozialpädagogen dahinter, die das Ganze für jemanden arrangieren, sondern das macht die Jugendkultur aus sich heraus, weil sie einfach von dem Gegenstand Fußball, von dem Gegenstand Verein angefixt ist. Man könnte sogar sagen, angemacht ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, da brennt ein Feuer in dir als junger Mensch. Und dieses Feuer führt dazu, dass du diese leidenschaftlichen, abenteuerlichen Reisen da auf dich nimmst und dann immer wieder solche Probleme dort vor Ort löst, mit dem Schlaf kämpfst, mit dem Feiern kämpfst und den Kater am Tag danach. Und dann musst du noch wach bleiben, weil da geht es dir erst ins Stadion. Das ist auch körperlich herausfordernd anstrengend und das schweißt natürlich in so einer Gemeinschaft zusammen. Und wenn man das jetzt hört, diesen Utun, dann ist einem natürlich auch klar, weshalb Kay Bernstein so ein besonderer Präsident für die Hertha gewesen ist, weshalb es ihm gelungen ist, die Mitgliederzahlen so in die Höhe schnell zu lassen, auch in einer sportlichen und wirtschaftlichen Durststrecke, weil er eben kein anderer oder kaum ein anderer in der Lage ist, sich da reinzuspüren, was im Fußball, in der Fußballkultur wirklich wichtig ist. Also wer immer im Privatschat zu den Fußballspielen anreist, in der Wipp-Lanche sitzt und ganz behaglich von A nach B reisen kann, ja, der kann auch eine gewisse Leidenschaft entwickeln. Aber wer mit der Masse mitreist, mit denjenigen Mitfährten, die wenig Geld haben, aber von ihrer Leidenschaft getragen, angetrieben so viele Entehrungen auf sich nehmen und allein durch das Gemeinschaftserlebnis, das Spielerlebnis, vielleicht auch das Ergebnis dafür entschädigt werden, da entsteht wirklich etwas, was wir Fußballkultur, Fan-Kultur nennen und man kann vielleicht aus diesen Ausführungen auch herausinterpretieren, egal was das ist, das muss etwas Besonderes sein, das muss etwas sehr, sehr Wertvolles sein und ich gehe in meinen Analysen manchmal auch so weit und sage, aufgrund solcher Geschichten, aufgrund der dahinterstehenden Bindungsprozesse, würde ich sagen, genau das ist das Tafelsilber des Fußballs. Das ist das, was den Fußball so wertvoll macht. Diese Bedeutung, diese Geschichten, die laden den Fußball kollektiv mit Bedeutung auf und machen im Anführungszeichen, wie gesagt, dieses Produkt. Fußball erst zu dem, was es ist, das steht dahinter und das müssen wir verstehen, das müssen wir betreffen, wenn wir Fußballspiele, wenn wir eine Saison, wenn wir ein Fußballereignis in seiner Bedeutung wirklich fassen wollen. Und das wird nach meinem Dafürhalten viel zu selten gemacht. Deshalb nutze ich jetzt kurz die Gelegenheit, ein Spedonier für Fanforschung zu halten, weil genau dann hat man die Gelegenheit, hinter solche Strukturen zu gucken und das aufzuarbeiten.
Ich schreibe mich ein, ich schreibe mich ein.
Da ist jemand auf der Suche nach Drittmitteln, das halte ich da bis hier. Aber ich unterstütze das. Ja, aber es ist, man merkt halt, Marc, wir werden ja darüber sprechen, Kay Bernstein war ja nicht immer ultra. Das ist vielleicht sogar zeitweise kurz ein Problem gewesen, dass er mal Vorsänger der Harlekin war. Aber er hat verschiedene Stufen des Fanseins durchlebt und hat deswegen, glaube ich, auch relativ viele Anknüpfungspunkte zu einer großen Menge an Fans. Es muss ja nicht jeder mit 14 bei jedem Spiel mit dabei gewesen sein. Es gibt auch andere Sozialisationen, die völlig zum Fußball dazugehören. Aber es hilft eben, wenn jemand diese Ebene verstanden hat. Bei ihm hat sich das auch auf dem beruflichen Werdegang ausgewirkt. Ich will da jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen. Das kann man sehr gut nachhören. Aber er hat also – von der Realschule ging es auf die Hauptschule – hat sich für ihn wie eine Enttäuschung angefühlt. Da hat er aber erstmals Lehrer erlebt, die pädagogisch anders mit ihm, vielleicht wertvoller mit ihm umgegangen sind. Er hat eine Lehre als Elektroinstallateur begonnen, die allerdings am Fußball gescheitert ist. Denn es war irgendein Spiel beim KSC, da gab es, glaube ich, schon die Fanfreundschaft. Deswegen wollte er dorthin. Er hat auf der Arbeit angerufen, hat gesagt, er ist krank. Er hat seiner Mutter gesagt, er fährt zur Arbeit. Er ist aber tatsächlich mit dem Bus oder Bahn nach Karlsruhe gefahren. Problem, er hatte den Schlüssel für die Werkstatt mit dabei. Und irgendwann hat seine Mutter angerufen, hat gesagt, wo ist denn, wo bist du denn? Ja, ich bin auf der Arbeit. Nee, das kann nicht sein. Dein Chef steht gerade vor mir. Und naja, dann war diese Ausbildung vorbei. Er wurde Industriemechaniker. Hat, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, bei einem Autohersteller unter anderem am Band gearbeitet. Da dann sehr, sehr oft um 6 Uhr morgens erst wieder zurückgekommen, direkt zur Schicht, Schicht gearbeitet. Und dann erst irgendwann spät ins Bett gefallen. Da sehen wir auch, warum er sich vor Anstoßzeiten eingesetzt hat. Eine seiner Visionen war, alle Spiele wieder um 15.30. Ja, wenn du das nämlich einmal erlebt hast, wie es ist, von so einem Sonntagsspiel zurückzukommen und wann du da zurückkommst, dann hast du da ein Gefühl für. Und der Fußball war aber bestimmt über seinen Werdegang da schon. Denn, dass er dann später mit sich beruflich neu orientiert, das hat wesentlich mit dem Hertha-Feen Benny zu tun und seiner Leukämieerkrankung. Ich weiß nicht, Marc, ob du das aus dem Stegreif so nur grob rekonstruieren kannst. Also es ist so, es haben sich die Harley Kings gegründet, da war kein Bernstein mitgeliebt. Das war die erste Ultrakopierung, was ultra genau definiert, das werden wir gleich noch mal hören. Es ging viel um Choreografien, es ging viel um eben den organisierten Support, das haben wir überall in ganz Deutschland gesehen. Südkurve München, Schickeria hat sich 1996 gegründet, also alle so 95, 96, 97, 98. Das ist eigentlich so deutschlandweit der Moment, wo sich die Ultras, wie wir sie heute kennen, meist gegründet haben. Und dann wurde das eben zu einem sozialen Ort für Kay Bernstein, wo man auch viele, viele Dinge organisiert hat, auch für andere Fans. Und es gab aber vor allem einen an Leukämie erkrankten Fan und für den wurden Typisierungsaktionen gestartet.
Richtig, richtig.
Kannst du uns da noch mal kurz ein paar, wie du das vielleicht auch schon mitbekommen hast, erklären? Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon damals auf deinem Radar war.
Nee, also ich bin ja auf 95er Jahrgang. Kenne ich das nur aus Erzählungen. Aber deswegen hatte ich auch vorhin kurz meinen Onkel erwähnt, denn er kannte den jungen Kay Bernstein und hat ihn erlebt, wie er sich in dieser Fanszene immer mehr sozialisiert hat, immer mehr eingebracht hat und er hat dann erzählt, dass das aber auch immer Respekt verlief. Also Kay Bernstein hat nie den Konflikt gesucht und jetzt ist er mit breiten Gangen in die Kurve und hat gesagt, so jetzt sind wir hier, sondern wenn bei irgendeinem Testspiel mal eine Pyro-Aktion starten wollte, hat man die etablierteren Fans in der Kurve auch immer gefragt. Das war aber auch – also auch da zeichnet sich schon ein bisschen vielleicht das ab, was wir später über Kay Bernstein lernen werden, dass er auch jemand ist, der Brücken gebaut hat, der nie versucht hat, Leute auszuschließen und zu explodieren, sondern immer versucht hat, alle mitzunehmen und so in dem Fall auch. Und in der Aktion, der Typisierungsaktion für den an Leukämie erkranken Fan Benny hat sich eben auch sein soziales Gen abgezeichnet. Und ich glaube, dass Kay Bernstein halt jemand ist, darauf werden wir später auch eingehen. Er hat nicht alles, auch aufgrund vielleicht seiner Sozialisierung, nicht alles richtig gemacht in seinem beruflichen Werdegang, im Sinne von Ausbildungen und so weiter. Wir haben gerade ja eine Aktion besprochen. Und Kay Bernstein war sicherlich jemand, der darauf angewiesen war, dass Leute ihm zugeneigt sind und dass er auch mal eine zweite Chance erhält. Und das hat er in sich aufgenommen und hat das dann auch in die Welt hinausgetragen und genauso anderen zweiten Chancen ermöglicht und den Blick offen gehalten für Leute, denen es schlechter geht. Und da trifft die Aktion mit Benni natürlich voll ins Schwarze.
Also man hat es damals geschafft, über ganz, ganz viele Aktionen 8.000 Menschen zu finden, die sich als möglicher Spender registrieren. Ihr kennt das hoffentlich inzwischen alle, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn wir hatten hier auch mal die DKMS-Aktion, die auch übrigens schon zu den ersten Spenden geführt hat. Es haben sich schon, glaube ich, zwei Menschen bei mir gemeldet, die weisen sich damals über den Rasenfunk richtig toll. Und ich weiß, Marc, dass du da auch eine persönliche Geschichte hast. Also dir muss ich auch nicht erzählen, Stammzelt-Spender zu werden.
Ich hatte auch das Glück, mal helfen zu können, ja.
Und das hat er damals organisiert. Und er hat unter anderem deshalb dann seinen damaligen Beruf, mit dem er dann eh nicht so happy war, abgebrochen. Er hat gesagt, ich konzentriere mich jetzt darauf, wenn wir das Leben von Benni retten wollen. Da ging es dann auch irgendwann darum, auch Geld zu organisieren. Denn man hatte dann die 8000 Spenden, aber die mussten noch alle ausgewertet werden. Das hat damals 50 Euro pro Spende gekostet. Also darum hat er sich dann auch gekümmert. Und da kamen dann erste Kontakte zu einem Radiosender auf, bei dem er dann ein Praktikum begonnen hat. Da war auch der Stadionsprecher, ich weiß nicht, ob es der damalige oder auch noch der jetzige, also der Stadionsprecher von Hertha BSC hat damals dort gearbeitet.
Müsste immer noch Fabian von Wachsmann, müsste es auch damals gewesen sein.
Okay, Fabian von Wachsmann, das erklärt vielleicht auch. Also der war extrem dagegen, dass der Vorsänger der Harlekins bei Radio Energy ein Praktikum macht. Er hat gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall können wir das machen. Das ist viel zu nah. Und dann hat aber tatsächlich jemand von Hertha BSC, mit dem Kay Bernstein damals schon zusammengearbeitet hat, die hat zum Stahlentsprecher gesagt, also wenn ihr euch den entgehen lasst, dann seid ihr selber schuld. Das war Problem Nummer eins, das wurde dann gelöst. Er durfte dort dann ein Volontariat beginnen und das ist im Grunde die Grundlage für seine spätere berufliche Laufwand. Er ist dann über diesen Radiosender ins Event-Management gekommen und hatte dann eben eine eigene Agentur aufgebaut für Event-Management, für Marketing, eigentlich alles, was man in dem Bereich tun kann. Das kommt alles hier heraus. So, das zweite große Problem war, Kay Bernstein hatte ein Stadionverbot, sollte aber für Radio Energy im Stadion über Hertha berichten und die haben gesagt, ja, nee, du darfst ja hier nicht rein. Daraufhin hat Radio Energy gesagt, ja, aber der will Bericht erstatten. Natürlich kommt er rein und dann musste er ja immer über einen eigenen Eingang reingehen und musste das immer so ein bisschen incognito machen, so wie es ich verstanden habe, dass das geklappt hat. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz interessante biografische Notiz. Wir haben hier jemanden, der mal ein Stadionverbot hatte. Und weil das später auch bei seiner Kandidatur – keine Angst zu der kommen wir gleich – dann auch ein Thema wurde, will ich eben mal kurz dazu zu Wort kommen lassen. Das ist jetzt zusammengeschnitten. Das sind zwei O-Töne. Erst hat er erklärt, was es passiert und dann hat er noch mal generell über Stadionverbrote gesprochen. Und auch hier äußert er sich logischerweise aus der Sicht, die ganz viele andere Präsidenten gar nicht haben können. Hören wir uns mal kurz an, zwei Minuten zum Stadionverbot von Kay Bernstein.
Das war gegen Energie Cottbus 2006. Heimspiel. Die Cottbuser haben in unserer Kurve einen Spruchband aufgehangen. Relativ clever gemacht. Über unserer Ostkurve im Oberring. Eure Eltern oder eure Mütter backen für uns oder irgendwas. Und dann haben wir mit dem Verein oder mit der Fanbetreuung gefragt, ob wir in der Halbzeit eine Antworttapete sprühen können und gegenüber ihrem Blog sozusagen auf der anderen Seite das Marantantur zumindest die Antwort in der Halbzeit präsentieren können. Dann haben wir das alles gemacht. Sind auch mit der Fanbetreuung darüber. Problem war aber, dass in dem Blog Cottbuser Althoole saßen, die das jetzt nicht ganz so cool fanden und dann die Polizei auf dem Plan war und die Polizei uns hat sozusagen wieder vertrieben. Wir standen aber hinter der wunderschönen Säule und dem Geländer. Wurde von der Polizei leider zusammengelegt. Gab auch schöne Bildaufnahmen. Wurde alles freigesprochen, alles zurückum, aber auch da wieder Auseinandersetzungen von Polizisten zerlegt und dafür Stadionverbot bekommen. Also ich habe Stadionverbot bekommen, weil ein Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet wurde. Und das Problem in der ganzen Stadionverbotsthematik, wo der DFB sich jetzt auch langsam annimmt, ist, dass die Unschuldvermutung umgekehrt wird, dass du per se von keinem Gericht dieser Welt verurteilt wirst und trotzdem Stadionverbot hast, weil die Statuten belegen, bei Einleitung eines Ermittlungsverfahrens haben sich alle Vereine der ersten und zweiten Liga darauf geeinigt in einem Votum. Das heißt, dann geben wir pauschal erst mal Stadionverbot aus. Mittlerweile gibt es noch ein Anhörungsrecht, dass die Vereine anhören dürfen und so weiter. Von daher ist für mich eher die Frage, warum wird da die Unschuldvermutung umgedreht und nicht das deutsche Gesetz gewahrt. Ja, der, der Scheiße baut, der eine Straftat begeht, der das Innenumfeld vom Stadion macht, alles gut, hat er das verdient, ist seine Konsequenz. Dann wiederum ins Verhältnis gesetzt, wie viele Tausende Besucher haben wir in den Stadien, wie viele Straftaten haben wir prozentual und dann müssten wir doch eher über die Kirmes, über das Oktoberfest oder über andere Großveranstaltungen reden, wo deutlich mehr Straftaten kommen. Aber um die Frage zu beantworten, wer Straftaten begeht, wer verurteilt wird, hat dann mit dem Stadionverbot zu rechnen, weil das die Spielregeln sind.
Das sind die Spielregeln, aber das sind Spielregeln, Harald, die Kay Bernstein ganz offensichtlich sehr anders bewertet als viele, viele andere im Fußballgeschäft. Und ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass unter den Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörern jetzt manche waren, die noch gar nicht wussten. Es reicht schon, dass ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen dich eröffnet wird. Und wir alle wissen, wie gerade im Kontext von Massenveranstaltungen sehr schnell mein Ermittlungsverfahren eröffnet wird. Das kann auch für Stickern und so weiter. Wurden schon Leute mit einem Stadionverbot belegt. Ich will jetzt nicht Stickern verteidigen, aber ob das ein Stadionverbot rechtfertigt, muss jeder für sich entscheiden. Also Kay Bernstein…
Ich finde es schön, dass man währenddessen dann voll gestickert einen Drucker im Hintergrund zieht.
Das ist Privateigentum. Aber deswegen will ich natürlich Stickern auch dann doch ein bisschen verteidigen. Zumindest im Privatraum finde ich es völlig okay. Das Problem ist, bei YouTube habe ich leider diesen Bereich abgeschnitten. Aber in anderen Videos hat man es schon gesehen. Aber Harald, das zeigt ja auch, warum Kay Bernstein über so viele wichtige Themen im Fußball auch anders gesprochen hat. Und ich finde gerade dieses Stadionverbotsthema, das ist ja hoch interessant, was er dazu sagt.
Ganz genau. Und zwar vor allem deshalb, weil er weiß, wovon er spricht. Und das ist ja so ein Punkt, den wir auch in anderen Feldern und Bereichen unseres gesellschaftlichen, politischen, wirtschaftlichen Lebens so oft vermissen, dass wir dann auch selbst in die Situation kommen, dass wir über Dinge reden, die wir nur aus der Entfernung heraus wirklich einschätzen können und uns deshalb hier und da irgendwelcher Vorurteile oder Alltagstheorien zu diesem Gegenstand bedienen müssen. So zum Beispiel hat ja die Fan-Kultur in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, im öffentlichen Diskurs in weiten Teilen ein vergleichsweise schlechtes Image, so gerade was die Gewaltthematik anbetrifft. Und sie hat gleichzeitig auch keine Lobby, die da positive Lobbyarbeit für Fan-Kultur machen könnte. Und deshalb bleiben solche Schilderungen, wie Kay Bernstein sie gerade im letzten O-Ton da gesagt hat, eingespielt wurde, bleiben solche Äußerungen ja meist unter der Decke. Darüber weiß man im Grunde nichts. Man denkt beim Thema Stadionverbot, ja das ist doch gut. Die Bösen, die sollen da draußen bleiben, die Straftäter draußen bleiben, weiß gar nicht, was da eigentlich so dahinter steht. Und dass dieses Thema ebenso wie das Thema Kollektivstrafen und so weiter wirklich gründlich bearbeitet gehört, da sehe ich ganz, ganz, ganz wichtige Herausforderungen für den Fußball. Auch für die, sagen wir mal, für die ganzen Kontrollausschüsse, die es im Fußball gibt, dass man sich mit der vermeintlichen, ich sage das mal in Anführungszeichen, Rechtsprechung nicht so einfach macht, sondern, dass man zumindest die allgemeine Gesetzeslage, die wir in Deutschland so haben, Stichwort Unschuldsvermutung, dass das auch im Fußball gelten muss. Und dass man dann eben auch immer sehen muss, na ja, so ein Leben, so eine Biografie eines Jugendlichen, eines engagierten Fans, die ist natürlich von Höhen und Tiefen gekennzeichnet, da macht man auch Fehler, gar keine Frage. Und dann ist so der Wunsch, denjenigen dann auch hart zu bestrafen, ja, den kann man eigentlich nur aus der Distanz heraus laufvoll ziehen, aber wenn man die Leute dann näher kennt, dann weiß man nämlich auch um deren Potenzial, dass sie wieder zurückkommen, dass sie eine Strafe bzw. eine Straftat auch bereuen können und dass sie sich wieder neu bewähren können und da gibt es nichts besseres als ein Fußballstadion, eine Fankruppierung, ein Fußballspiel, in dem man sich dann wieder neu bewährt und die Leute dann möglichst schnell auch wieder zurückholt, weil es eben da genau darum geht, einerseits auch Akzente zu setzen, zu provozieren, die anderen zu verschmähen, aber gleichzeitig da auch Spielregeln einzuhalten. Und diese Auseinandersetzung, diese Form von Auseinandersetzung in einem emotional extrem aufgeladenen Umfeld, die haben wir in keinem anderen Bereich. Bei den angesprochenen Kürmissveranstaltungen oder Oktoberfesten, da kommt dann noch das Thema Alkohol dazu und da kommt es dann zu Gewalt und Straftaten und Übergriffe, aber da gibt es im Grunde nicht diese Herausforderung, sich als Gruppe in einer Auseinandersetzung immer wieder neu zu justieren, immer wieder auch über das eigene Fair Play nachzudenken und immer wieder darüber nachzudenken, ja, wie reizen wir jetzt die Grenzen oder das Herangehen an eine Grenze möglichst originell und optimal aus und wie gehen wir damit um, wenn wir die Grenze überschritten haben? Das ist ein Spiel, in dem sich junge Menschen sozialisieren und es ist ein Spiel, was ich durchaus, auch wenn es hier und da zu Grenzüberschritten kommt, für extrem wertvoll halte, gerade innerhalb von irgendeiner Kultur.
Ich meine, gibt es wahrscheinlich manche, die dir jetzt Verharmlosung vorwerfen würden. Ich meine, du willst damit ja bestimmt keine Gewalt rechtfertigen, aber das ist ja genau das Problem, dass es so unscharf voneinander zu trennen ist. Was ist jetzt eben Teil eines Spiels, was man doof finden kann? Ich verstehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum man sich auflösen muss, warum die Blockfahne geklaut wird, vor allem, weil es ja aus der ursprünglichen italienischen Ultrakultur gar nicht so ist. Die machen sich dann eine neue. Aber ich kann das ja akzeptieren, dass die eben nach diesen Regeln dieses Spiel spielen und kann aber gleichzeitig kritisieren, wenn diese Regeln eben zum Beispiel in Gewalt umschlagen, die es ja eben auch manchmal gibt. Und man kann ja auch das Klauen von Fanscheiß als Gewalt bezeichnen. Das ist was höchst Subjektives. Aber ich glaube, das zeigt schon so diese Problematik. Ich verstehe alles, was du sagst, habe aber in meinem Kopf gleich schon so ein Aber, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich muss quasi auch die Hörerinnen und den Hörer einfangen, der vielleicht auch dieses Aber im Kopf hat.
Ja, dieses Aber ist natürlich auch extrem wichtig, weil wir natürlich auf gar keinen Fall quasi die Ausbildung von Gewalt im Fußball lancieren wollen, voranbringen wollen, dann am Ende des Tages da stehen und sagen, wenn du Gewalttäter werden willst, musst du zum Fußball gehen. Das Vorurteil existiert ja, aber das ist ja, wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, wenn man sich die Ereignisse, die da wirklich passieren, anguckt, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass das ein Ort von Gewalt ist, sondern statistisch gesehen, mit Blick auf die Gesamtzuschauerzahlen, ist beispielsweise die Zahl der Opfer von Gewalttaten im Fußballstadion verschwindend gering. Das muss man bei aller Emotionalität, bei aller Leidenschaft, bei allen Spielregeln, Stichwort Zaunfahne klauen und so weiter, bei allen Spielregeln, die dafür Dramatik, für brenzliche Situationen sorgen, ist das schon eine beachtliche Leistung, wo die Sicherheitskonzeptionen der DFL, der Vereine und so weiter ganz maßgeblich auch dazu beigetragen haben oder die Arbeit von Fanprojekten ganz maßgeblich dazu beiträgt, dass das Stadion am Samstagnachmittag einer sehr sichersten Orte ist, wo du in einer großen Gruppe Zeit verbringen kannst. Das muss man so sagen und natürlich ist dieser Reflex nachvollziehbar, dass wir sagen, oh, da kommt es zu Gewalt, die Medien berichten drüber, also müssen wir das quasi in keinen Ersticken. Das ist so eine Reaktion aus der Hüfte heraus, die wir auch in anderen Feldern so haben. Und fordern wir harte Strafe, möchten die Leute da rausziehen, aber wir ignorieren oder vergessen dabei, irgendwo muss es hier dann auch sein und statt Leute wegzusperren ist es natürlich immer sinnvoller, ihnen dann auch eine Chance zu geben, sich zu bewähren. Und nichts ist besser geeignet für die eigene Bewährung als eine soziale Gruppe, mit der man dann zum nächsten Spiel geht, wie wir das eben in der Trendkultur als solche sehen. Problematisch wird es erst dann, wenn der Spirit in einer Gruppe auf Krawall und Gewalt aus ist, dann ist der Punkt da, wo ich dann auch ärtere Maßnahmen für angemessen halte, weil dann ist dieses Moment der, sagen wir mal, heiligenden Funktion einer Kurve, der Selbstreflektion innerhalb einer Kurve, dann ist dieses Argument, dann zieht das nicht mehr. Aber das sehe ich in deutschen Fußball nicht. Da hatten wir auch solche Phasen, in dem, den Sinne noch nicht, dass man sagen könnte, oh ja, jetzt sind ärtere Maßnahmen erforderlich, ganze Geisterspiele erforderlich und, und, und. Das sind immer nur so aus der Hüfte heraus geschossene Strafbedürfnisse, die dann dazu führen. Und die bringen uns nicht weiter. Die bringen auch nicht mehr Ruhe, Frieden und Gelassenheit in Stadion, sondern die heizen solche Stimmungen, zagen eher noch auf.
Ja, es ist ein hochkomplexes Thema und allein darüber könnte man viel sprechen. Es wird aber vor allem deshalb relevant und deswegen habe ich diese Wolte über Stadionverbot noch ziehen wollen, weil Kay Bernstein irgendwann beschließt, er möchte jetzt sich zur Wahl stellen lassen als Präsident. Und deswegen werden all diese Themen nochmal für eine bundesweite Öffentlichkeit schon diskutiert und entscheidend ist ja aber die Frage, also er war lange Ultra, dann hat er sein eigenes Unternehmen und so weiter gegründet. Wir werden auch gleich noch hören, wie er dann beschreibt, als welche Art von Fan er sich eigentlich zum Zeitpunkt der Präsidentschaftskandidatur gesehen hat. Aber die Frage ist ja dennoch, warum hat sich Kay Bernstein überhaupt aufgestellt? Und da hören wir mal kurz rein und Marc darf uns dann den Kontext liefern, denn ich weiß, dass es einen legendären früheren Twitter-Thread von dir gibt, wo du einfach nur damals immer aufgeschrieben hast, was so passiert ist in den letzten Monaten, und es liest sich wie ein völlig auf Speed geschriebenes Drehbuch. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, eine tragische Komödie. Also wir hören mal kurz an, warum wollte Kay Bernstein dann überhaupt Präsident werden?
Der letztendlich wirkliche Auslöser war Lars Winthors, sein Auftritt bei Bild live nach dem Spiel gegen Hoffenheim, wo ich sage, das kann doch jetzt nicht wahr sein, wir haben ein bisschen Ruhe, dann wird das nächste Fass aufgemacht aufgrund von Enttäuschung, von fehlender Erwartung, von was auch immer. Jetzt will er versuchen, den Verein zu spalten und für mich war dann eher so die Frage, was kannst du als Mitglied machen? Was ist deine Verantwortung? Was kannst du einbringen? Also so bin ich geprägt, so bin ich wahrscheinlich von meiner Mama auch als nicht-Hilfersyndrom, Kümmer-Syndrom, aber wenn ich was mache und helfen will, dann mache ich es halt richtig. Und da war dann eher die Idee zu sagen, komm, wir brauchen einen inhaltlichen Neustart. Egal wie und wann wir den wie hinkriegen, wir müssen darüber nachdenken, wie kann das grundsätzlich ganzheitlich wirklich besser laufen, weil das es sozusagen rückwärts immer wieder Probleme gab, immer wieder Enttäuschungen gab, immer wieder Dinge passiert sind bei Hertha, wo man sich an den Kopf gefasst hat oder wo man dann wunderschön abblästern konnte. Das war eher so der entscheidende Punkt zu sagen, ey nein, der Neustart ist eigentlich unumgänglich und in der Antizipation des Momentums, das könnte wirklich dazu kommen, war das dann sozusagen die Energieaufbringung zu sagen, jetzt machen wir uns mal wirklich Gedanken und erstellen mal eine Vision, wie man Hertha BSC sich vielleicht ein Stück weit wünscht. Ein bisschen geerdeter, ein bisschen normaler, ein bisschen mehr Seele in diesem Verein.
Marc, was war da los nach dem Spiel gegen Hoffenheim?
Es war so viel, auch das kriegt man natürlich nur noch stückweise zusammen. Aber es war so, dass Hertha das erste Mal seit gefühlt hundert Jahren wieder ein Fußballspiel gewonnen hat. Und das ja eigentlich große Freude war. Felix Wagert war neuer Trainer, konnte aber nicht wegen Corona. Marc Fotheringham, sein Co-Trainer mit einem wunderbarer Schotte, der einen Journalisten nach einer Braveheart-Anspielung zurechtgestutzt hatte, hatte übernommen. Und ja, es gab eigentlich grundsätzlich Freude. Man hat 3 zu 0, glaube ich sogar, gewonnen, völlig aus dem Nichts. Und man dachte, okay, vielleicht jetzt schaffen wir es, uns zusammenzureißen und jetzt einfach gemeinsam gegen diesen Abstieg vorzugehen. Ja, und dann setzte sich Lars Winters bei BildTV ins Interview und hat damals dann einfach öffentlich mit Werner Gegenbauer gebrochen und hat so viel Öl – Dem damaligen Präsidenten. Dem damaligen Präsidenten, genau. Anspannungen waren schon in den vielen Monaten vor immer zu spüren. So, das muss man klar sagen. Es wurde eher übereinander geredet als miteinander. Es ging oft über Medien und ein generelles Misstrauen sich gegenüber hat man durchgängig gespürt. Und das war dann der Punkt, an dem es halt eskaliert ist. An dem quasi Lars Winters öffentlich den ganz großen Konflikt mit Werner Gegenbauer ausgerufen hat und mehr oder weniger klargestellt hat, ich oder er. Und das auch mit unlauteren Methoden, wie ich finde. Also zum einen hat er Unwahrheiten erzählt. Das ist so. Er hat beispielsweise gesagt, dass er keine Ahnung hätte, wo das Geld stecken würde, was anhand dessen schon mal gar nicht möglich ist, als dass er quartalsweise Finanzberichte bekommen hat. Jetzt können wir natürlich in den Raum stellen, dass der damalige Geschäftsführer Finanzen-Ingo-Steller, die so umständlich und nibulös formuliert hat, dass man wirklich nicht durchsehen konnte. Aber das wäre jetzt erst mal eine Unterstellung.
Also bitte, das Wunderkind der deutschen Wirtschaft wird ja wohl dann so ein Finanzbericht trotzdem nicht gefriert.
Fakt ist, dass er in Beiständen saß, in Gremien saß, dort Gremienarbeit hätte auch tun können. Aber faktisch, das wurde mir auch mal später bestätigt, nie da war. Dann frage ich mich auch, wie will man da noch Dinge erfahren? Aber Quartalsberichte wurden ihm ja auch zugeliefert und er hat auch insofern unlautere Methoden benutzt, als dass er damals klare Anreize gestellt hat, ja wenn Werner Gegenbauer geht und ich einen Kandidaten nach meinem Gusto bekomme, dann sehe ich mich auch in der Lage, wieder Geld in diesen Verein zu stecken. Also liebe Mitglieder, hilft mir doch bei dieser Unternehmung. Und das öffentlich bei BILD TV, ohne dass jemand da vorher darüber gewusst hätte, stattdessen war es tatsächlich wohl sogar so, dass vorher eigentlich sogar noch ein Burgfrieden beschlossen wurde. Also es gab vorher wie gesagt ja leichte Aussagen und so weiter und dann gab es wohl ein Treffen zwischen Investoren und Vereinen, wo gesagt wurde, wir halten jetzt alle öffentlich auf gut Deutsch die Schnauze und ordnen alles diesen Abstieg unter. Das wurde dann gefühlt drei Tage später von Las Vintas gebrochen. So und das war die eskalierende Situation, die vieles weitere dann ins Rollen gebracht hat. Einen Satz vielleicht noch dazu. Ich hatte in unserer Podcast-Folge damals mit Kay Bernstein die Frage gestellt, wenn es nicht so dramatisch schlecht um den Verein gestanden hätte, ob er sich trotzdem zur Wahl gestellt hätte. Diese Frage hat er mit Nein beantwortet. Es ging wirklich darum, den Verein zu retten. Man muss sagen, Kay Bernstein hat sich um 2006 herum aus der organisierten Fernszene zurückgezogen. Sicherlich war er als Ansprechpartner immer noch da. Er hat aber nicht mehr aktiv mitgewirkt. Es sollte dann eben 15 Jahre dauern, bis er wieder ins aktive Vereinsgeschehen eingreifen würde. Dafür brauchte es anscheinend auch einen Knall, denn ansonsten hat er sich mit seiner Eventfirma und ähnlichem gut aufgestellt und hatte gar nicht mehr das Bedürfnis, da so aktiv einzugreifen. Aber dieses Bildinterview von Lars Winters hat alles weitere eskalieren lassen und dann Kay Bernstein wieder auf den Plan gerufen.
Ja, und diese sogenannte Zeitung wird sowieso noch eine große Rolle spielen im weiteren Verlauf. Weil du es jetzt gerade schon angesprochen hast, ein Zitat, was er bei euch im Interview gesagt hat, zu der Frage, warum eigentlich er?
Einer muss es machen und da vorne stehen. Aber ich finde, es sollte der machen, der es am wenigsten will, weil er es dann am besten machen kann und sich nicht um Ego oder Profilierung oder andere Dinge schert, sondern nur um die Aufgabe.
Da gibt es das Zitat aus Dune irgendwie, das ist der beste Anführer, der es nicht sein will, tatsächlich. Das deckt sich ganz gut. Wir haben ein bisschen Nerdtum noch reingebracht.
Und das habe ich ja auch immer gesagt, hey, lasst uns einen besseren finden, der mehr Know-how, der mehr Zeit, der mehr Ressource hat, der vielleicht noch 28 Millionen bei in irgendwelchen Kellern rumzuliegen hat, oder, oder, oder, der auf die Zeit, auf das Amt die bessere Lösung für den Verein ist.
Sofort.
Also den mit den 28 Millionen hat man nicht gefunden, aber Kay Bernstein hat seinen Hut in den Ring geworfen. Harald, gehe ich recht in der Annahme, dass seine Bekanntgabe der Kandidatur, die ja – er ist ja Marketingprofi gewesen – perfekt orchestriert war, mit einer eigenen Webseite wie www.hartanahide.de hieß die, und einer Vision, die er dort für Hartha entwickelt hat. Ist er da auch zum ersten Mal auf deinem Radar erschienen?
Genau, und zwar quasi aus dem Nichts. Ich kannte ihn ja so nicht. Ich bin ja auch kein Hertha-Fan, sondern nur Beobachter aus der Distanz heraus. Und als das dann plötzlich sichtbar wurde, in dieser, sagen wir mal, Großwetterlage, in dieser Situation, in der der Verein sich da befand, mit diesen ganzen Grabencampen, den ganzen Auseinandersetzungen. Boah, da dachte man von außen betrachtet sofort, das ist jetzt aber mal ein Zeichen, das ist jetzt aber mal ein Lichtblick, weil das kann ein Systemwechsel herbeiführen. Und zwar genau an der Stelle, wo es in Deutschland jetzt das größte Ausmuffelzeichen setzt, nämlich genau in der Situation, in der sich die Hertha damals befand und wir alle anderen Vereine noch sehr, sehr weit entfernt waren. Und dass man dort jetzt nach diesen ganzen Geschichten so ein Zeichen setzt, indem man so eine Kandidatur erst einmal bekannt gibt und dann zwar von jemandem, der das, was er eben dem Othon auch gesagt hat, auch tatsächlich lebt, also diese Zurückhaltung, diese Uneigennützigkeit, dieses sich in den Dienst der Sache stellen und das nicht als Sprungbrett für irgendwelche anderen Geschichten nutzend. Das hat man dem sofort abgenommen und auch während seiner ganzen Amtszeit gesehen. Also, was so bei mir im Gedächtnis ist, so als Bild von Kay Bernstein sind immer, wie er da so auftritt, immer mit so einer Trainingsjacke. Der zieht dann da kein Jacket an, sondern ist dann mit so einer blauen Trainingsjacke da immer unterwegs und kam dann mir auch immer extrem zurückhaltend so vor. Ist dann ein Gespräch hier und da vertieft, wenn man ihn auf der Tribüne gesehen hat oder so, aber niemand, der dann da so die Öffentlichkeit sucht, um eine Bühne zu haben, um der Welt zu erklären, was er da eigentlich für Tolles macht. Das hört man von dem oder hat man von ihm quasi nie gehört, sondern hat immer sachlich darüber gesprochen. Und eben den Rotoren da fiel mir spontan das Stichwort Verantwortung ein. Also er ist Mitglied dieses Vereins, er ist unzufrieden und er stellt dann sich, aber auch anderen die Frage nach der Verantwortung und Verantwortungsübernahme und zeigt sich dann bereit, genau das zu tun, aber nicht so nach dem Motto, na toll, ich habe diese Biografie, ich bin jetzt genau der Richtige, was Tausende um ihn herum gesagt haben, du bist es, du musst es machen. Selbst Leute, die ihn nicht kannten wie ich, gedacht, was ist aber eine Lösung, sondern der dann immer noch sagt, es kann aber auch jemand anderes machen, der da besser geeignet ist für diese Situation in diesem Moment. Und da kann ich sagen, das ist für mich so eine Blaupause, durchaus romantisch verklärt, aber eine Blaupause für Menschen, die Funktionen im deutschen Fußball übernehmen wollen, macht es so wie der. Uneigennützig bringt euch der Sache wegen ein und nicht um irgendwelche Geschäfte zu machen oder um euch ins Rampenlicht zu rücken, sondern ganz uneigennützig und offen und nicht mit so einer Überhöhung nach dem Motto, das kann ja eigentlich nur ich machen. Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz groß gewesen. Das wurde auch bundesweit damals so wahrgenommen, weil man sofort gemerkt hat, das hat eine realistische Chance.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir zustimmen würde, dass es genau so wahrgenommen wurde, weil im Nachhinein würde ich auch sagen, dass er uneigennützig und es nicht für sich selbst gemacht hat. Aber gerade weil man dann seine Namen kannte, hätte es sehr, sehr gut sein können, dass es jemand ist, der erstmal nur ins Rampenlicht wollte, denn da ist er ja auch hingekommen. Und ich weiß, Marc, dass auch bei vielen Herthanerinnen und Herthanern, bei allen Dingen, die man da gut finden konnte, bei der Vision, die auf wirherthana.de stand, aber das war halt auch sehr viel Marketinggespräch, wie man schon hunderttausendmal gehört hat im Fußball. Was glaubst du denn, wann hat sich das gedreht, dass man gesehen hat, okay, dieses erstmal nur eine Vision aufschreiben könnte tatsächlich mit Leben gefüllt werden?
Also einmal möchte ich dir nochmal beipflichten, tatsächlich gab es nicht nur Juhu-Schreie, sondern auch eine gesunde Skepsis aufgrund… Also man muss sagen, Kay Bernstein, für meine Generation, ich kannte diesen Namen nicht und andere in meinem Umfeld kannten ihn auch nicht, weil er eben 2006 aus der Szene verschonet ist. Wir kannten die Harlequins, wir kannten… Also wir kannten eigentlich sein Hinterlassenschaft, sein Machtwerk, kannten wir, bevor wir ihn namentlich kannten. Das heißt, für diese Generation war er eben nicht namentlich greifbar und war komplett neu. Und die Skepsis war schon da, denn wir müssen uns auch kurz an die Zeit erinnern unter Paul Keuter, einem der Geschäftsführer von Hertha BSC, in dem es sehr viel Marketing. Helfen konnte. Und dann hat er diese Kampagne, die ja erstmal, wie wir gesagt haben, durchstilisiert, er hat es mit Leben gefüllt. Und ein großes Projekt beispielsweise war, er hat auf dem Gelände seiner Firma, hatte er einen Workshop abgehalten über einen ganzen Tag. Und Hertha. Eigentlich ist es eine Veranstaltung, wo ich eigentlich meine Vision präsentieren will, sondern er hat nur zugehört und hat die Leute machen lassen und das für sich mitgenommen. Und hat ja später dann auch ein Zehn-Punkt-Programm vorgestellt, in dem auch Erkenntnisse aus diesen Workshops mit eingearbeitet waren. Und ich glaube, dass er dann sehr schnell durch solche Aktionen – übrigens sein Gegenkandidat Frank Steffel, über den werden wir vielleicht auch noch ein, zwei Worte verlieren, weil er den krassen Gegensatz zu Kay Bernstein irgendwo auch bildet – Der war vor Ort bei diesem Workshop, saß aber die ganze Zeit nur daneben, hat sich mit den Journalisten unterhalten, die da waren und die ganze Zeit auf sein Handy geguckt. Daraufhin wurde er auf Facebook damals auf seiner Seite kritisch angeschrieben von einem Hertha-Fan, der meinte, es kann ja eigentlich nicht sein, dass man da hingeht und sich nicht einbringt und dass er nur auf sein Handy geguckt hätte, woraufhin er souverän wie eh und je ein Screenshot seiner Anrufliste darunter gepostet hat und gesagt hat, ja guck mal, ich hab in der Zeit ja gar nicht telefoniert, ich kann ja gar nicht ganz an deinem Handy gewesen sein. Kleine Anekdote für zwischendurch. Aber es zeigt auch schon, wie die beiden Kandidaten mit Menschen geredet haben. Und ich glaube, dass Kay Bernstein, er hat ja seine Kandidatur auch als frühester Kandidat eingebracht. Die Zeit bis zur Wahl hatte es durchgängig mit Leben gefüllt, mit guten Interviews, mit Workshops, mit Begegnungen. Er war greifbar und das hat dazu geführt, dass er ein Profil gewonnen hat und dass Leute eben nicht nur das Gefühl hatten, er macht es aufgrund des vermeintlichen Ruhms des Amtes weiterer Möglichkeiten, Vernetzungsmöglichkeiten, sondern er macht es, weil er sich in den Dienst seines Vereins stellen müsste. Und dass da dieses mit Leben füllen, das war der springende Punkt.
Also Frank Steffel, CDU-Politiker, war der Gegenkandidat, saß lange im Bundestag und war im Grunde – es gab noch einen Dritten, aber der wollte eigentlich eher zeigen, dass es auch noch eine weitere Alternative geben könnte, ich glaube, da tut man jetzt gar nicht so unrecht. Und das, was du sagst, ist aber, glaube ich, ganz wichtig. Also Bekanntgabe der Kandidatur war sogar bei 11 Freunde, nicht bei einem großen anderen Medium. Kay Bernstein war auch Zeit seines Lebens aus guten Gründen sehr, sehr kritisch gegenüber dem Axel-Springer-Verlag. Allein das macht ihn noch mal doppelt sympathisch. Alle, die dieses Format hier hören, wissen, wie ich zu dieser Einschätzung komme. Und er hat aber sehr viele Interviews gegeben. Also zum Beispiel alles, was wir jetzt im Streamer mit Felicio gehört haben, das waren viele der bisherigen O-Töne, die ich gespielt habe. Das war vor der Wahl, vor der Mitgliederversammlung, die dann stattgefunden hat. Da hat er sich drei Stunden, 15, den Fragen von Felicio gestellt und aber auch den des Publikums und hat da eben genauso gesprochen, wie wir ihn bisher gehört haben, viele andere Interviews, die er gegeben hat. Die kamen dann erst, als er Präsident war, wo er dann aber noch mal rückgeblickt hat auf diese Zeit. Und zwei Themen waren da natürlich vor allem wichtig. Das eine war, warum will er das machen? Und da musste man ihm vertrauen, dass er es nicht für sich macht, sondern für die Sache. Und das andere Thema, und das wurde eben vor allem von gewissen Boulevardmedien großgemacht, ein Ultra. Oh Gott, oh Gott, jetzt der Verfall des Abendlandes. Und mit diesen Vorurteilen, mit denen Ultras ja generell zu kämpfen haben, hatte Kay Bernstein auch nach seiner erfolgreichen Wahl noch zu kämpfen. Und da möchte ich jetzt gerne den nächsten Ton von ihm einsprechen, weil er zum einen, finde ich, ganz gut beschreibt, welches Problem eigentlich die Ultras in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung haben. Und dann hören wir uns danach dann aber auch noch an, wie sich sein Fäntum eigentlich verändert hat. Denn du hast es ja gesagt, 2006 war er im Grunde erst mal raus aus der organisierten Szene. Und wir sprechen jetzt über die Kandidatur im Jahr 2022. Aber das hat nicht davor zurückgehalten, da erstmal Ängste zu schüren. Denn so ist das eben einfach bei Ultras.
Es ist natürlich sehr öffentlich geprägt, das Wort Ultra. Und es ist in der Öffentlichkeit sehr negativ besetzt, weil die Berichterstattung oftmals nicht differenziert, was ist Hooliganismus, was ist Ultra, was ist Fender sein, was ist Kategorie A, B, C, wie es die Sicherheitsbehörden kategorisieren. Sondern es wird immer relativ viel pauschalisiert in einen Topf geworfen. Und Ultra ist letztendlich eine Definition darüber hinaus. Also mehr machen als das Normale. Und ich finde, Ultra ist jetzt nicht per se derjenige, der für sich meint, Ultra zu sein, sondern das sind so viele mehr. Wenn du jetzt seit so vielen Jahren diesen Podcast hast, kannst du auch ein Podcast-Ultra sein, weil du mehr machst als die anderen.
Ich bin ein Podcast-Ultra, echt.
Und dieses Ultra bedeutet letztendlich Aufopferung, Loyalität und die Bereitschaft auch – in der Start-up-Welt würde man sagen – die letzte Meile gehen, diesen letzten Meter machen, diese fünf Prozent mehr geben.
Was heißt Aufopferung?
Eine Aufopferung heißt schon, sich für diesen Verein, für die Gemeinschaft, sich aufzuopfern, indem man das Wertvollste gibt, was man hat, nämlich seine Zeit. Und seine Emotion und sein Engagement im Sinne von, wenn wir Choreografien gemalt haben, dann waren wir der Jugendklubersatz. Wenn wir bei den Gesprächen einer Choreografiestunde gemerkt haben, der Junge hat Probleme in der Schule oder in der Ausbildung, dann haben wir ihm geholfen. Wenn wir gehört haben, der hat Probleme, die Bewerbung zu schreiben, dann konnten wir auch da sagen, okay, komm, wir helfen dir. Also wir waren über die Choreografie-Ausarbeitung sehr nah dran an den Jungs und an unseren Freunden und konnten somit den Ersatz für die fehlende pädagogische Entwicklung oftmals geben. Und das ist dann halt auch ultra, weil ultra schon auch ganz viel soziale Aspekte mit einbringt. Ein bisschen, das finde ich, hat man dann schon mit den Grünen aus der früheren Zeit. Sie sind auch ein bisschen das Korrektiv und der Stachel, der oftmals sagt, auch manchmal zu sehr überspitzt, wie ich heute finde, aber der sagt, an der und der Stelle müsstet ihr genauer hinsehen, seid ihr euch sicher, was ihr da macht. Sie sagen schonungslos ihre Meinung und das ist dann in einer Demokratie auch ganz klar auszuhalten. Und ultra ist was ganz Positives, wie ich finde, weil es die Begeisterungsfähigkeit zeigt und das soziale Engagement vereint in der Loyalität zu seinem Verein.
Also Ultras als das über das Normale hinausgehende, diejenigen, die das Wertvollste geben, was sie haben, nämlich ihre Zeit. Ultras als Ort der sozialen Interaktion haben wir vorhin schon kurz angerissen und aber auch Harald Ultras als Korrektiv, die dann auch der Stachelimpf Fleisch sein können. Er hat relativ oft in vielen Interviews diesen Vergleich mit der Anti-Atomkraft-Bewegung und mit der Anfangszeit der Grünen gemacht. Wann, Harald, lesen wir das, was Kay Bernstein hier gesagt hat in deinem nächsten Lehrbuch als Definition, das sind Ultras? Oder hat dir da doch was gefehlt?
Nein, nein. Also er hat es vor allem auch mit wenigen Wörtern exakt auf den Punkt gebracht. Also die letzte Meile gehen, etwas mehr machen, nicht etwas mehr machen, deutlich mehr machen, sich vertiefen. Das ist das, was bei mir jetzt so hingeklieben ist in deiner Ultra-Definition. Und da ist auch nach meinem Dafürhalten der Kern des Ganzen auf dem Punkt gebracht. Und dieser Stachel, den die Ultras, sagen wir mal sportpolitisch, gesellschaftspolitisch, innerhalb der Fußballkultur setzen, den kann man ja nur setzen, wenn das Feld dafür bereitet ist, dass mal jemand fixen muss, dass mal jemand Opposition einnehmen muss, weil doch offensichtlich irgendeine Entwicklung im Profifußball in Gange ist, seit vielen Jahrzehnten, die uns so auf der Werte-Ebene nicht mehr wirklich gefällt, wo wir sagen, oh, dazu braucht es noch ein Gegengewicht. Und wenn man an der Stelle angelangt ist, dann wird es für mich als Sportwissenschaftler hoch spannend und hoch interessant, denn ich bin eben kein Sportökonom oder kein Management-Experte, sondern ich begreife den Sport in allererster Linie als soziales Thema, als historisch gewachsenes Thema und eben auch als Bildungsthemen. Sport ist etwas, was in seiner Grundstruktur ironisch verandert ist. Du machst es nur des Sportsbildens. Du versuchst ihn nicht zu verzwecken, obwohl der Sport gerade weil er so frei ist, weil er so einen Eigenwert hat, sich ja wunderbar gut verzwecken lässt. Aber der eigentliche Wert des Sports liegt darin, sich in die Tätigkeit, sei es jetzt leichter, die Kornen schwimmen oder ein Fußballspiel, zu vertiefen. Und der einzige Grund, weshalb ich mich vertiefe, ist das Spiel an sich. Es ist also zweckfrei in seiner Wertestruktur. Und das spielen die Kinder auf dem Bolzplatz. Das ist auch das Ideal für Sport in der Stunde, dass man an eine Sache herangeführt werden soll. Und man soll dann quasi Feuer fangen, für die Sache brennen und die Sache soll was mit dir machen, weil du dich in diese Sache vertiebst. Und genau dieses Moment, das scheint im professionellen Fußball, so wie er organisiert ist, wie man damit auch Geld verdienen kann, ein Stück weit an den Rand gedrängt zu sein, dazu sehen wir zu wenig. Möglicherweise ist das bei den Spielern so, aber es fällt auf, dass dies drum herum, das Geld verdienen, das Geld machen, das vernetzen und so weiter, dass das viel wichtiger geworden ist. Und dann wird der eigentliche Kern des Sports ein Stück weit ins Hauptzeits gestellt. Und da ist ganz interessant, dass dann genau in diesen Prozess hinein sich diese Gegenbewegung, sprich die Ultras etabliert haben, die möglicherweise, ohne es zu wissen, genau diesen Moment aufgreifen und dann quasi sich vertiefen wollen. In die – ich sage das jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen – in die wahre, in die kleine Lehre des Sports, dass man den Sport eben nicht instrumentalisiert, dass man ihn nicht verzweckt, sondern dass man für die Suppe brennt und das Bedürfnis hat, sich immer weiter, immer weiter dabei zu vertiefen und das ist auch das Geniale am Sport, diese Möglichkeit, sich zu vertiefen, die ist endlos. Selbst wenn ich richtig gut spielen kann, ich kann es noch besser machen, ich kann es noch mal wiederholen und noch besser machen und auch das Begreifen, das Beu- wachten eines Spiels ist von dem gleichen Momentum getragen, dass ich mich in die Problemlösung, die die Spieler unten auf dem Platz machen, immer weiter vertiefe, dass ich in meinem Kopf Modelle entwerfe, wie man es anders machen müsste, dass ich die mit meinen Kumpels aus der Kurve oder auf der Arbeit in der Uni, an der Schule oder wo auch immer, dass ich mich darüber streite, wie es denn besser geht. Also dieses Vertiefen, es geht immer mehr. Und das halte ich als etwas enorm Wertvolles, weil es ganz viele Parallelen auch zu denen aufweist, dass ich unter Bildung bestehe. Bildung, egal in welchem Bereich, ist immer ein Vertiefen, ein Weckel von Interessen, ein Anfaffen eines Feuers, was mit meiner Altun etwas macht, was bei mir den Wunsch auslöst, ich vertiefe mich noch mehr und noch mehr. Und dass so etwas im Fußball in der Kurve entsteht, ist für mich ein gigantisches Ereignis, ein superspannendes Phänomen, weil wir dann auch sagen können, da stehen möglicherweise in diesen Fan-Protesten auch Anwälte für den wahren Kern des Sports. Das sind immer wieder mit ihren Stimmen, mit ihren Protestaktionen einfordern und dann dieses Spiel haben. Und in diesem Spiel mit und gegen die Chefetagen des deutschen Fußballs, mit diesem Spiel erinnern sie permanent an die Frage, worum geht es im Kern? Was wollen wir machen? Und sie möchten darauf aufpassen und darauf achten, dass der Fußball nicht verkauft wird vor andere Interessen, dass der Fußball nicht zu sehr verzweckt wird, sondern dass dieser Kern des Spiels – Gewinnen und Verlieren, Solidarität, Fair Play – dass dieser Kern gewarnt bleibt. Und das ist dann eine Botschaft an alle Verbände und alle Vereine, hört euch das an und überlegt in eurem Handeln, was nicht einfach ist. Ihr müsst ja natürlich auch wirtschaftlich denken, hört euch das an und überlegt, wie könnt ihr in eurem Tun diesen vermeidlichen Kern des Sports bewahren. Du weißt, es klingt jetzt hier und da ein Stück weit romantisch, aber das lässt sich theoretisch sehr schön herleiten. Und ich meine, solche Themen, die sollten wir viel häufiger diskutieren, gerade weil wir die aus eigener Erfahrung immer wieder aufspüren und da etwas dran finden. Deshalb sollten wir es aus meiner Sicht zur Sprache bringen und uns dann über Werte im Sport, über Philosophie des Sports, Soziologie des Sports darüber sollten wir uns unterhalten und nicht zu schnell immer gleich auf dieses Vermarktung- und Geldsthema kommen.
Jetzt ist es ja aber andererseits auch nicht so, dass die Ultras mit Taktiktafeln im Block stehen und jeden Spielzug durchanalysieren, sondern man könnte ihnen doch auch vorwerfen, dass die Ultras ja ihr eigenes Spiel machen, das eigentlich auch losgelöst von Gewinnen und Verlieren funktioniert. Ist das dann vielleicht schon der Kern dessen, warum es manchmal so schwierig ist, für andere Arten von Fußballfans zu verstehen, was die Ultras da eigentlich machen? Weil diejenigen, die quasi wollen, dass alles so bleibt, wie es ist, was übrigens auch bedeutet, dass sie eine Rolle spielen im Stadion, also es könnte hier auch um Selbsterhalt gehen und zwar nicht des Fußballs, sondern dieser kleinen Gruppe, wenn man böswillig sein wollen würde. Aber weil die sich ja eigentlich genau losgelöst haben vom Spiel und ihr eigenes Spiel draus machen und oft genug, da muss man ja nur irgendwelche Kurvenblätter lesen, wird dann in der Nachbetrachtung, ja, also wir haben drei nur auf den Sack bekommen, aber Mann, haben wir die niedergesungen, war richtig geil in der Auswärtsfahrt. Und da kann ich schon auch verstehen, dass das für andere schwer ist nachzuvollziehen.
Das ist eine Frage der Identifikation. Weshalb feiert man sich da selbst? Weshalb inszeniert man sich da selbst? Weshalb tanzt man? Weshalb choreografiert man? Weshalb malt man Plakate und so weiter? Und weshalb geht man darin so sehr auf? Das ist das Spiel, der Spieltakt, der Anlass dafür, dass man sich auf diese Art und Weise selbst inszeniert und mit einer beeindruckenden Leidenschaft und Emotionalität den ganzen Sache, Choreografie und so weiter vertieft. Und das ist für mich der Spiegel, den man Richtung Spielfeld hält und dann quasi auf so einer symbolischen Ebene sagt, guck mal zu.
Also wir geben alles, tut ihr es auch.
Ja, ganz genau. Wir geben alles, und zwar 24-Siebel, nach diesem Prinzip rund um die Uhr. Und wir erwarten das von euch auch. Und wir sind auch bereit, und dann wird es spannend, wir sind auch bereit zu switchen, unsere Choreografie mal hinten anzustellen, wenn dann da unten etwas Spektakuläres passiert. Vielleicht nicht gerade, wenn die Choreografie gerade so läuft, aber perspektivisch im Saisonverlauf können wir uns in unserer Selbstinstituierung auch zurücknehmen. Aber wir sind immer wieder der Motor, der daran erinnert, worum es eigentlich geht. Es geht um dieses Sich-Vertiefen. Und das erwarten wir bedingungslos von allen, die im Verein Verantwortung haben, und vor allem von allen, die im Verein Fußball spielen. Ihr sollt euch gefälligst vertiefen, und zwar 24 Stunden am Tag, sieben Tage die Woche, so wie wir das hier oben auch machen. Und diese Spiegelmetapher, die finde ich hochinteressant, vor allem in Kombination mit der Zeitperspektive, dass wir das über einen Saisonverlauf hinkriegen können. Und da lohnt es sich, bestimmte Fanszenen, Ultraszenen in bestimmten Vereinen, in bestimmten Spielzeiten genauer anzuschauen. Wann haben sie dann ihre Selbstinszenierung mal aufgebrochen? Wann ist es mal ungeswitcht, sodass mehr Aufmerksamkeit im Spiel war? Und wann – und das sind die großen Momente des Fußballs – Wann wird das Stadeln zu einer Einheit? Und da ist so, ich bin da jetzt auch geografisch gesehen relativ häufig so am Eintracht Frankfurt dran und da kann man in diesem Europa spielen bei der Eintracht. Da kann man dieses Bier und Einheit sehen, da kann man dieses Umswitchen im Saisonverlauf mehrfach beobachten und rekonstruieren und das finde ich eine überspannende Quelle über die, wo wir perspektivisch mehr ins Gespräch kommen sollen. Weil das ist das, was Fußball für mich ausmacht, das ist diese Leidenschaft und diese Chance, sowohl in der Kurve wie auch auf dem Spielfeld, dass ich mich als immer Mensch dort vertiefen kann. Dass ich mich dort ausleben kann und in einer Gemeinschaft noch mehr vertiefen kann, so sehr, dass wir als Mannschaft auf dem Platz zusammenwachsen und dann auch übermächtige Mannschaften die Klee zwingen können, einfach weil wir als Team näher an der Sache dran sind, als die anderen.
Da gab es einen ganz prägenen Moment auch bei Hertha in dieser Saison nach dem Magdeburg-Spiel. Der Kurvenvorsänger Kreisel durfte quasi runter zum Feld nach Apfel. Hertha hatte dieses Spiel spektakulär mit 4 zu 6.
Das war ein Tennis-Ergebnis, so habe ich es mir gemerkt.
Genau. Es war ein 4 zu 6, das man verloren hatte. Daraufhin durfte Vorsänger Kreisel runter zur Mannschaft. Und wie gesagt, wir denken, dieses ihr legt gefälligst eure Trikots in die Kurve ist ja eigentlich, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, nicht ewig her. Und Hertha TV produziert ja eine eigene Doku über diese Saison. Da ist das als Videoschnipsel sehr gut sichtbar und hörbar, wie er zur Mannschaft redet. Und ich glaube, was Harald noch meint mit Siegen und Verlieren, das geht manchmal über das eine Spiel hinaus. Es geht eher um Tendenzen. Und Hertha hatte dieses Spiel verloren, aber die Kurve hatte auch in diesem Spiel wieder erkannt, dass da etwas zusammenwächst auf dem Feld. Und dass es eine Identifikation der Spieler untereinander gibt, aber auch mit dem Verein, die man in den Jahren zuvor überhaupt nicht gespürt hatte. Oto und Kreisel, wir erholen uns gerade erst von dieser ganzen Investoren-Scheiße. Und sprach dann zu einzelnen Spielern und weckte so Assoziationen, guckte beispielsweise Bence und Martin Lader in die Augen und sagte, ihr drei Brüder, geil. Und guckte zu Fabian Reese und sagte, du, Flohmarkt, ist ein bisschen plakativ schon, aber er nannte Eigenschaften, die er mit ihnen verbindet. Und das zeigt eine gewisse Identifikation, das hättest du mit gewissen Spielern der vorherigen Jahre nicht tun können. Da hätte er auf jemanden gezeigt und hätte gesagt, ja, du bist auch dabei. Und das zeigte eine generelle Entwicklung. Zum einen, dass Kreisel überhaupt die Chance eröffnet wird, runter zur Mannschaft zu gehen. Das ist ja alles andere als selbstverständlich. Zeigte auch das neue Verhältnis zwischen Vereinsführung und organisierter Szene. Auch das Kreisel in einem der Heimspiele diese Saison das Mikrofon bekam, um das gesamte Stadion anzuzünden. Das normalerweise passiert ja auch nur in der Ostkurve. Und da zeigt sich das, was Harald, glaube ich, meint, über das eine Spiel hinaus zu sehen. Da gibt es eine Tendenz und man wächst zusammen und die Identifikation wächst wieder zusammen. Und das hatte Kay Bernstein eben auch erkannt, um da den Bogen wieder zu schlagen.
Ganz kurz dazu, Fabian Reese ist dafür bekannt, dass er auf Flohmärkten in Berlin flaniert. Genau, das ist das perfekte Wort dafür. Aber natürlich denken jetzt nicht alle so wie wir gerade über Ultras und so, wie es auch Kay Bernstein gesagt hat. Und deswegen wurde eben diese Nähe zu den Ultras, die wurde eben als Nachteil ausgelegt. Es wurde so grob die Drohkulisse aufgebaut. Achtung, jetzt übernehmen diese Vollkaoten den Verein.
Der Pyro-Präsident.
Das ist ein geflügeltes Wort in der Hertha-Szene.
Über Pyro-Technik werden wir später noch sprechen. Da hat er nämlich auch interessante – Gott sei Dank hat er das erst später gesagt, was er dazu gesagt hat. Aber jetzt hören wir uns mal kurz an. Wie hat sich denn Kay Bernstein eigentlich vor seiner Wahl selbst definiert? Und das zeigt ja auch, wenn man genauer hinguckt, ist es dann oft anders als eben der Ultra-Kay, der jetzt Präsident werden will.
Wenn man sich den Anhänger-Club Oberring, Manne-Sangel, Helmut Friberg und diese ganze alte Bande anguckt, die jetzt 60, 70, aber die sind immer noch da. Und die sind da wegen ihren Freundschaften. Und natürlich habe ich ganz viele kommen und gehen gesehen. Und ich war früher schon einer – und das war ja unsere erste Generation – ich war einer, der immer das große Ganze gesehen hat. Wenn ich oben in die Kurve rein bin, habe ich eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, bis ich unten da angekommen bin, weil ich erst mal mit jedem geredet habe, übertrieben gesagt. Und mir war das große Ganze immer wichtiger als das einzelne Teil der Gruppe sozusagen. Und zur Situation heute ist es so, dass ich natürlich noch ein paar Leute kenne und ein paar Leute noch da sind aus meiner Generation. Aber meine Freunde sitzen mit mir auf der Haupttribüne oder sitzen im Oberring und sind da unten gar nicht mehr. Und von daher ist das Verständnis eher da und es ist eher ein Ich bin Herr Thana und wenn André von 1892 hilft, sagt, ich brauche ein neues Lager oder ich weiß nicht, wie ich hier meine Suppentour mache, dann ist es mein Selbstverständnis zu sagen, wie kann ich dir helfen, weil du machst was Gutes und wir sind Herr Thana. Und das ist eher mein Verständnis der Ich bin Herr Thana und helfe, wo ich kann, ob das bei Fußballturnieren ist, bei 1892 hilft und so weiter. Aber ich bin nicht in der aktiven Fan-Szene involviert, weil dann ist man nach 16 Jahren einfach raus, weil die sagen, naja, der Typ ist auch vergänglich und all das, was du früher mal gemacht hast, ob Spendetbecher, ob Fan-Kongress, ob all das, was du mal gemacht hast, wird dir hinterher doch sowieso nicht gedankt. Also da ruft heute keiner mehr an und sagt, geil, du warst Freitagabend in Kaiserslautern und hast 4-0 verloren. Das macht man doch für sich und nicht für einen anderen. Von daher ist die Zeit und der Austausch der einzelnen Generation, ich würde sagen, wenn ich jetzt in die Kurve gehe, kenne ich vielleicht noch 200 Leute.
Ja, nur noch 200 Leute kennt der Harald. Das ist natürlich…
Heilig.
Ja, also da wird natürlich Herbert Heiner vom FC Bayern sagen, das ist ja albern. Aber ich glaube, das zeigt ganz gut welches… Kay Bernstein hat dieses Verständnis, was wir drei, glaube ich, auch haben. Ich meine, wir haben das selbst an uns schon erlebt oder wir haben es auch bei Freunden gesehen. Man wächst an verschiedene Positionen im Stadion. Und selbst derjenige, der unten in der Kurve steht, der sitzt eben irgendwann auf der Haupttribüne und gehört vielleicht irgendwann auch mal zur Sektion Mecker-Rentner. Das ist eben die normale, die domalen Station, die ein Fan haben kann. Und dennoch, obwohl er das sehr gut erklärt, wie sich das bei ihm verändert hat und dass er eben nicht mehr – also, sehr klar, dass er nicht zum aktuellen Vorsänger hingehen kann und sagen kann, hier, übrigens, ich war mal vor 16 Jahren eine große Nummer, ihr singt jetzt mal Folgendes oder hört jetzt mal auf mit euren frechen Transparenten, dass jeden, der irgendwie mit Ultrakultur zu tun hat, der weiß, dass das nicht da ist. Aber dennoch sehen wir ja hier, er kennt immer noch so viele in der Kurve und er nennt die 200 und sagt, ja, sind nur noch 200. Also deswegen, und das zeigt er trotzdem aber schon, wie besonders das ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass man hier jemanden hat, der sich dann zum Präsidenten hat wählen lassen, der eben alles so ein bisschen in sich vereint. Er war mal in der Kurve, er war mal alles Fahrer, er sah später auf der Haupttribüne, er war dann die ganze Zeit im WIP-Bereich unterwegs, hat sein Unternehmen aufgebaut und so weiter und so fort. Ein bisschen von allem.
Wer soll beantworten?
Entschuldigung, ich habe die ganze Zeit Harald angeguckt, aber das konntet ihr nicht, ich gucke euch ja beide an.
Ich habe dazu aber ein passendes Zitat von Kay Bernstein, der auch, glaube ich, vor seiner Wahl auf der Bühne stand und sagte, ich kann nicht alles, kann ich nicht. So, aber als was sich Kay Bernstein immer gesehen hat, ist Projektmanager. Also jemand, der weiß, wie er Leute bekommt, die es können. Das sollte ja seine Amtszeit in den anderthalb Jahren auch durchaus zeigen, dass er fähig war, Leute zu finden, die den Job machen können. Für weniger Geld, mit mehr Identifikation, mit besserer Kommunikation, wie auch immer. Und es nicht eben die typischen alten Hasen sein müssen. Ich habe ja vorhin drüber geredet, dass vor allem das Establishment die Nase gerümpft hat, als er gewählt wurde. Weil da, glaube ich, auch Leute um bestehende Verhältnisse gebangt haben. Und dass da jemand kommt, der vielleicht einen anderen Blick drauf hat und sagt, naja, gut, dich kennt jetzt vielleicht keiner, aber du müsstest das eigentlich auch kennen. Vielleicht sogar, weil er die Leute aus vergangenen Tagen kennt. Auch das sollte ein Thema werden. Aber um zum Ursprungspunkt zurückzukommen, Kay Bernstein hat sich eben als jemand betrachtet, der alles kann und alles vereint, der aber vereinen kann und dafür die richtigen Leute finden kann. Und das beschreibt es vielleicht auch ganz gut, dass er überall mal im Stadion saß. Also hat er überall so ein paar Gedanken zu und kann überall ein paar Leute finden, die ähnlich denken.
Er wäre das perfekte Forschungsobjekt gewesen, Harald.
Auf jeden Fall ist, was das betrifft, natürlich ein Musterbeispiel in wehererlei Hinsicht, was einzigartiges, was er da gelebt hat, was er da gemacht hat und vor allem auch, was er da vorhatte. Und es ist ja superspannend, dass wir jetzt quasi im Nachhinein alles rekonstruieren, wie alles nun so gelaufen ist. Das ist ja nochmal eine andere Perspektive, als die jeweils aktuelle Perspektive, aus der heraus er und sein Umfeld dann bestimmte Entscheidungen getroffen haben, bestimmte Homepages gebaut haben und auch bestimmte Interviews so gegeben haben. So ist es jetzt eine Geschichte, die abgeschlossen ist, die wir analysieren können und aus der heraus wir Schlussfolgerung können. Und eine Schlussfolgerung kann sein, dass das Modell, dass jemand aus der Co-Doc Präsident eines großen Vereins wird, dass dieses Modell durchaus funktionieren kann. Und vor allem kann man sehen, was so die DNA eines Clubs eigentlich ausmacht und sein kann. Das ist nämlich tatsächlich, dass man zwar Verantwortung übernimmt, dass man gute Ideen hat, dass man sich eindringt, dass man permanent hilft und und und. Also immer in Aktion ist, aber gleichzeitig in der Lage ist, sich als Person immer wieder zurückzunehmen und hinten einzustellen und einzuordnen, weil man das Ganze – das hat er in diesen letzten Urtonen aus meiner Sicht so schön komponiert – weil man das Ganze natürlich nur für sich macht. Zwar nur für sich nach innen. Deshalb fährt man nach Kaiserslautern und folgiert da 4-0, wie er das da gesagt hat. Da fragt eigentlich hinterher keiner mehr, warum warst du da? Da kann man auch nichts großartig vorzeigen, das macht man nur für sich. Für das Erlebnis, was einem guttut. Und wenn dieser Modus erst einmal so in einem drin ist, wenn man da Feuer gefangen hat dafür, dann macht man es auch immer wieder. Und das halte ich für enorm wertvoll. Und da bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass wir in allen Kurven dieser Republik Menschen haben, die genau das auch können. Jetzt jeder wieder auf seine eigene Art und Weise, aber die in der Lage sind, Verantwortung für eine größere Gruppe zu übernehmen und sich selbst dabei zurücknehmen. Und das sind für mich die Führungspersönlichkeiten, die wir im deutschen Fußball dringender denn je brauchen, weil das klassische Modell ganz anders herumgestrickt ist. Wir suchen immer nach Anführern, die irgendwelche persönlichen Qualitäten haben, die irgendetwas mitbringen und dann von oben nach unten einen Verein nach ihrer Idee strukturieren. Und bei Bernstein hat das ganz offensichtlich einen anderen Weg gemacht. Er konnte zuhören, wie Marc vorhin auch zum Thema Workshop auf seinem Workgelände erzählt hat. Er wurde da so einen Workshop initiiert und sich dann nicht als Präsidentschaftskandidat in dem Sinne präsentiert, sondern zuhört, sich nur jitzen macht und dann hinterher auch was rausnimmt aus diesen Arbeitsgruppen, die dort gebildet wurden, aus diesen Diskussionen und sich dann eben zurücknehmen kann. Das finde ich für Führungspersönlichkeit. Neudeutsch sagt man ja dann immer Leadership. Da gibt es ganz tolle Leadership-Konfette. Und da meine ich, die müssen wir nicht aus der Wirtschaft oder der amerikanischen Psychologie zu uns importieren, sondern wir müssen einfach die Augen aufmachen, die Ohren aufmachen, in die Kurven gehen, aber auch auf die Tribüne gehen und mit den Menschen sprechen, die dort den Fußball für sich inszenieren, die den Fußball verfolgen und die verstanden haben, wie das Ganze in seinem Kern funktioniert. Im Kern ist das ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt, das mir vor allem deshalb so gut gefällt, weil ich da die Gelegenheit habe, das große Ganze wahrzunehmen und etwas für mich zu machen, um mich gleichzeitig als Person zurückzunehmen. Da meine ich, dass das so ein Profil, was wir zukünftig bei der Analyse anderer Präsidenten, die jetzt nicht nur bei der Hertha sind, auch in andere Vereine kommen werden, was wir jetzt als Maßstab immer mal auch auslegen können, mal prüfen können und auch Menschen ermuntern können aus den Kurven, von den Tribünen oder aus anderen Bereichen. Überlegt mal, ob jeder da das Zeug dazu hat. Bei Bernstein hat gezeigt, dass man damit Großes machen kann. Macht es ihm nach.
Und er wollte einen Umschwung einleiten. Ich würde sagen, wir kommen jetzt dann mal zu dieser Mitgliederversammlung. Ich möchte noch kurz einen Schnipsel einspielen. Der kam eben noch von davor. Der nämlich ganz gut, glaube ich, die Art und Weise, wie Kay Bernstein gesprochen hat über das, was er davor hat skizziert. Und dann, Marc, dass du uns mal erzählen, was das für eine Mitgliederversammlung war. Ich habe noch einen Schnipsel aus seiner Rede mitgebracht. Aber hören wir uns erst mal an, was Kay Bernstein eigentlich vor der Mitgliederversammlung darauf geantwortet hat. Auf die Frage, na was willst du denn jetzt eigentlich mit Hertha machen?
Die letzten Jahre waren durchaus von Odenprofessionalität und Chaos geprägt. Jetzt haben wir so ein paar Tage hinter uns und es dreht sich. Es wird positiv wahrgenommen, was sich bei Hertha BSC wandelt. Und die Aufbruchsstimmung – spürt auch Lars Bintos – die Aufbruchsstimmung wird im Verein wahrgenommen. Und die müssen wir in Energie umwandeln und jedem Hertha-Ner eine Gießkanne geben, damit dieses Pflänzchen der Hoffnung im Graben der Zerrissenheit blüht und wir daraus unsere Energie mitnehmen für die kommenden Aufgaben.
Kay Bernstein und seine Sprachbilder – war immer schön.
Die sind wirklich schön. Es sollte ja später noch ein Baum gepflanzt werden. Also das Pflänzchen der Hoffnung, er hat es ernst gemeint. Der Kontext dazu ist, man hat die Relegation gegen den HSV unter Felix Magath gewonnen. Auch daher, glaube ich, bezieht er dieses, dass sich die Stimmung langsam dreht. Aber das beschreibt er, glaube ich, ganz gut eben, Marc. Du hast auch gerade die Sprachbilder schon angesprochen. Da war er wirklich gut drin. Ich konnte quasi aus den Metaphern auswählen, was ich hier einspielen möchte.
Ich nehme an, wir reden auch noch über die Reha-Station und das Krankenbett. Diese Mitte der Versammlung war das vage lebte Demokratie am Ende des Tages. Man muss sagen, dass – ich habe jetzt mit sehr vielen Leuten gesprochen, in all den Jahren, muss man jetzt ja sagen – und man muss sagen, dass Lars Vintors auf dieser Mitgliederversammlung zum letzten Schlag ausgeholt hatte eigentlich. Er und Frank Steffel kannten sich. Nach der Mitgliederversammlung sind sie zusammen essen gegangen. Dieser Wahlkampf lief eigenartig, indem der damalige Vorstandsvorsitzende Klaus Brückemann öffentlich eine Wahlempfehlung für Gegenkandidat Frank Steffel aussprach und sich später windig versuchte, rauszureden, aber es nicht hinbekommen hat. Er wurde auf der Mitgliederversammlung dazu – da sollte er Erstellung beziehen – zwar ein unsouverener Auftritt. Es ging damit weiter, dass Frank Steffel Ingmar Pering, damaliges noch Präsidiumsmitglied, der selber kandidiert hatte, plötzlich für sich vereinnahmt hatte, er sollte sein Vize werden. Es wurde immer wieder Kay Bernstein die Hand gereicht, dass auch er doch in das Team Frank Steffel integriert werden könnte und eine bezahlte Position im Verein haben könnte. Und Marvin Brumme – den hatten wir vorhin nicht erwähnt – ist ein Hertha-Fan, der auch dachte, sich mal bewerben kann ja nicht schaden. Sollte dann später im demokratischen Ergebnis keine große Rolle spielen. Aber seine ganz wichtige Rolle war, dass auch er auf dieser Mitgliederversammlung öffentlich bestätigt hat, weil er dazu befragt wurde von einem Mitglied, ob auch er das Angebot bekommen hatte, für Frank Steffel zurückzustecken.
Auch gegen Geld, weil das eigentliche Amt ist ja ein Ehrenamt.
Es ging eher um Positionen, die vielleicht dann mit gewissen Gehältern verbunden sind. Nicht, ich zahle so, mir geht es und dann so.
Ich meinte quasi eine bezahlte Position. Anders als die, für die man ja kandidiert.
Richtig, richtig. Genau. Und Frank Steffel – auch das nochmal zu wiederholen – Frank Steffel und Hertha BSC haben nichts miteinander zu tun. Frank Steffel ist – ich muss es fast so despektierlich sagen, denn wenn man Frank Steffel googelt, wird man genug Ergebnisse finden und Artikel finden, die mich dahingehend unterstützen. Frank Steffel ist alter Berliner CDU-Filz. Und Frank Steffel ist vorher im sportlichen Kontext als Präsident der Füchse Berlin, dem Handballverein, bekannt geworden, die sich unter ihm entwickelt haben. Das kann man gar nicht anders sagen. Ich kenne da die Hintergründe teilweise nicht so genau, aber sie haben sich unter ihm entwickelt. Und plötzlich tauchte der aus dem Nichts auf bei Hertha und wollte plötzlich Präsident werden und sprach aber immer, immer wieder nur von einem Angebot. Und der würde ja die Hand reichen und er, Frank Steffel, der die Füchse Berlin gerettet hat, könnte das auch mit Hertha leisten. Und Vlas Fintos fand die Kandidatur von Frank Steffel komischerweise ganz gut. Und plötzlich tauchten Videos auf von Paul Darday, Dick van Burek und Marco Pantelitsch, die allesamt eine Wahlempfehlung für Frank Steffel aussprachen. Und man sich fragte, wie kennen denn diese drei Leute Frank Steffel und was interessiert denn diese drei Leute, auch wenn es verdiente Hertha-Ner sind, was da auf irgendwelchen Mitgliederversammlungen passiert? Machen wir uns mal ehrlich.
So.
Und all das hatte ein extremes Anschein von Hinterzimmerdeals. Genau der Politik, von der sich Hertha ja eigentlich trennen wollte nach den letzten Jahren, was passiert war. Und wie es teilweise unter Werner Gegenbauer passiert ist, das sehe ich gar nicht im Nachhinein schlecht reden möchte. Aber die Zeit von Werner Gegenbauer war auch eine Zeit, die davon geprägt war, dass sich die Mitglieder nicht haben mit, die wurden nicht auf Augenhöhe gesehen. Die wurden unterrichtet auf Mitgliederversammlung und das war's.
Und das war eine lange Zeit, von 2008 bis 2022, 14 Jahre.
Richtig, richtig. In der Zeit hat er viel für Hertha auch getan. Er hat stabilisiert, er hat auch Geld reingesteckt, muss man auch sagen. Und war auch da, wenn niemand anders da gewesen wäre. Deswegen, das möchte ich auch in Ehren halten, aber um das kurz zu erwähnen. Und mit diesem Stimmungsbild fing diese Mitgliederversammlung an, dass man das Gefühl hatte, wir haben da einen Kandidaten mit Kay Bernstein, mit dem wir sein Dasein als Vollbluthertaner abnehmen, aber wo wir nicht genau wissen können, was leistet er von all dem Gesagten und kann er in diesem, weil es gab keinen Kay Bernstein – Kann er Präsident? Kann er Präsident, es gab keinen Kay Bernstein vorher, kann er das. Weil auch die Lage eher extrem war, in der sich Hertha befand. Und auf der anderen Seite hattest du mit Frank Steffel jemanden, der offensichtlich ja auch einen weltmännischen Eindruck machte und der Verbindungen in die Berliner Wirtschaft und Politik hatte, der einen anderen Berliner Sportverein stabilisiert hatte. Und das Stimulungsbild vorher war nicht klar. Also man wusste schlichtweg nicht, wie diese Wahl ausgehen wird. Es hatte einen Anschein von 50-50. Und man muss ja auch sagen, dass Kay Bernstein nicht mit einer überwältigen Mehrheit gewählt wurde. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass auch die jeweiligen Auftritte auf dieser medizinischen Versammlung den Ausschlag gegeben haben. Denn Kay Bernstein, so wie wir ihn bislang gehört haben, war – er war aufgeregt, das würde ich schon sagen, aber er war trotzdem ruhig und strukturiert und hat – war Kay Bernstein. Und Frank Steffel war gefühlt unvorbereitet und hatte dann mal zur Rede geschwungen und hat sich vor allen Dingen in der Aussprache mit den Mitgliedern komplett verzettelt und fast schon eine Anti-Stimmung kreiert, also ich gegen euch und ach, wenn ihr mein Angebot nicht annehmen wollt, dann na gut. So, also auch etwas gönnerhaftes die ganze Zeit rübergebracht, wo man so war, dieser Verein ist zu wichtig, als dass das jemand gönnerhaft mal kurz übernimmt. So, und ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich – es sind ja nur wenige hundert Stimmen gewesen, die den Unterschied gemacht haben. Ich glaube, dass tatsächlich der Auftritt von Frank Steffel und der Auftritt von Kay Bernstein, aber auch die unsouveräne Art und Weise, wie sich Klaus Brüggemann rausreden wollte, als auch das Marvin Brumme verraten hat, dass auch er zurückstecken sollte, all das hat dazu geführt, dass an dem Tag der Gedanke gewachsen ist. Okay, wir haben ja offensichtlich eine – das ist eine Schicksalswahl. Wir entscheiden uns hier darüber, was Hertha BSC in Zukunft sein soll. Und mit Frank Steffel hatten die Mitglieder offensichtlich das Gefühl, sie hätten jemanden gewählt, mit dem es einfach so weitergelaufen wäre, der zwar im Gusto des Investors gewesen wäre, aber mehr auch nicht. Und der Hinterzimmer, die jetzt schon vor seiner Wahl gefühlt getätigt hatte. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir jemanden, der diesen Verein lebt. Und es kann eigentlich gar nicht schlechter werden als aktuell. Also entscheiden wir uns doch einfach mal für die Wundertüte.
So ist es dann gekommen. Also, wie sich Frank Steffel vorbereitet hat, dazu konnte ich nichts finden. Kay Bernstein hat später erzählt, er hatte an dem Wochenende die ganze Zeit über seine Tochter, 13 Monate alt, hat mit ihr auf dem Arm mehrmals seine Rede geübt und hat aber gesagt, das war eigentlich perfekt, um mich damit nicht zu aufgeregt in diese Veranstaltung reingehe. Er habe sich immer wieder eingeredet, Mensch, ist das doch nur ein Angebot, was ich mache. Lustigerweise das Wording von Frank Steffe dann später. Ich habe sehr lange nach der Rede von Kay Bernstein und auch nach der von Frank Steffe gesucht im Internet. Ich habe sie leider nicht in voller Länge sehen können. Hertha wollte sie auch nicht rausrücken, aber fuchs genug bin ich, dass ich die zwei wesentlichen Zitate dann doch irgendwo aufgetrieben habe, die über die auch später dann gesprochen wurde. Das heißt, wir hören jetzt einen Zusammenschnitt. Es sind zwei kurze Passagen aus der Rede von Kay Bernstein. Es sind aber die Passagen, über die nach der Mitgliederversammlung dann auch am intensivsten gesprochen wurde.
Unsere alte Dame liegt auf der Intensivstation. Wir können sie jetzt von innen ganzheitlich heilen und sie wieder gesund machen. Jeder von euch, der heute hier ist, ist ein Markenbotschafter von Hertha BSC. Jeder kann hier mithelfen, muss mithelfen, damit wir wieder unsere blau-weiße Seele zurückgewinnen.
Ja, Marc, du hast sehr genickt. Natürlich kennst du diese Zitate zur Genüge. Gab es da damals noch etwas Neues, was in dieser Rede für dich dazu erdient wurde zur Person Kay Bernstein? Oder war es vor allem so, dass man festgestellt hat, okay, so tickt der?
Das war heruntergedampft das, was er über all die Monate vorher in seinem Wahlkampf quasi tituliert und in den Raum gestellt hatte und sich so präsentiert hat. Das war das. Und auch da wieder benutzt er ja Worte, die theoretisch erstmal Eimerbegriffe sind. Was ist denn Markenbotschafter? Und was ist denn, was ist das denn alles? Und auch das, das muss man eben sagen, egal was Kay Bernstein gesagt hat, er hat das mit Leben gefüllt. Und Markenbotschafter hatten wir. Insofern auch auf dem hat man bemerkt, Leute gingen wieder stolzer mit Hertha-Klamotten in die Stadt. Es gab eine Zeit, wo Leute das Gefühl nicht gemacht haben, weil sie wussten, dass sie gehässige Sprüche bekommen. Weil gleichzeitig erstarkte ja auch Union und entwickelte da dieses Gegengewicht und dieses Guck mal, jetzt seid ihr hier die Nummer zwei. Und unter Kay Bernstein haben sich Leute dann wieder mehr getraut, Fahne zu zeigen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und auch sich mehr einzubringen. Leute aus der Fanszene sind in Satzungskommissionen gegangen, weil die Satzung von Hertha BSC aktuell überarbeitet wird. Leute haben sich aktiv eingebracht, ein Konzept dafür zu entwickeln, wie bei Hertha BSC Frauenfußball stattfinden kann. Das kam aus der Fanszene heraus. Mein geschätzter Co-Podcaster Lukas ist mittlerweile Stadionsprecher der Heimspiele der Hertha Frauen. Weil er sich dazu animiert gefühlt hat, weil so eine offene, fennahe Kultur gelebt wird. Das war vorher nicht möglich. Das ist mit Markenbotschafter gemeint. Das ist damit gemeint, dass sich jeder einbringen kann, um diesen Verein von der besagten Intensivstation zu holen.
Dann hören wir uns noch kurz an. Das war der Moment, in dem das Ergebnis verkündet wurde. Das war auch ein Schnipsel, der damals sehr weit geteilt wurde.
Es gibt 9 Stimmen, 40. Es gibt Ja-Stimmen, also Stimmen für Marvin Brummel, mit insgesamt 26 Stimmen. Es gibt eine Ja-Stimme für Herrn Frank Steffel von 1280. Und es gibt Ja-Stimmen für Kay Bernstein mit 1600.
Ich bin kein Hertha-Fan, Marc. Ich krieg da immer noch Gänsehaut weg. So war es damals aber auch. Als damals die Videos rumgehen, dachte ich mir Alter, was ist denn da gerade passiert?
Was passiert ist, ist, dass Menschen das Gefühl hatten, sich ihren Verein zurückgeholt zu haben. So kann man es auf den Punkt bringen, nach Jahren der Distanzierung, nach Jahren, die sich fast schon nicht erwünscht fühlen, unter gewissen Entscheidungsträgern und Investoren, haben sich Leute so gefühlt, als hätten sie ihren Verein zurück und haben sich so verbunden gefühlt und auch so mündig wie seit Jahren nicht mehr. Das meine ich vorhin mit gelebter Demokratie und dass Kay Bernstein ein Paradebeispiel für 50 plus 1 ist. Das ist durch die Mitglieder entstanden. Und ich weiß auch noch, wie ich in der Halle saß und ich hatte den Tweet quasi vorformuliert und musste nur noch abdrücken quasi und höre die Stimme und weiß alles klar und schicke das ab und sitze da noch und plötzlich sprang alles um mich herum auf und Leute feierten das wie die gewonnene Relegation gegen den HSV. Es war überlebensnotwendig für einige, hatte ich das Gefühl. Ich glaube, das war auch für viele der letzte Moment, um zu sagen, ich mache das hier und jetzt mit. Und wenn das klappt, bin ich wieder voll dabei. Und ansonsten, wie Harald vorhin sagte, dann werde ich für immer zwei Hertha-Präsidenten bleiben, aber mich aktiv einbringen. Das wird nicht mehr passieren. Dann haben sie mich verloren. Und da haben viele, glaube ich, ihr Feuer zurückentdeckt.
Das ist eine superspannende Szene. Auch ein superspannendes Dokument, dieses Wahlergebnis. Und was mir dazu einfiel, als ich mir das eben angehört habe, war eigentlich total irrsinnig, erstaunlich, dass wir sowas im Fußball so selten erlebt haben, sozusagen. Also man könnte wahrscheinlich, man braucht nur die Finger einer Hand, um ähnliche Beispiele der letzten 40 Jahre Fußballpolitik diesbezüglich zu rekonstruieren. Wann gab es denn mal Kampfforum? Wann gab es denn mal echte Wahlen, die die gesamte Hinterzimmerpolitik ins Abseits gestellt haben? Da gibt es, mir fallen kaum welche ein, ganz, ganz, ganz selten und das Irrsinnige ist eigentlich, dass bei einem Thema und einem Phänomen, was urdemokratisch gar nicht anders laufen sollte, als dass wir unterschiedliche Positionen haben, eine Versammlung machen, die Mitglieder zu Wort kommen und die Mitglieder sagen, ja das ist ja unser Verein und ich möchte, dass es so läuft und mein Nachbar möchte halt, dass es anders läuft und dann zählen wir mal aus, für was wir uns dann entscheiden. Und das ist im Grunde ein Punkt, den wir in der Zukunft näher beleuchten müssen. Warum passiert das im Fußball nicht? Und warum ist dieses Hinterzimmer-Thema im Fußball ein so großes Thema mit dem ganzen Irrsinn, dass man alle Gegenkandidaten dann irgendwann auch noch einkaufen will und jedem irgendwo einen Posten bespricht. Das ist ein riesengroßes Problem im deutschen Fußball insgesamt. Das erinnert sich auch an den DFB und die Wahlen, die da dann immer mal abgehalten werden. Was ich auch mehrfach schon untersucht habe, wo ich auch viele Daten dazu produziert habe, dass diese Wahlen in der Basis überhaupt keine Relevanz haben. Das Wahlmänner-System, was man da hat. Also das Wahlsystem im Fußball ist häufig eines, was Demokratie verhindert, was Partizipation, was Mitbestimmung verhindert und was bestimmt Gründe und vor allem diese ganzen Seilschaften der Hinterzimmerpolitik erst so möglich werden lässt. Und da ist jetzt im Vereinsrecht etwas vorhanden, was wir in Deutschland haben, was extrem wertvoll ist und was auch in Zukunft immer eine größere Rolle spielt. Bei BVB Stuttgart hatten wir ähnliche Situationen, wo dann ansonsten dröge Mitgliederversammlungen plötzlich hoch interessant werden, wo dann Tens auch den Sonntagnachmittag opfern, um dort hinzugehen, Zeit zu verbringen, um dann irgendwann, wenn es darauf ankommt, ihre Hand zu heben. Das war in der Vergangenheit nicht so populär und das wird jetzt immer wichtiger. Man denkt auch an die Mitgliederversammlung bei Bayern München, wo es dann woher geht, wo dann plötzlich die oben an der Spitze des Vereins merken, oh, wir vertreten ja nur die Mitglieder und wenn wir viele Mitglieder haben, könnten theoretisch auch viele kommen, die heute hier sich zu Wort melden und eben ihre Hand heben oder nicht heben. Und das finde ich ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Beispiel. Deshalb müssen wir dieses Dokument sehr, sehr sorgfältig bewahren und immer wieder daran erinnern. Das ist enorm wertvoll.
54 Prozent Zustimmung gab es für Kay Bernstein, das ist exakt die Zahl, die auch Werner Gegenbauer bei der Mitgliederversammlung davor bekommen hat, allerdings ohne Gegenkandidaten. Das zeigt eben schon, wie viel Kritik da laut wurde. Und jetzt ist Kay Bernstein Präsident geworden, gegen die Erwartungen vieler, wenn auch natürlich nicht aller. Und er sagt unter anderem das in seinem ersten Interview dann mit Hertha TV. Wir hören mal kurz rein.
Ich habe immer gesagt, ich biete mich an, für den Verein mich auf zu opfern, rein zu hauen. Das ist mein Inhalt, das ist meine Punkte, für die ich stehe. Und hier bin ich. Und liebe Mitglieder, entscheidet ihr, ob ihr mir die Verantwortung übertragt. Für euch als Präsident von Hertha BSC das Beste zu geben. Und natürlich darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, gibt es auch 1.300 Leute, die mich nicht gewählt haben. Und denen gilt es natürlich, die Hand auszustrecken und zu sagen, lasst uns reden, lasst uns eure Ängste, eure Sorgen, eure Zweifel ernst nehmen. Lasst uns in den Dialog gehen. Ich kann euch versprechen, hier ist kein Ultra jetzt in der Geschäftsstelle, der mit einer Fahne oder mit einer Fackel oder mit irgendwas rumläuft, sondern hier ist einer, dem Hertha am Herzen liegt und der bestmöglich versuchen will, sich hier einzubringen und Hertha wieder besser machen will.
Die Hand ausdrecken auch denjenigen, die ihn nicht gewählt haben, sagt sich leicht, war aber in dem Fall dann zum Teil ein Telefonhörer in die Hand nehmen, Marc.
Richtig. Es gab Fans, die sich mit Kay Bernstein und dem Weg so wenig identifizieren konnten, als dass sie aus dem Finalstreten wollten, als er dann offiziell gewählt war. Und da nahm Kay Bernstein den Hörer in die Hand und telefonierte diesen Leuten hinterher. Und soll wohl eine beeindruckende Quote hingelegt haben, denn nahezu alle von diesen Fans sind im Verein geblieben, nachdem sie mit ihm gesprochen haben, sich abgeholt gefühlt haben und verstanden haben, was sein Ziel ist. Ähnliches ist übrigens später bei Marius Gersbeck passiert, der nach seiner Gewalttat in den Verein zurück integriert wurde. Und auch da wollten Fans aus dem Verein austreten und auch er hat Fans hinterher telefoniert. Wie erfolgreich das war, weiß ich nicht, aber auch das scheint sich dann in die Zukunft zu tragen, dieses Modell. Und Hände zu reichen war nicht nur auf Fans bezogen, sondern eben auch auf alle möglichen Leute auf der Geschäftsstelle. Denn ich weiß, dass damals von sehr hohen Leuten im Verein gesagt wurde, wenn der gewählt wird, bin ich weg. Weil es einfach ein fast schon absurdes Ständedenken im Fußball gibt. Und wenn du nicht Teil meiner Blase bist, dann gehörst du hier nicht her. Und dann traue ich dir das nicht zu, weil nur wir können das. Denn wir sind Ex-Profis oder was auch immer einen dann dazu befähigt. Und man muss eben auch sagen, dass Leute wie Ingmar Pering oder auch ein Pär Mock Stümer, ein weiteres Präsidiumsmitglied, den konnte man auch ins Lager von Frank Steffel stecken, auch wenn er das nicht so ganz offensiv vorgetragen hatte. Auch es gab extreme Grabenkämpfe in dieser Zeit bei Hertha. Und da musste Kay Bernstein Hände reichen oder wollte auch Hände reichen. Er hätte auch sagen können, ich könnte jetzt auch gerne gehen, sondern aber es ging immer darum, dass die, die schon da waren, eine faire Chance bekommen und dass sich alle erst mal vertragen und man dann immer noch gucken kann, ob es funktioniert. Aber erst mal war es so und es war auch so, dass er ein, da sind wir wieder bei den Workshops, die Kay Bernstein so geliebt hat, dass er das Präsidium genommen hat und die sind erstmals, ich glaube, am Wochenende und paar Tage waren die weg. Und dann hat er wohl jedem ein weißes Blatt Papier hingelegt und gesagt, so, warum bist du bei Hertha? Was willst du gestalten? Was ist dir wichtig? Und können wir einen Weg finden, dass wir für die Sache vereint daran arbeiten? Und erst mal gab es ja auch keine weiteren Präsidiumsaustritte. Das sollte dann alles noch folgen. Das hat sich ja bis in den letzten Monate teilweise gezogen, gewisse Personalien. Aber erst mal war es wirklich sein Bestreben, die Geschäftsstelle zu beruhigen, ein gesundes Verhältnis auch zu Lars Windhorst aufzubauen. Wir können ja gleich darüber reden, wie sich das dann teilweise auch gestaltet hat.
Ja, aber es ist eben ganz wichtig, es gab dann ein neues geflügeltes Wort. Und ich weiß, dass das noch ganz früh bei mir im Forum, also im Rasenfunkforum, dann schon Menschen verwendet haben. Und jetzt, als ich noch mal so viele Interviews mit Kay Bernstein gehört habe und eben auch noch mal jetzt hier gleich einen Auszug, was er direkt nach seiner Wahl gesagt hat, jetzt verstehe ich auch, woher dieses Wort kam, nämlich von Kay Bernstein.
Wir brauchen den Burgfrieden auf allen Ebenen. Den brauchen wir mit dem Investor, den brauchen wir mit den Gremien, Präsidium, Aufsichtsrat, den brauchen wir mit den Mitarbeitern der Geschäftsstelle, den brauchen wir mit den Fans und mit den Mitgliedern. Diesen Burgfrieden, der wird nur über wir müssen uns gegenseitig verzeihen und wir müssen Vertrauen aufbauen funktionieren. Und wenn das die Grundlage ist, wo wir alle in ein Boot gesetzt haben und gesagt haben, wir müssen ein bisschen die Erwartungen runterschrauben, wir müssen mehr Demut im Alltag vorleben und dann ein geeintes Präsidium haben, was wirklich Hertha vorlebt, was wirklich nahbar ist, was wirklich auf die Menschen zugeht, was mit den Leuten spricht, was das Präsidium, was Sport5 bei der Vermarktung unterstützt. Beispielsweise, wenn wir es schaffen, das vorzuleben und uns einzubringen, wird das Zusammenwachsen ganz von alleine kommen.
Dass sich das noch mal traut, jemand die Demut des Fußballs neu zu beschweren, nachdem man da schon so oft vom Fußball für enttäuscht wurde, aber erst mal Burg, Frieden nach innen, eben in alle Richtungen. Das war das, was du auch schon angedeutet hast, Marc. Und dann eben auch eine gewisse Demut der Aufgabe gegenüber. Richtig.
Richtig. Man muss eben sagen, dass viele vorher nach wie vor das Image der großen alten Dame pflegen wollten. Und warum sollten wir denn nicht am Wochenende gegen Leverkusen gewinnen? Wir sind doch Hertha BSC. So, also diese Form der eigenen Überhöhung aufgrund vergangener Tage war bei Hertha in jedem Fall vorhanden, obwohl man in diesen vergangenen Tagen ja nicht mal Titel geholt hat. Das ist ja auch etwas, was Hertha von vielen Vereinen unterscheidet. Jetzt ob Schalke, der HSV, die hatten alle ihre Jahrzehnte glatt, wo sie dann auch Titel geholt haben. Das gab es bei Hertha nicht, außer man zählt die zwei Meisterschaften in den 30er-Jahren dazu.
So viele Titel waren es bei Schalke jetzt auch nicht, aber das ist ein anderes Kapitel.
Zu seinem Zeitpunkt war ja schon klar, dass nicht mehr viel Geld vorhanden ist. Also es musste ja auch reit wirtschaftlich eine neue Demut gelernt werden und ich würde behaupten, das hat geklappt.
Obwohl die Aufgabe Großwall, Kay Bernstein, war im Morgenmagazin zu Gast nach seiner Wahl und da hat er das hier gesagt.
Die Anspannung fällt ab. Man sagt so ein bisschen in ein Loch, sieht aber auf der anderen Seite durchs Fallen schon das große Monster der Erwartung, das große Monster des Wartens auf einen zukommen und sagen, okay, Luft holen, wir können hier eine Geschichte schreiben. Wenn wir die alle in ein Boot kriegen, setzt das Energien frei, die uns befinden. Das wird toll.
Das wird toll, hat er gesagt. Er hat aber auch vom Monster der Erwartung gesprochen. Und was da mit zusammenhängt, was dann Kay Bernstein so angegangen ist, dem wollen wir uns dann jetzt mal widmen. Denn im Sommer 2022 ist es dann soweit. Hertha hat seinen neuen Präsidenten und es ist eben der Ultra-Kay, wobei wir ja gerade schon herausgearbeitet haben, wie das zu bewerten ist. Und es wurde dann aber erst mal still, Marc. Denn Kay Bernstein hat auch gesagt, für die ersten 100 Tage seiner Amtszeit – er hat es aus verschiedenen Gründen dann nicht geschafft, aber das lag nicht an ihm – da wolle er schweigen, weil er eben vorher so viele Interviews und so weiter gegeben hat. Richtig.
Das ging dann an die Arbeit. Also so, wie ich ja schon einmal ausgeführt hatte, was man Kay Bernstein immer zugutehalten musste, er hat seine Worten, die teilweise ja auch sehr aufgebrauscht waren und mit Pathos und Sprachbild und so weiter, er hat eigentlich immer Taten folgen lassen. Und so war es dann erst mal an der Zeit, eine Bestandsaufnahme wirklich zu machen. Was ist denn in den Gremien überhaupt los? Er konnte ja das ja vorher auch nur als Außenstehender bewerten. Sicherlich hat er ein, zwei Insights, die vielleicht der gemeine Hertha-Fan nicht hatte. Aber er musste erst mal diese Charaktere kennenlernen, wissen, was ist denn das Ziel von jedem Einzelnen, warum liefen die letzten Jahre, wie sie liefen. Denn da waren ja auch noch sehr viele Leute dabei, die auch schon jahrelang Teil des Ganzen waren und Entscheidungen mitgetragen oder sogar getroffen haben. Und ich hatte ja schon ausgeführt, dass es da z.B. Workshops gab mit allen Präsidiumsmitgliedern, dass es Aussprachen gab mit dem Aufsichtsrat. Denn auch das, musste man ja sagen, das Verhältnis zwischen ihm und dem Aufsichtsrat, vor allen Dingen dem Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden Klaus Brückemann, war natürlich aufgrund der Wahlkampfzeit belastet. Und auch solche Dinge mussten auch erst mal evaluiert werden. Und ich finde, das war eine gesunde Einstellung dazu, was folgen sollte. Denn jetzt schon wieder vorauszupreschen, ohne mit den einzelnen Leuten gesprochen zu haben, nachdem man im Amt ist, geht natürlich nicht und hätte sehr wahrscheinlich wieder dazu geführt, dass der Haussegen schiefgehangen hätte.
So kann man nämlich, Harald, Hinterzimmerpolitik auch betreiben. Man kann sich ja gemeinsam im Hinterzimmer zu einem Workshop treffen und die Interessen aller anhören.
Ganz genau. Und in dem Fall macht einerseits Hinterzimmerpolitik einen gewissen Sinn, aber vor allem auch diese Hundert-Tage-Regel ergibt einen wirklichen Sinn, weil es wäre ja kontraproduktiv, wenn man über die Leute, die man noch gar nicht in allen Arbeitszusammenhängen kennt, letztlich öffentlich spricht, bevor man mit denen intern gesprochen hat, bzw. nicht direkt über die Leute, sondern über bestimmte Aufgabenfelder, Strukturen, Ziele, Visionen oder auch über bestimmte Themen aus der Vergangenheit. Da kann man natürlich als Präsident mit seinen eigenen Ideen weiter vorfrischen, weitere Visionen entwickeln, aber dann würde man natürlich vergessen, alle anderen mit ins Boot zu holen. Und deshalb ist es ziemlich logisch, erst mal 100 Tage oder mindestens 100 Tage nichts öffentlich zu sagen, sondern intern mit den Leuten zu reden, um dann – und das wäre dann ein pfiffiger Schachzug, um dann auch andere mit in die Bütte zu nehmen, sozusagen, wenn es an die Öffentlichkeit geht, dass die Leute dann eben aus ihren Feldern, von ihren Arbeitsbereichen heraus sichtbar werden und dann auch ihre Ideen in den Verein und an die Öffentlichkeit tragen können. Nö. Also das klingt für mich nach einer stimmigen, authentischen Linie, die wir quasi von der Bewerbung, von der Vorbereitung der Bewerbung, der Bewerbungsphase bis hin in die ersten 100 Tage so nachvollziehen konnten. Und eine Randbemerkung habe ich dazu noch viel mehr gerade ein, zu diesem Schweigen oder beziehungsweise nicht öffentlich sein in den ersten 100 Tagen. Aus Publicity-Gründen gab es auch gar keine Notwendigkeit, öffentlich zu werden. Der hatte in den ersten 100 Tagen, ohne ein Wort zu sagen, so viel Öffentlichkeit wie kein anderer Präsident in der Bundesliga. Und hat es einfach laufen lassen, so die Kampagne der Bild-Zeitung, die ganzen Schreckensmeldungen, die waren dann erstmal Thema für sich und haben sich nach meinem Dafürhalten aus meiner Beobachtung heraus dann quasi ohne sein großes Zutun selbst entweder ausgelaufen oder von selbst geklärt. Auch das fand ich jetzt als Medienthema auch interessant, wie das so gewirkt hat.
Ich kann dazu auch sagen, dass Kay Bernstein – darauf werden wir auch noch zu sprechen kommen – aber Kay Bernstein hat sich immer extrem viel spiegeln lassen, von auch Außenstehenden, also auch von Medien. Er hat mit einzelnen Journalistinnen immer wieder telefoniert, ohne mich da voranstehen zu wollen, aber wir auch immer mal wieder, weil er ernsthaftes Interesse daran hatte, zu verstehen, wie auch der Verein von außen gesehen wird, wie gewisse Handlungsschritte von außen gesehen werden, teilweise was auch in der Vergangenheit passiert ist und wie man das bewertet hat, aber auch wie sein Auftreten bewertet wird und gewisse Dinge gesehen werden. Er hat auch beispielsweise mit ehemaligen Hertha-Präsidenten Gespräche geführt nach seiner Wahl, teilweise auch davor, aber vor allen Dingen nach seiner Wahl, wie in der Gegenbauer und alle weiteren davor. Und diese ersten 100 Tage waren auch davon bestimmt, dass er extrem viele Mitarbeitergespräche geführt hat. Also ist mit den Leuten ein Currywurstessen gegangen oder ist mit denen durchs Olympiagelände gelaufen, um einfach einmal mitzubekommen, wie denn auch die Stimmung auf der Geschäftsstelle ist. Denn darauf werden wir auch sicherlich zu sprechen kommen. Das war ein Ort, an dem er dann sehr viel Zeit verbracht hat, mehr als jeder andere Präsident, glaube ich, im Profi-Fußball. Denn er hat es dann so geregelt, dass er seiner Frau die Geschäfte der Firma quasi übergeben hatte, um sich voll und ganz dieser Aufgabe zu widmen und ein permanentes Büro auf der Geschäftsstelle zu haben und permanent Zugriff auf alle zu haben, permanent in Entscheidung mit dabei sein zu können, um Präsenz zeigen zu können und wirklich als Führungspersönlichkeit auch wahrgenommen zu werden, anstatt andere Präsidenten, die gerne mal auch nur Stippvisite machen. Und dann ist es ja umso wichtiger, ein Gefühl für jeden Einzelnen zu bekommen.
Und das ist eben durchaus bemerkenswert. Er war immer von Dienstag bis Freitag da, plus dann am Wochenende wird er auch gearbeitet bei Bundesligisten, selbst wenn man in der zweiten Liga irgendwann ist. Und das ist schon mal ein wichtiger Punkt. Das haben wir nämlich noch gar nicht erklärt. Also er ist eben für die Zeit seiner Amtszeit, die eben auf zwei Jahre erstmal hätte gehen sollen bis zur ersten Wiederwahl, da hat er sich quasi für dieses Ehrenamt freigenommen und konnte sich das leisten. Und das ist natürlich eine bizarre Situation, weil das nochmal ein Schlaglicht auf so grundsätzliche Gegebenheiten im Fußball legt. Und da hat er bei euch im Podcast auch was zu gesagt.
Für mich ist der Fehler im System schon der, dass dieses Amt eigentlich nur darauf – oder nicht nur, aber das Amt – musste dir leisten können. Und so ist es ja bei meinen Amtskollegen so. Es ist eigentlich ein Amt für den Übergang von Rente zum Lebensarm.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und nochmal ein bisschen Abenteuerspielplatz, ein bisschen Rampenlicht, ein bisschen gebraucht werden, ein bisschen gehört werden, ein bisschen…
Jetzt hat man das hässlichste Gefühl, dass es manche oft Präsidenten sind, und man das Gefühl hat, die können vielleicht auch einfach noch nicht so ganz loslassen. Die waren vorher Manager oder ähnliches. Jaja, genau.
Und das, finde ich, ist ein Fehler im System, dass du ein Amt baust, was per se erst mal da, was du dir leisten musst, damit du es übermachen kannst. Und dann habe ich das Privileg und das Glück, über die Arbeit der letzten zwölf Jahre mir diese Auszeit nehmen zu können, ohne dass die Agentur oder unsere Familie in Schieflage gerät. Sprich, das ist darauf angelegt, ich kann mir das leisten. Ob das verhältnismäßig ist im Verhältnis zum Zeitaufwand, zur Verantwortung und zum Aufwand, das ist nochmal ein anderes Blatt Papier, ist aber für mich in dem Fall dann nachrangig, weil wenn ich meinem Verein helfen kann, wenn der Verein sein Potenzial entwickelt und das wieder in die richtige Richtung kommt, dann ist alles gut. Dann war es genau das wert.
Und das ist doch interessant, Harald, oder dass wir hier quasi auf ein strukturelles Defizit hingewiesen werden, so gut man verstehen kann, dass das lange ein Ehrenamt war, denn die Vereine sind ja auch gemeinnützig orientiert oder gemeinwohl orientiert, sollten sie zumindest eigentlich sein. Muss man ja doch feststellen, so wie der Fußball sich entwickelt hat, damit wird eigentlich auch eine Professionalisierung dieser Personengruppe, die überhaupt eben Präsident oder Ähnliches werden kann, wird verhindert.
Ja, ganz genau. Damit verweist er auf ein Kernproblem des organisierten Sports. Dieses Kernproblem situiert sich immer so in dem Spannungsfeld zwischen Ehrenamt oder dann doch einem mindestens light-Manager-Posten, den man da haben will. Im Grunde beide Positionen beißen sich. Du kannst für ein Ehrenamt kein Geld nehmen. Und gleichzeitig fällt es natürlich schwer, sieben Tage die Woche zu arbeiten, ehrenamtlich, mit so viel Verantwortung, mit so viel Druck auch aus der Öffentlichkeit, ohne dafür irgendeinen Ausgleich zu kriegen. Aber mit dem Begriff Ausgleich, da kommen wir auch nicht so ganz klar, wenn man beispielsweise in den DFB hineinschaut, wo dann, ich weiß nicht, 12, 15, 20 DFB-Vizepräsidenten da irgendwelche Ausgleichszahlungen kriegen für Dinge, von denen man gar nicht weiß, was machen die da eigentlich, oder der DFB-Präsident bis zu einer halben Million im Euro an Aufwandsentschädigung für sein Ehrenamt bekommt, von der FIFA, aber auch vom DNB. Das hat dann immer so einen Geschmäckle. Das ist ein richtig großes, ernstzunehmendes Problem. Das spricht er da an. Und die strukturelle Lösung ist, das finde ich jetzt auch als Begrifflichkeit hoch interessant, dass man da so eine Lösung für die Schnittstelle zwischen Rentenalter und Lebensarm findet in der eigenen Biografie und dann eben den Kreis derer, die sich so ein Ehrenamt leisten können, dann entsprechend klein situiert. Da kommen eben nur wenige Menschen in Frage. Was man da allerdings auch zusagen muss, ist, er hatte natürlich ein ganz besonderes Modell der Präsidentschaft vor Augen. Ein Modell, was dann letztlich auch erfordert, dass ein Kurs eines Vereins, die Reform, die Neuaufstellung eines Vereins vorwiegend über eine Person läuft, was bei Hertha definitiv der Fall war. Da ist man ja von diesem Investorenfußball quasi innerhalb einer Nacht nach der Wahl umgeschwenkt in ein ganz neues, ganz anderes, eigentlich sehr ursprünglich traditionelles Bild von Fußball und Fußballvereinen und das hängt nun mal an seiner Person. Und deshalb kommt er aus der Rolle, dass er auch alles machen muss, dass er aber auch einen 7-Tage-Job hat, da kommt er gar nicht aus. Das ist ein Sonderfall. Der muss auf andere Vereine so nicht übertragbar sein. Wenn man eine bereit aufgestellte Mannschaft hat, kann ein Präsident das auch ehrenamtlich leisten, ohne 7 Tage die Woche da zu sein. Aber ich denke mal, 3 Tage, 4 Tage muss man schon haben. Das heißt, man muss sich so ein Amt tatsächlich auch wirklich leisten können, was sich übrigens auch jeder Ehrenamtler leisten muss. Also jemand, der 2000 Euro verdient, aber nebenher noch die Fußballmannschaft seiner Kinder trainiert, der muss auch überlegen, ob er sich das leisten kann. Und man leistet sich das halt, weil man auch etwas zurückkriegt. Man hat eine Aufgabe, für die man brennt, für die man lebt. Und das ist dann auch eine Chance, die man wahrnehmen muss, wenn einem so viele Menschen das Vertrauen geben und Hoffnungen in einsetzen. Von daher kann ich das auch sehr gut nachvollziehen. Was mich in seinem Statement wirklich begeistert, also regelrecht begeistert, ist die Fähigkeit eines Fußballpräsidenten auf dem Niveau, sich gleich zu Beginn in der Weise zu hinterfragen, zu reflektieren. Seine Rolle auch öffentlich zu erörtern, zu diskutieren und auch zu zeigen. So sehe ich diese Problemlage. Ich gehe auch sehr selbstkritisch mit meiner eigenen Rolle um. Ich bin dankbar, dass ich mir in zwölf Jahren Agenturarbeit ein finanzielles Preußler geschaffen habe, sodass ich mir das leisten kann. Aber ich stelle mir gleichzeitig die Frage, ob das korrekt ist, dass Menschen wie ich, Kay Bernstein, sich so etwas leisten können. Da schwingt für mich in meiner Interpretation ein ganz besonderer Umgang mit Verantwortung, die dieser Präsident, Kay Bernstein, verkörpert hat. Das heißt, er macht das nicht aus dem Selbstbewusstsein heraus. Ich bin der Beste, ich bin der Einzige, und ich bringe jetzt hier die Wende und die goldenen Zeiten für die Hertha, sondern er macht das durchgängig reflexiv und vor allem er setzt bei seiner eigenen Rolle an, die er tagtäglich kritisch reflektiert. Und das war so meine Frage im Hinterkopf, als ich den O-Ton verfolgt habe, gehört habe, dachte ich, boah, habe ich irgendwo von einem anderen Präsidenten, bei München, von Borussia Dortmund oder von irgendjemand anderem, mal ein ähnliches Statement gehört? Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, ich wünsche mir in naher Zukunft mehrere solcher reflexiven, selbstkritischen, grüblerischen, aber auch offenen, konstruktiven Selbstreflexionen von Menschen in Führungspositionen zu hören, wie von Kay Bernstein. Also diese Tonspur, die brauche ich dringend für meinen Podcast.
Du kannst dir gerne auf Hertha Baze, auf YouTube, das gesamte Gespräch angucken, 2, 5 Stunden. Tatsächlich ist das Gespräch ja auch erst zu dem Zeitpunkt, also Januar 2023 entstanden, weil wir eigentlich geplant hatten, nach seinen ersten 100 Tagen ein Gespräch zu führen. Es sollte dann etwas dazwischen kommen, über das wir gleich reden werden, und hat das alles nach hinten verschoben. Aber zu dieser Vision erst mal einen finanziellen Ausgleich zu schaffen für das Präsidiumsamt, da steckt ja schon ganz viel drin. Also zum einen ist es so, dass man auch nochmal klarstellen muss, und das hat er in späteren Interviews ja auch, weil ihm dann vorgeworfen wurde, aha, da will jetzt jemand eben, wie Harald schon gesagt hat, eine Manager-Posten für sich selbst schaffen. Nee, Kay Bernstein hat das immer im Bezug darauf gemeint, was nach ihm kommt. Also er wollte diesen, diesen finanziellen Ausgleich für Menschen nach, die nach ihm in dieses Amt kämen, schaffen. Das ist das erste, also Selbstbereicherung hätte es dahingehend nicht gegeben. Zweitens, soweit ich informiert bin, gibt es finanzielle Ausgleichsmodelle für Präsidiumsmitglieder als auch Präsidenten im Fußball. Im Fußball Hertha hängt er nur mal wie so oft in solchen Themen einfach hinterher. Das heißt, er spricht ja auch nicht etwas an, was völlig utopisch ist. Das wurde ihm ja teilweise auch vorgeworfen, wenn Leute eben nicht über den Hertha-Kosmos hinausblicken, dann zu sagen, aha, was schlägt der denn jetzt schon wieder wildes vor? Ja, etwas, was teilweise schon Usus ist. Also da schwingt schon ganz viel mit. Und natürlich spricht er damit auch eben eine Ungerechtigkeit an, weil es ganz viele von diesem Amt exkludiert, weil es quasi den, ich weiß, Kampfbegriff geworden, aber den alten weißen Mann fördert. Weil gewisse Leute an diese Ämter auf Qua ihres Alters, ihrer Sozialisierung, ihrer Gesellschaftsschicht und so weiter gar nicht herankommen können. Und wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass Kay eigentlich auch nicht den Weg gehabt hätte, um da anzukommen, wo er letztendlich ankam. Und da diesen Leuten wieder – deswegen komme ich darauf immer wieder zurück, Kay Bernstein, der Brückenbauer – diesen Leuten auch eine Brücke zu solchen Ämtern, zu solchen Kompetenzen bauen zu wollen, das hat ihn sicherlich ausgezeichnet.
Ja, und das Interessante ist, man würde auch dieses Exkludierende öfter präsentiert bekommen, wenn es öfter richtige Wahlen gäbe mit Gegenkandidaten. Also Marvin Brumme, der Bäcker war es ja – ich glaube, Bäcker ist er vom Beruf, nee?
Nee, er arbeitet im Baustellenbereich. Ich glaube, da geht es um Statik oder so, aber nagelt mich nicht drauf fest. Auf jeden Fall findet man ihn auf Baustellen.
Okay, also irgendwas mit B. Soweit hatte ich es mir noch gemeint. Aber auf jeden Fall, da hatten wir eben jemanden, der nicht so gut vernetzt war und der eben noch nicht wirtschaftlich unabhängig war, der eher eben ein Zeichen setzen wollte mit seiner Kandidatur. Und wir haben es vorhin gehört, der hat zweistellige Stimmen bekommen. Irgendwas 22, 26, irgendwas so um den Dreh rum und Kay Bernstein waren 1600. Also und das wird uns aber nicht vor Augen geführt, weil es in der Regel diese Wahl nicht gibt, weil es gar nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, sich als Gegenkandidat zu positionieren. Deswegen wird das nicht gezeigt. Und gleichzeitig ist es interessant, weil zwei Dinge glaube ich passiert sind dann in der ersten Phase von Kay Bernstein. Das eine ist das Sportliche. Ich glaube, da müssen wir gleich noch mal drüber reden. Es ist auch hochinteressant, wie dann die Berichterstattung sich oft darauf kapriziert, ob jemand mit jemandem sich verträgt. Also kann Kay Bernstein mit Freddy Bubic? Dabei ist es doch erstmal wichtig, ob die zusammenarbeiten können. Ob die danach noch zusammen was trinken gehen, das ist eigentlich ja egal. Aber das haben wir in der Politik, das haben wir in aller Berichterstattung. So funktioniert das. Interessiert vielleicht auch die Menschen noch mehr als der Inhalt, kann sein. Aber das Zweite ist, dass es eben auch so ein Unbehagen fast schon gab, vor allem von nicht wohlgesonnenen Medienvertreterinnen und aber auch natürlich Fans, dass eben Kay Bernstein danach, dass zwar über ihn geredet wurde, aber dass er versucht hat, weniger zu reden. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, weil die Situation haben wir ja eigentlich bei ganz vielen anderen Präsidenten in diesem Amt immer – also wer hört schon die ganze Zeit den Präsidenten sprechen? Das ist eher die Ausnahme. Und die Frage ist, ja, was ist eigentlich das Reglement, an das sich so jemand halten muss? Und da ist nämlich Kay Bernstein, finde ich, immer sehr offen mit umgegangen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch Teil seines oder könnte Teil seines Vermächtnisses sein. Ich möchte zur Diskussion stellen, dass er nämlich die Satzung, die eigentliche Vereinssatzung als Leitplanke nimmt. Und diesen Aspekt würde ich jetzt gerne mal mit diesem U-Ton hier beleuchten.
Für mich ist die Satzung aber wiederum dann das höchste Gutweiler brauchen wir. Klar, in gewissen Punkten fehlt ihr die Klarheit und fehlt ihr auch ein bisschen die Aktualität. Aber die Satzung ist das maßgebliche. Und dann mit dem Aufsichtsrat auch nochmal zu sprechen von wegen ihr seid für die Aufsicht zuständig. Und wenn ihr euch auf die Aufsicht konzentriert, habt ihr genug zu tun und nicht aufs Gestalten. Weil dann haben wir auch keinen Konflikt, weil das Präsidium und das Aufsehen eine ganz klare Geschäftsordnung hat. Und über die Geschäftsordnung, die ist strukturgebend gewesen. Und somit ist dann wiederum der Burgfrieden für alle. Auch dann war ja noch Lars Windhorst, Tenno und die anderen Streitbahnen drum herum, die haben sich da schon einfangen lassen im Sinne von, nee, es geht jetzt nur um Hertha-BSC und um nichts anderes.
Und den interessanten Punkt daran finde ich also zweierlei. Zum einen können wir gleich mal generell über die Bedeutung von Satzungen im Vereinsfußball sprechen. Ich denke, Harald hat da ein paar Gedanken zu. Aber das zweite Markt ist, wenn er sagt, dass sich Tenor, der Aufsichtsrat, dass die sich einfangen haben lassen durch die Satzungen, dann bedeutet das doch eigentlich, dass sie vorher nicht ganz satzungskonform sich in gewisse Bereiche gebischt haben, bei denen sie eigentlich gar nicht mitreden sollten oder die sie vielleicht nur beaufsichtigen sollten, aber nicht mitentscheiden.
Korrekt, kann man so eigentlich zusammenfassen, viele Gremienmitglieder vor Kay Bernstein haben ihre Rolle völlig überdehnt im Verein. Sprich, du bist vielleicht – das ist ja ein hohes Amt – du bist nur Mitglied des Aufsichtsrates und hast eine klare Funktion in diesem Verein zu erfüllen. Denkst du dir aber, wenn ich jetzt schon hier sitze, dann kann ich auch noch mit XY reden und da wieder sind wir bei Hinterzimmern eben nicht in den eigentlichen Sitzungen, die protokolliert werden und so weiter, sondern da wird hier mal ein bisschen gemauschelt und da ein bisschen geredet und da ein bisschen gestaltet, weil ich bin doch, ich habe doch eine Führungsrolle bei Hertha-BSC, das kann ich mir ja wohl rausnehmen. Also es gab ein völlig falsches Selbstverständnis, was die eigene Funktion und die eigene Kompetenz in diesem Verein angeht und natürlich entwickeln sich daraus Interessenskonflikte, daraus ergeben sich Schlupflöcher für Leute von außen, sprich Lars Winthors seine Berater und Tenor an sich. Und Kay Bernstein hat diese Satzung eben, wie er schon selbst gesagt hat, als höchstes Gut gesehen und hat immer wieder gesagt, lasst uns das in den Gremiensitzungen besprechen. Da ist ein völlig offener Raum. Da können alle Ideen neudeutsch gepitcht werden und dann können wir überlegen. Aber abseits dessen reden wir über das so nicht, denn es wird nicht festgehalten, es wird nicht protokolliert, es ist nicht nachweisbar und fällt dann schnell in diesen Bereich der Hinterzimmerdeals. Ich weiß von einigen Gremienmitgliedern, die damit nicht umgehen konnten, die so bei Hertha gefühlt nie gelernt haben zu arbeiten, an denen das sehr sauer aufgestoßen ist und die ja dann nach ein paar Monaten seiner Amtszeit dann gegangen sind, teilweise sehr lautstark.
Harald, ist vielleicht die Satzung, die wir ja überall haben, vom DFB bis hin zu DFL, da dürfte es eine Geschäftsordnung sein, bis hin eben zu allen Vereinen. Ist das vielleicht ein unterschätztes Gut, was wir im deutschen Fußball haben?
Ja, nicht nur im Fußball ein unterschätztes Gut. Letztlich ist unser gesamtes gesellschaftliches, zwischenmenschliches Zusammenleben von so etwas wie Gesetzen, Satzungen, Ordnung, Vereinbarungen, die auch schriftlich fixiert sind, geprägt und gekennzeichnet. Satzungen erfüllen immer dann einen Sinn, wenn mehrere Menschen an einer Sache arbeiten, wenn es so etwas wie Rollenverteilung, Aufgabenverteilung, Funktionsverteilung, Kompetenzzuschreibung und so weiter gibt. Das muss mehr oder weniger klar geregelt sein. Das ist im Gemeinwesen einfach erforderlich. Das kann nur dann aufgelöst werden, wenn man in einer Gruppe zusammenarbeitet, beispielsweise in einer Band, in einer Fußballmannschaft oder in einer anderen kreativen Künstlergruppe oder wo auch immer, wo man sich intuitiv versteht, wo man dann das Feld genau im Blick hat und merkt, oh, der eine prescht vor, jetzt ist meine Rolle die, und dann schaukelt man sich gegenseitig quasi hoch. Also so etwas wie so ein kreatives Feld, was dann auch immer genialische Ergebnisse hervorbringen kann. Aber diese kreativen Felder, das wissen wir aus unserem Alltag, sind ziemlich selten. Deshalb ist es eine Erwungenschaft, dass wir bestimmte Dinge, Regeln und Insatzungen festhalten. Vor allem in Feldern, wo die anderen Akteure aufgrund ihres Naturwelt- und auch ihrer naturgegebenen Selbstüberschätzung dazu neigen, die Dinge komplett selbst in die Hand nehmen zu wollen. So nach dem Motto im Fußball weiß ich ganz genau, wie es laufen muss. Ich presche vor, ich weiß, wie das geht und bewege mich auch in Teilthemen, in denen ich mich eigentlich nicht so gut auskenne, weil ich habe das große Ziel vor Augen und alle anderen haben mir gefälligst, hinterherzulaufen. Also so klassische Fußballdiktaturen oder Monarchien. Da ist der Fußball anfällig dafür und genau deshalb müssen wir diese, sagen wir mal, Selbstüberschätzung Einzelner irgendwie bändigen. Das einzige Werkzeug, was wir da haben, ist tatsächlich eine Satzung. Unsere Satzung ist gut, weil die gibt allen Beteiligten Sicherheit. Wo den Chefs als auch den Mitarbeitern alle haben die Sicherheit, hier ist mein Platz, hier ist meine Aufgabe in dieser Satzung. Und alle Mitglieder eines Vereins haben ja auch Zugriff auf die Gestaltung dieser Satzung. Wenn sie dann merken, irgendwas liegt schief, wir müssen daran arbeiten. An dem Punkt müssen wir unsere Satzung ändern, damit wir in unserem Handeln, in unserem Alltagsgeschäft zukünftig so weiter agieren. Und dann setzt sich so ein Diskurs in Gang, die Mitglieder beraten darüber, es gibt eine Satzungskommission, man bringt sich da ein und schaut, ob man die Satzung ändert. Und wenn man sie dann ändert, der Abstimmung in der Mitgliederversammlung, dann hat das Konsequenzen. Das wird zukünftig so geworden. Das konnten wir sehr schön sehen bei der Mitgliederversammlung vor zwei Jahren bei Bayern München, dass es darum das Thema Satzung und Satzungsänderung und so weiter geht, wo sich ja die Chefetage dann beispielsweise geschlossen gegen den Antrag gestellt hat, die Wahrung der Menschenrechte in die FC Bayern Satzung mit aufzunehmen. Also solche Stierblüten produziert das. Das ist jetzt nicht gut, das ist jetzt nicht schlecht, aber es zeigt, oh, eine Satzung hat Konsequenzen. Da müssen wir drüber reden. Und dann kommt es zu solchen Situationen. Und das ist so das Salz in der Suppe von Demokratien. Das ist der State of the Art, auf den wir uns einigen. Und davon könnten wir ausgehend Politik machen. Natürlich mit den Konsequenzen, die so eine Satzungsänderung dann hat. Also im ersten Moment klingt Satzung immer so ein bisschen dröger.
Kann es auch sein.
Es muss es ja auch sein. Da ist wenig Kreativität drin. Das ist einfach eine dröge Festlegung der Leitplatten. Mein erster Gedanke, als ich Kay Bernstein eben in dem O-Ton gehört habe, war, oh, jetzt spricht der Beamte durch und durch. Diese Rolle hat er auch noch beeindruckend, aber so brauchen wir das halt. Wir haben diese Regelung und müssen auch damit arbeiten. Und dann muss es aber in einem Verein auch Orte geben, Räume geben, wo man dann eben über die Zukunft offen, frei, meinetwegen auch illusorisch debattiert, fabuliert, sich verständigt, welchen Fußball wollen wir eigentlich. Und das kann die Kurve sein, das kann die Kneipe sein, das kann die Straßenbahn sein, wo man über Fußball ins Gespräch kommt, wo man dann auch Visionen entwickelt, wo man eigentlich hin will. Und dann irgendwann wird dieser Prozess eingeleitet. Oh, ist diese Vision so stark, ist die so wichtig, dass wir schauen müssen, ist das in unserer Satzung so abgebildet, wollen wir uns darauf verständigen, so Fußball zu spielen. Deshalb finde ich eigentlich Satzungsarbeit unerlässlich. Und da müssen wir auch immer, wenn wir Visionen entwickeln, wenigstens im zweiten oder dritten Schritt mal hinschielen, wäre das nicht was pfiffiges, wenn wir, sagen wir, im deutschen Fußball, bestimmte Themen in den Satzungen nicht nur als Bloss hin, sondern als verbindliche Leitplanke etablieren wollen. Weil dann haben wir eine Chance, uns immer wieder darauf zu berufen. 50 plus 1 ist so eine Leitplanke. Das ist ein super gutes Beispiel, weil das wirklich jeder inzwischen versteht, welchen Wert diese Leitplanke hat. Das ganze Ausland, Rennszenen aus dem Ausland beneiden die Bundesliga um diese geniale Regelung, während andere da auf Granit beißen und dann eine andere Vision vom Fußball haben und sagen, oh, das müsste man eigentlich aushebeln, das blockiert uns bei anderen Themen. Aber an der Stelle merkt man, wie wichtig solche Regelungen für den Fußball sind.
Und das hat man auch bei Klaus Brüggemann festgestellt, der Fall, den ich vorhin beschrieben hatte, dass er eine Wahlempfehlung für Frank Steffel geäußert hatte, hatte ja für sehr viel Unmut gesagt, hatte auch für einen Rüffel seitens des Ältestenrats bei Hertha BSC gesorgt. Aber er konnte sich auf einen sehr schwammigen Satz dahingehend in der Satzung berufen und sagen, naja, sagt mir, dass ich hier was völlig Falsches getan habe. Und die Satzung hat das in der Form aufgrund ihrer Schwammigkeit, aufgrund auch einfach ihres Alters so nicht hergegeben. Und genau deswegen gibt es ja gerade schon seit Monaten eine sehr aktive Satzungskommission bei Hertha BSC, wo sich auch Hertha-Fans aktiv einbringen, um all diese Löcher, all diese Schwammigkeit nach Möglichkeit zu beseitigen. Aber natürlich, so wie sich das Leben dreht, wird es auch irgendwann wieder dazu kommen müssen, Dinge zu aktualisieren. Aber für den Moment will man sie schon modernisieren, um genau solchen Dingen entgegentreten zu können.
Das ist eben Teil des Vermächtnisses von Kay Bernstein, diese Satzungs-Kommission, nenne ich sie jetzt einfach mal, die tagt jetzt und wird irgendwann ihre Verbesserungsvorschläge einreichen. Gleichzeitig ist das, was, also wenn wir jetzt hier auf dem Spurbiss wären und sprechen würden, dann würden wir das komplett anders, also wir drei wären natürlich stabil in unserer Haltung. Aber auf dem Spurbiss würde man sagen, genau wegen dieser Satzungen ist der Fußball so langsam und alles dauert so lange und Entscheidungen werden nicht schnell getroffen. Was ja stimmt, also jede Satzungsänderung braucht ihre Zeit. Und gleichzeitig, wenn man aber aus der Vogelperspektive nochmal draufschaut, deswegen fand ich das so interessant, Harald, dass du 50 plus 1 nochmal mit reingebracht hast. Wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, die KGAAs da draußen, die eben die ganzen Fußballabteilungen sind, die könnten ja komplett umgangssprachlich gesagt holdrehen. Die könnten machen, was sie wollten. Wenn es nicht diesen kleinen Türklotz gäbe, 50 plus 1, der dafür sorgt, dass du mit dem Rambox-Satzung immer mal wieder zwar in aufwendigen Prozessen und unter großem Anstrengungen, aber dass du da noch mal reinkommst. Und wenn man diesen Türklotz rausziehen würde, dann, weil es wird immer nur davon gesprochen, dass dann endlich Investoren kommen könnten und so weiter. Es bedeutet aber letztlich auch, dass es dann egal ist, ob ich in einem Verein Mitglied bin oder nicht, denn meine Stimme hat dann kein Gewicht mehr.
Und an der Stelle, an der Stelle müssen wir die Frage stellen, welchen Fußball wollen wir? Wofür stehen wir eigentlich? Und wenn wir darüber nachdenken, tauchen so viele Selbstverständlichkeiten auf, die nicht wirklich Selbstverständlichkeiten sind, sondern die in unserer Kultur und der Gesellschaft gewachsen sind. Nämlich so ein Vereinsleben, nicht nur bei den Top-Bundesliga-Klubs, sondern bei jedem der 24.000 Fußballvereine hier in Deutschland. Das ist etwas gewachsen. Da schicken Eltern ihre Kinder zum Training. Die Eltern fahren die Kinder zu wegkämpfen, zu Fußball spielen, zu turnieren. Die Eltern machen Übungsleiterscheine, investieren Zeit, die investieren Geld, die investieren Aufwand, die Gemeinden stellen Plätze zur Verfügung. Das ist also ein kultureller Invest in diesen Fußball, der gigantisch ist. Aufgrund dieses Invests haben wir dann irgendwann eine Handvoll wirklich guter Fußballer und Fußballerinnen hervorgebracht, die in bestimmten Vereinen, die auch sehr gut geführt sind, erfolgreich sind, in der Bundesliga, Zweiten Liga und so weiter Fußball spielen. Das heißt, das ist nicht so ein Konstrukt wie beispielsweise bei Rasenballsport Leipzig, wo man das quasi zusammenkauft, sondern das ist ein gewachsenes Konstrukt. Aber auch Rasenballsport Leipzig bedient sich ja bei ihren Spielern in einem Pool von kulturellen Invest, was andere geleistet haben. Also alle, die da durch den Abrucksleistungszentrum gegangen sind, kommen ja auch irgendwo her. Die haben ja auch irgendwo Großeltern, Eltern, Freunde, Nachbarn, Kinder- und Jugendtrainer, die investiert haben in den Fußball. Das heißt, ich begreife den Fußball als Errungenschaft unserer Kultur, unseres kulturellen Zusammenlebens. Genau aus dem Grund müssen wir das bewahren. Das Kultur-Gut-Fußball mit all den Investitionen der vielen Millionen Menschen, die dort teilhaben, die dort investieren, die sich auch dort darüber freuen. Und man kann aus meiner Sicht nicht daherkommen, so als helmsärmiger Manager und Investor, und dann einfach mal von diesem Kultur-Gut sich die Sahne so abschöpfen und sagen, das ist jetzt quasi die Ausstattung, die ich aus der Gesellschaft heraus mir nehme, abschöpfe. Und damit mache ich dann Kohle. Und man vergisst den ganzen Unterbau. Das heißt, die Einheit des Fußballs müsste nach meinem Dafürhalten bei jeder Profi-Abteilung usw. mitgedacht werden, bewahrt werden und gehalten werden. Und wenn Investorenmodelle mir schlüssige Antworten darauf geben könnten, wie sie das in ihrem Arbeiten, Wirken und Tun garantieren wollen, parallel zu Satzungen oder irgendwas anderem, dann wäre ich da offen, das zu diskutieren und mir neugierig anzuhören. Nur ich habe es bis heute noch nirgends gehört. Das einzige, was man da als Modell ausinterpretieren kann, ist tatsächlich das unreflektierte Abschöpfen der Talente, das Verbrauchen der Talente und damit das Verbrauchen gesellschaftlicher Ressourcen auf Kosten aller. Und das, denke ich, sollte es in unserer Kultur nicht einfach so uninterfragt geben. Das sollten wir auch Protest und Widerstand leisten, wenn so etwas gemacht wird. Und darüber müssen wir eben diskutieren. Das müssen wir ins Bewusstsein holen. Wir können ja auch – jetzt habe ich lange doch geredet – wir können ja auch irgendwo schauen, ob wir eine Gegenrede kriegen, dass mir das jemand mal anders erläutert oder erklärt, was dann der Sinn des Ganzen ist.
Ja, ich glaube Teil der Gegenrede wäre, dass der Spitzenfußball dir sagen würde, wir geben ja auch der Gemeinschaft zurück. Es gibt den DFB-DFL-Grundlagenvertrag, über den wenige Millionen fließen. Natürlich angesichts der Milliarden ist es wenig. Dann würde natürlich der Spitzenfußball sagen, wir schaffen doch so viele Arbeitsplätze, wir sind eine riesige Industrie, wir sind Industrienummer. Man vergleicht sich dann immer mit so richtig großen Industrien. Das stimmt zwar nicht, aber man hat ja schon sehr viel. Ich glaube, das wären so Argumentationen, die auch nicht komplett in ihrem Kern falsch wären. Genauso ist aber ja dein Punkt eigentlich auch klar geworden. Und das ist letztlich eine Entscheidung, woran man den Erfolg misst. Messen wir den Erfolg daran, dass ein deutsches Team ein Europapokal gewonnen hat, mit auch deutschen Spielern? Oder messen wir den Erfolg daran, dass die Summe an Fußballspielenden, Kindern und Jugendlichen, Mädchen und Jungs, konstant hochgegangen ist? Und das ja etwas sehr Positives für die Gesellschaft hat. Sport ist ja etwas sehr Gutes, hat ganz ganz viele tolle Eigenschaften. Also da sind so Grundschatzfragen anhängig, die dann ganz klar definieren, in welchem Lager man ist. Ich glaube, wir drei müssen da jetzt gar nicht diskutieren, weil selbst wenn ich die Gegenposition einnehme, schaffe ich das nicht aus vollem Herzen, wie man gerade schon gemerkt hat. Aber wir sind damit ja, Marc, auch über Bande bei der Bedeutung des Mitgliederseins gekommen. Und auch da hat ja eine Entwicklung bei Hertha BSC angesetzt. Wir haben davon gesprochen, es gab Mitglieder, die wollten oder sind ausgetreten, weil Kay Bernstein gewählt wurde. Du hast schon erzählt, er hat dann versucht, viele davon ist es ihm auch gelungen, umzustimmen, dass sie erstmal bleiben. Aber das ist ja nicht die einzige Entwicklung. Wie haben sich denn die Mitgliederzahlen dann im Verlauf der Zeit entwickelt bei Hertha?
Natürlich ist das nicht monokausal. Das muss man natürlich dazusagen. Und trotzdem ist natürlich ein Trend zu erkennen, dass Hertha mittlerweile 50.000 Mitglieder hat. Und 10.000 davon kam in der Zeit von Kay Bernstein, also in diesen anderthalb Jahren. Und das ist die Arbeit, das ist einfach Grundlagenarbeit, die gemacht wurde. Also Kay Bernstein hat nicht versucht, wieder neue Räume zu erschließen, würde ich erstmal behaupten, sondern erstmal geguckt, wieder die Basis zu stärken. Also die, die überhaupt da sind, dass die sich gesehen fühlen. Und das Interessante ist, das ging ja mit einem massiven Sparkus einher. Also ihr kennt das ja, man ist fünf Jahre Mitglied und kriegt einen Kugelschreiber. Man ist zehn Jahre Mitglied und kriegt 30. Das ist alles eingestampft worden. Das klingt so klein, aber Hertha musste an allen Ecken und entspannen. Also das Mitgliedsein hatte teilweise fast schon – also materiell hatte es weniger Nutzen, als man es vorher kannte. Das mag einigen unwichtig erscheinen, manchen ist es wichtig. Aber die Leute haben sie wieder mitgenommen und gesehen gefühlt. Man hat einfach die Mitgliederbetreuung gestärkt, man hat Exklusivitäten geschaffen. Also wenn du Mitglied bist, kriegst du aber auch das und das. Oder du hast früher einen Zugang zu Tickets oder es gibt Mitgliederverkäufe und so weiter. Also es lohnt sich, wirklich Mitglied zu sein. Und du kannst eben auch wirklich auf diesen Mitgliederversammlungen, die neu gestaltet waren, die zugänglicher wirkten, kannst du mitgestalten. Also hat auch, glaube ich, das Argument immer wieder hervorgebracht. Auch Thema Markenbotschafter und Thema du kannst diesem Fall auch ein Stück Seele zurückgeben. Da hat Kay Bernstein nicht nur sich in der Pflicht gesehen, sondern hat versucht, alle bestehenden Kräfte wieder zu aktivieren. Und das ist, glaube ich, Leuten aufgefallen. Also, so wie ich es erlebe, sind auch ganz viele Hertha-Fans erstmals Mitglied geworden in dieser Zeit, weil sie bei befreundeten Hertha-Mitgliedern gesehen haben, wie attraktiv das jetzt ist und wie viel Spaß das machen kann, da soziale Teilhabe zu spüren, da mitgestalten zu können. Und das hat offensichtlich sehr gut funktioniert. Ich glaube, dass die Hertha-Familie so – in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht ein etwas zynisches Wort, aber so lebendig ist, wie seit – also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, wann es jetzt mal so war, muss man so klar sagen. Und das spürt man auch in dieser Stadt. Und ich glaube, daraus entwickelt sich dann wieder eine Attraktivität, neue Mitglieder zu gewinnen. Das muss immer gar nicht die Kampagne sein, die nicht Hertha-Fans erklären will, warum das jetzt so toll ist, sondern du musst erst mal die zu dir holen, die eigentlich dir ja ohnehin positiv zugeneigt sind.
Warum willst du nicht mitmachen? Genau, das führt nämlich auch zu einem ganz anderen Blick auf Mitglieder und auf Mitgliederversammlungen. Wir springen jetzt ein bisschen zeitlich, denn das, was Kay Bernstein hier sagt, das bezieht sich dann schon auf eine nächste Mitgliederversammlung, die ganz anders stattgefunden hat. Marc, da kannst du uns dann gleich gern noch ein paar Worte zu sagen. Aber wir hören mal kurz, was er zu diesem Thema sagt.
Wir haben zwar nicht so viele Mitglieder wie Bayern München, aber bei der letzten Mitgliederversammlung im November hatten wir mehr Teilnehmende vor Ort als parallel bei Bayern München oder bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Also wir sind schon sozusagen ein demokratischer Leuchtturm in dieser Fußballwelt. Was heißt Mitgliederanzahl versus Teilnehmenden auf der Mitgliederversammlung und wie das Ganze funktioniert. Wir müssen es halt nur transparenter und ehrlicher leben. Also wir müssen halt eher gucken, wie kriegen wir andere Formate hin. Also kriegt man, also wir sind ja auch ein Verein der zwei, wir sind einer der wenigen Vereine, der zwei Mitgliederversammlungen im Jahr hat. Brauchen wir die. Also würde es auch reichen, wenn wir eine Mitgliederversammlung haben, wo wir satzungskonform das regulativ bedienen und würde eine Beteiligungskonferenz im selben Mitgliederduktus sozusagen nicht viel mehr austauscht. Dialog.
Das gab es doch mal mit Axel Krusalsmund.
Wie hieß denn das? Na, Harter im Dialog. Harter im Dialog hat man installiert, natürlich weil es an gewissen Dingen prinzlig wurde, um gewisse Meinungen abzuschwächen.
Meinungen abzuschwächen. Das war Harter im Dialog und Meinungen stärken und erstmal stattfinden lassen. Im ersten Moment stattfinden lassen und dann stärken, indem man sie auch teilhaben lässt, zu einem Konsens zu finden. Das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das, was Kay Bernstein versucht hat, mit konkreten Maßnahmen. Vielleicht, Marc, magst du uns mal erzählen, wie sah denn dann die erste Mitgliederversammlung nach der Wahlmitgliederversammlung aus?
Gute Frage. Ich glaube, das war dann schon einfach ein ganz anderes Modell in dem Sinne, als dass das auch schon teilweise ein bisschen mehr als Fanfest gelebt wurde. Also man hat einfach mehr Räume der Begegnung geschaffen außerhalb der Halle, in der alles stattfand. Also man konnte gemeinsam was essen, man konnte zuletzt bei der letzten Mitgliederversammlung, das heißt, man konnte dann auch in den Teambus einmal rein und durchlaufen und solche Dinge. Und die Hertha-Verantwortlichen sind da auch frei rumgelaufen. Du konntest mit denen reden. Allein das ist schon eine große Veränderung. Und es war eben auch so gestaltet, dass der Pressesprecher, damals noch Max Jung, mehr dem Moderator gegeben hat und alle an einem Tisch saßen und Max Jung Fragen gestellt hat und die Verantwortlichen, sei es die Geschäftsführung um Tom Herrich oder das Präsidium, auch dem Vizepräsidenten Fabi Drescher beispielsweise, dass die dann so in einem viel lockereren Ton und auf Augenhöhe berichtet haben. Und das war schon eine Auflockerung und eine Demokratisierung des ganzen Prozesses, die, glaube ich, allen sehr gut getan hat. Eine Veranstaltung, die ich aber da auf jeden Fall wählen möchte, ist, wir haben eben über Hertha im Dialog gesprochen. Hertha im Dialog war augenscheinlich erstmal der Versuch, mit den dann direkt in Kontakt zu kommen. Also alles, was eigentlich in eine Aussprache einer funktionierenden mit dieser Versammlung eh klappen könnte, hat man dann, dafür hat man extra ein Format geschaffen, wo Leute – ich weiß nicht, wie viele das waren, wahrscheinlich so 150 Hertha-Fans oder so – durften dann kommen und dann saßen da auch Werner Gegenbauer und Co. und dann durften Fragen gestellt werden und die haben dann darauf geantwortet. Aber auch das war ein bisschen fadenscheinig, weil eben doch nicht das gesamte Meinungs-Spektrum abgebildet wurde und weil Leute doch untergebuttert wurden. Es gab dann den Zeitpunkt, das war kurz nach der Trennung von Fredi Bobic und der Installation von Benny Weber als Sportdirektor und Andreas Zecke-Neuendorf als Leiter des Hinspielerbereichs und auch der Akademie, da hatte er so eine Doppelfunktion, dass man Hertha im Austausch ins Leben gerufen hat. Sehr ähnlicher Name, aber deutlich anders gelebt, allein deswegen, weil MedienvertreterInnen nicht gestattet waren. Auf Mediaversammlungen sind die ja zugegen. Dort wollte man es wirklich in einem sehr intimen Rahmen halten. Das war eine sehr kurzfristig anberaubende Geschichte. Man hätte es in Zukunft ausbauen wollen, also auch mehr Mitglieder dazuholen wollen. Das waren jetzt um die 100, glaube ich. Und dann hat man da für den Profifußball eigentlich erschreckend transparent erzählt, warum man sich dann von Friedi Brobic getrennt hat und was man jetzt vorhat. Und was ist denn gerade mit Lars Vintors, Triple Seven und so weiter. Natürlich, man kann nicht verhindern, dass Leute dann, die dabei waren, trotzdem Tweet rausschicken. Das ist so. Aber man hat einen sehr, sehr exklusiven, intimen Rahmen geschaffen, um die Mitglieder so sehr abzuholen und so sehr ernst zu nehmen, wie ich das vorher noch nie erlebt habe.
Und das ist ja interessant, Harald, dass hier jemand den Erfolg von Mitgliederversammlungen nicht daran bemisst, wir haben unser Präsidium bestätigt und die Geschäftsführung wurde entlastet von den Mitgliedern, sondern an der Zahl der Teilnehmenden und der das dann vergleicht mit anderen Schwergewichten des Mitglieder-halbwegs-noch-geführten Fußballs, Eintracht Frankfurt und Bayern. Beides natürlich so ein bisschen mit Sternchen versehen, ist klar. Und dass er dann aber darüber nachdenkt, was können wir tun, dass möglichst noch mehr Mitglieder kommen. Das ist ja interessant. Und er verwendet da das Wort demokratischer Leuchtturm. Und ich glaube tatsächlich – ich hoffe, dass ich da jetzt nicht im Nachhinein überhöre – aber das war auch eine der Hauptaspekte, die mir in den Sinn gekommen sind, als ich gesehen habe, was da bei Hertha BSC passiert war. Das eine war die bessere Stimmung und dass sich auch sportlich was getan hat und auf Investorenseite. Aber das andere war vor allem, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, nicht nur es gibt jetzt mehr Mitglieder, sondern diese Mitglieder können auch wirklich sagen, wie sie Hertha BSC haben wollen und können natürlich immer noch in einem begrenzten Rahmen, weil der Verein gehört einem Investor. Da muss man nicht drum herum reden. Aber in diesem begrenzten Rahmen haben sie den Platz zu sagen, wie sie Hertha gestalten wollen. Und so soll Hertha dann auch sehen. Wäre doch ein Modell für mehr Vereine, oder?
Genau genommen ist es ein Modell für alle Vereine. Stimmt. Im Sinne von Vereinen ist ja genau das. Und das eigentlich schon voll ironische ist, dass selbst wir jetzt in unserem Gespräch darüber reden, oh, das wäre doch toll, wenn es so wäre. Weil die Serialität uns ja eben ganz, ganz klar was völlig anderes zeigt. Wir haben Vereine, wir haben Mitglieder, wir haben Mitgliederversammlungen, wir haben Satzungen, wir haben Mitbestaltungsmöglichkeiten. Das ist alles im Vereinsrecht, im deutschen Vereinsrecht, aber auch in den Satzungen der Vereine so festgelegt. Und es wird aber im Grunde seit Jahren, Jahrzehnten nicht gelebt. Das ist keine Realität. Da sind die Mitglieder in vielen Vereinen so auf die Funktion von Kunden reduziert. Die dann ein bisschen was einzahlen, so am Mittendebeitrag dafür ein bisschen was kriegen. Sie dürfen dann an irgendwelche Tickets besser rankommen. Auch wie Marc vorhin sagte, in den zehn Jahren kriegst du ja noch einen Google-Schreiber, freust dich darüber. Das ist so ein Kundenverständnis von Mitgliedern, was aus der Ökonomie kommt, was auch funktioniert und was in Massen dann auch einigermaßen befriedigt, wenn man so will. Aber der Urgedanke unseres Vereinswesens, weshalb das in Deutschland auch so erfolgreich ist, ist, da treffen sich Menschen mit einem Interesse, sei es jetzt in einem Kleintierzopfverein, in einem Musikverein oder in einem Sportverein und wollen dann ihre Sicht von Sport, vom Fußball in diesem Verein als Gemeinschaft, Leben, Gestalten und Vorhanden getragen. Von den Ergebnissen ihrer Auseinandersetzung zur Zukunft des Fußballs, zur Zukunft für die Jugend, zur Zukunft des gesellschaftlichen Miteinanders, das ist Vereinswesen pur. Und das ist das wirklich große Verdienst von Kay Bernstein, dass er das, diese Selbstverständlichkeit, die ja auch juristisch so festgeschrieben ist, dass er die in den deutschen Sport mal partiell bei Hertha BSC wieder beleuchtet hat. Deshalb ist der Begriff Leuchtform genau richtig. Und davon können wir alle lernen. Nicht nur in den Vereinen, sondern auch in den Verbänden, die ja da genau das gleiche Problem haben, wo dann eigentlich die Top-Funktionäre sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie so viel Sitzfleisch haben, dass sie nach 20, 30 Jahren Boxentour dann irgendwann in die fetten lukrativen Posten kommen. Und die dann natürlich aufgrund ihrer Erfahrungen ganz, ganz großes Interesse daran haben, dass eben diese Demokratie nicht stattfindet, weil die könnte ja gefährden, dass man im nächsten Jahr wieder auf diesen tollen Posten und damit auf der WIP-Trikkenlinie und so weiter sitzen kann, sondern dann könnte es passieren, dass jemand, der eine bessere Idee hat, dort sitzt. Und das haben wir im deutschen Sport, insbesondere im U-Spall, in den letzten Jahrzehnten in einer Art und Weise kultiviert, die aus meiner Sicht bedenklich ist und die, und das habe ich in vielen empirischen Studien auch auf die Zahl gebracht, die von der Basis des U-Spalls von den Vereinsmitgliedern, von den DFB-Mitgliedern, mehrheitlich und zwar mit einer großen Mehrheit abgelehnt wird. Man wünscht sich an der Basis genau das, was Karl Bernstein macht, und zwar in einem Prozentsatz. Da reden wir von Prozentwerten von 80 bis 95 Prozent mehr Demokratie im Fußball einfordert. Die vielleicht nicht alle mitgestalten wollen, aber die einen Fußball wollen, der von Demokratie getragen wird. Wir erleben das auch gegenwärtig bei all diesen Demonstrationen gegen rechts, dass sich Sportvereine, dass sich Vereinsvorsitzende stark machen für gesellschaftliche, politische Ziele und dass sie die Kraft der Vereine auch mitnehmen auf die Straße, dass man auch sagen kann, wir zeigen in bestimmter Hinsicht Haltung in diesem Land. Und das ist etwas dieser Zusammenarbeit zwischen Sport und Demokratie, zwischen der Organisation des Sports, sprich Vereine, sprich Verbände, Dachverbände und so weiter. Das ist vom Ansatz her urdemokratisch. Die Demokratie ist aber in weiten Teilen auf der Strecke geblieben, ausgetauscht durch so ein unfragmatisches Kundenverhältnis und wird jetzt zusehen, das beobachte ich an ganz vielen Stellen, wird zusehend wieder zurückgehoben. Und das wäre jetzt vielleicht so eine Umwandlung des Slogans, wir holen uns das Spiel zurück. Leute, holt euch die Vereine, holt euch den Fußball, holt euch die Verbände wieder zurück, weil das ist Aufgabe eines jeden Mitglieds. Und das, Kay Bernstein, das meine ich, ist wunderbar und ganz deutlich unterstrichen. Und da drücke ich den Daumen, dass es in diese Richtung weitergeht.
Und es war eben auch optisch zu sehen, also für diejenigen, die die Hertha-Mitgliederversammlung nicht so verfolgt haben wie Marc, früher sah eine Hertha-Mitgliederversammlung aus, genauso wie bei allen anderen und wie bei irgendwelchen DAX-Unternehmen und Konzernen vorne eine große Bühne. Da sitzen ganz, ganz viele Männer nebeneinander, vielleicht auch zwischendurch mal eine Frau. Die haben alle so ein Mikro vor sich und es gibt einen Rednerpult. Und da läuft man dann nacheinander hin im Ablauf der Tagesordnung und hält seine Reden. Und da darf dann vielleicht auch mal ein Mitglied drauf und sprechen. Aber ob er eine Antwort bekommt, ist gar nicht klar. Grüße an Herrn Hoeneß, der sich da manchmal auch gerne rausgezogen hat beim FC Bayern. Und das war eben schon allein optisch anders. Als ich die erste Mitgliederversammlung dann gesehen habe im neuen Gewand, das sah aus wie eine Talkshow. Das sah irgendwie aus wie Fünf nach Drei oder Fünf nach Neun. Jetzt hier, Hertha. Und das hatte schon eben ganz anderen Flair und war ja auch anders gelebt. Und ja, so kann man Mitgliederversammlungen auch gestalten.
Und es liegt eben auch in der Natur des Eventmanagers und des Eventveranstaltes, Kay Bernstein, der da natürlich ganz viel Kompetenz und Herzflut halt reinfließen lassen, eben auch in das Fanfest im Sommer, was jetzt zweimal stattgefunden hat, sicherlich auch nach ihm weitergeführt wird, weil auch das ein riesiger Erfolg war. Das war wie ein Hertha – ja, also ja, es war ein Tag lang so ein Hertha-Spaßpark. Mit Begegnungen, mit Foodtrucks, mit alles Mögliche für Kinder, mit Kleinbühnen, wo Leute gesprochen haben, auch da alle sehr anfassbar. Kay Bernstein, wie auch bei Heimspielen, läuft über dieses Gelände und macht mit jedem Fotos. Der wird nicht gefühlt mit einem Security-Typen durchgeschleust, um seine eine Rede zu halten, um dann wieder zu gehen, sondern der ist anfassbar, dem kannst du auch die Meinung geigen, theoretisch, er hätte sicherlich eine Antwort darauf gehabt, wobei das immer alles sehr harmonisch ablief.
Und da sind tolle Szenen entstanden, wie beispielsweise beim ersten als Marco Richter, der damals noch kurz vorher seine Hohenkrebsdiagnose bekommen hatte und deswegen ja erstmal ausfiel, kam zum Training der Mannschaft, die im Amateurstadion, die U23 hatten, die ein öffentliches Training dann gemacht. Und da kam er und wurde von den Hertha-Fans unendlich herzlich begrüßt. Und auch da hast du schon eine neue Form von Zusammenhalt gespürt. Und dass Spieler auch nicht kommen und gehen, sondern erst mal in diese Hertha-Familie aufgenommen werden. Wie sie damit dann umgehen, steht offen am anderen Blatt Papier. Aber ob jetzt dieses Hertha im Austausch, ob die dynamischere, anfassbare Version der Mitgliederversammlung oder dieses Fanfest, das waren Dinge, die Hertha und unter Kay Bernstein sehr wichtig waren, ich weiß noch, dass ich mit Kay Bernstein auch mal drüber geredet habe, ob es sich mal so ein Hertha-Festival geben könnte, über mehrere Tage meinte er, findet er richtig gut, würde er aber am liebsten erst mal nur mit den Mitarbeitenden machen. Also auch da erst mal wieder den Kern stärken. Das waren so Dinge, die, glaube ich, dann als Veranstaltung auch mal durch den neuen Geist verkörpert haben.
Und vielleicht ist das der perfekte Moment, um mal reinzuhören, was eigentlich Kay Bernsteins Vision eben für Hertha BSC in diesem Mitgliederaspekt war. Das hier hat er dazu gesagt.
Das kannst du doch keinem normalen Jungen mehr erklären. Und wie sollen die Leute im Stadion für die jungen Spieler sozusagen sich überhaupt den Namen merken, wenn sie wissen, der ist doch sowieso in zwei Jahren wieder weg. Dann ist der da. Also wie lange waren die Leute früher in dem Verein? Wie sehr hat man noch einzelne Spieler in den einzelnen Kurven wirklich Denkmäler gesetzt und gesagt hat, ihr seid hier eine Ikone? Das ist natürlich auch eine gewisse Bindung, eine Prägung, eine Faszination von dem Fan-Dasein. Ich glaube, also ich hoffe mal, also der DFB, die DFL, also ich glaube schon, dass viele auch in der Pandemie-Zeit sozusagen schon gemerkt haben, dass dieses Produkt Fußball, diese Unterhaltungsindustrie, in der man sich bewegt, sehr, sehr, sehr stark von den Emotionen und von den Menschen abhängig ist. Und es ist nun mal, und da ist Hertha ja ein klassisches Beispiel, wir sind der Arbeiterverein Ossendetting, der Verein für die ganz normalen Leute, der BSR-Fahrer, der Elektriker, der Gaswasserinstallateur, der Immobilienmakler, der Finanzjournalist. Hertha ist der Verein für die normalen Leute, die da hingehen und ein Ventil haben, um ihren Alltag zu entfliehen, um mal, und das ist ja das Sarkast, das ist das Kuriose, dass du immer wieder mit einer neuen Hoffnung da ins Olympiastadion rennst, und dann immer geknechtest mit einer Nackenschelle nach Hause bist und sagst, ok, du hast eben nicht, du hast eben nicht das Ventil erfahren, du hast nicht glücklich und zufrieden gehst du am Montag auf Arbeit und sagst, ey cool, und beim Bäcker drängelst du dich vor, weil der Unioner dann keinen Pfandkuchen mehr kriegen soll oder irgendwas. Aber nein, das ist doch dieser Stolz, diese Zufriedenheit, dieses Ventil der Emotion am Wochenende in diesem Stadion, mit den Kumpels, mit den Freunden und des Austausches zu sein.
Hertha für den normalen Fan, Marc. Das wollte Kay Bernstein. Ich habe in der Vorbereitung immer wieder darüber nachgedacht, finde ich vergleichbare Persönlichkeiten im deutschen Fußball. Und hier habe ich mal so eine Synergie gefunden. Peter Fischer ist für mich der einzige Präsident gewesen, der ähnlich aus Sicht der Fans über seinen Verein und über ihren Verein gesprochen hat.
Das ist total richtig. Ich habe irgendwann auch schon mal über eine Parallele nachgedacht, vielleicht, weil die sogar mal übereinander geredet haben oder so. Ich glaube, da bestand auch ein Verhältnis der Wertschätzung. Die haben sich, glaube ich, öfter mal auf irgendwelchen VIP-Tribünen länger ausgetauscht. Ich glaube, da gab es eine Wertschätzung und die ist ja auch begründet. Ja, Hertha für den normalen Fan. Ich glaube, das war Hertha schon immer. Tatsächlich. Also Hertha hat sich immer als Verein für die gesamte Stadt gefühlt, auch für Teile Brandenburgs. Also wenn man den Stadion-Trecher Fabian von Wachsmann kurz vor Antwoch hört, heißt es immer Berliner Brandenburger, nicht nur Berliner. Aber auch wirklich alle Berliner. Und nicht nur einzelne Stadtteile. Es gibt Bezirks-T-Shirts von Hertha, die gehen immer weg. Und Leute wollen noch, gefühlt ihren kleinsten Kiez noch da drauf gedruckt bekommen von Hertha, weil sie sagen, das brauchen wir auch noch, das brauchen wir auch noch. Also man findet auch alle aus der Stadt. Ich finde es interessant, was er auch gesagt hat, weil ich ja vorher auch gesagt habe, Spieler waren auch teilweise beliebig. Spieler waren wirklich wie Waren zu gewissen Zeitpunkten. Verbesserst du uns, verbesserst du uns nicht, wenn nicht, okay, tschüss. Sehr gesichtslos oftmals eingekauft worden. Besonders natürlich in der Winterzeit war das sehr beliebig. Und wenn ich jetzt darauf gucke, wie beispielsweise mit dem Marco Richter, auch mit dem Jean-Paul Boetius damals umgegangen wurde, klar schwere Schicksale, aber da zeigen sich ja oft auch die wahren Gesichter des Umfeldes. Aber auch in dieser Saison, wenn wir über einen Fabian Reese reden, wenn wir über einen Toni Leissner reden, der als Ex-Unioner kam, teilweise ja sogar noch da mit Plakaten unliebsam begrüßt wurde am Trainingsgelände, wenn ich über Harald Tabakovic nachdenke oder auch über die ganz vielen Eigengewächse wie Pascal Clemens und Co. dann haben die ein völlig neues Profil als Menschen bekommen. Also wirklich, das sind jetzt eher Menschen, die gut kicken können und nicht andersrum irgendwie und auch das wurde durchaus geschaffen.
Und dann ja Harald, sehr interessant, der Verweis auf die Pandemiezeit und eben verbunden mit der Hoffnung, dass das ja DFB und DFL gelernt haben müssten, dass ohne den Fan im Stadion ist dieses Unterhaltungsprodukt wenig wert. Hast du das Gefühl, dem ist auch so?
Zumindest meine Antwort ist ganz klar, dummerweise sind wir gerade dabei, das, was man meinte, kurzzeitig gelernt zu haben, und über Bord zu werfen. Das finde ich extrem bedauerlich. Wobei unmittelbar nach der Pandemie hat man ganz, ganz viele Beispiele sammeln können, wo man sagen konnte, oh ja, jetzt ist was Neues entstanden. Jetzt ist tatsächlich so ein Ruck da durchgegangen. Man hat erkannt, dass der Fußball ohne Mitglieder, ohne Fans entweder gar nichts oder deutlich weniger wert ist. Das war so eine Zäsur, die die Pandemie quasi auf der Lernebene mitgebracht hat. Ich sage dir mal gern, das war ein riesengroßes Experiment, diese Pandemie mit der Geisterspiele, lieber mit all den gesellschaftlichen Debatten, die dann an diesem Beispiel orientiert ausgetragen wurden. Die Sonderrolle, die die DFL mit ihrem Hygienekonzept gekriegt hat. Auch im europäischen Vergleich, man konnte dann in Deutschland den Spielbetrieb wenigstens in abgespeckter Form auch recht erhalten. Das ging in anderen Regionen nicht so rund wie in Deutschland. Und vor allem in anderen Wirtschaftszweigen lief das halt längst nicht so. Fußballspieler konnten gemeinsam mit 22 Leuten, die Schützrichtern, auf den Platz hin und her laufen. Und das ganze Volk durfte nicht mehr zum Friseur gehen. Also da sahen wir ja alle ganz anders aus. Das war voll mit Sessur, wo man gemerkt hat, boah, irgendwas ist im Fußball anders. Und da hat es auch sehr viel Kritik, sehr viel Hinterfragen hat da stattgefunden. Und da musste sich der Fußball-DFL und DFB selbstkritisch mit auseinandersetzen. Christian Seifert hat das aus meiner Sicht sehr flug getan, indem er so eine Task Force ins Leben gerufen hat. Da hat sich zwar noch bei der Arbeit der Task Force quasi herausgestellt, dass das eine richtig tolle Nebelkerze war, aber vor allem dann bei der Präsentation der Ergebnisse durch die Kollegin Heidi Mückner, die dann da sagte, ihr lehnt euch mal zurück und treu vom Fußball 2032. Also da habe ich gemerkt, wenn wir den Stream wieder abschalten, das ist die Nebelkerze und nichts anderes. Dann war das letztlich auch. Und das sieht man eben jetzt dummerweise am Beispiel Investoreneinstieg. Das ist für mich jetzt die Debatte der Gegenwart, an der sich zeigt, wie leichtfertig die aktuelle DFL-Führung all diese Errungenschaften, dieses neu gewonnene Vertrauen, aber mit der Druckzucht über Bord nicht nur, sondern regelrecht kippt, indem man diese Abstimmung vom Mai dann im Spätherbst, Frühwinter nochmal wiederholt, damit Akki Watzke das Ergebnis kriegt, was er haben will, obwohl er im Mai noch gesagt hat, ein bisschen schnippig, Tschüss Demokratie. Damit ist das Thema vom Tisch. Die wollen das nicht, also ist es vom Tisch, aber ein paar Wochen später wird halt noch mal abgestimmt und wäre jetzt, hätte Martin Kind bei der letzten Abstimmung sich unter Umständen anders verhalten, hätten wir möglicherweise in drei, vier Monaten die dritte Abstimmung gehabt. Und das ist natürlich was, was ins Mark oder in den Kernbereich unseres Demokratieverständnisses einschlägt. Dann sagen auch, ihr habt überhaupt nichts gelernt. Ihr macht gerade so weiter wie vor der Pandemie und der Fußball muss wieder komplett aufgebaut und aufgestellt werden und immer noch ist die Orientierung an der Premier League das Maß aller Dinge und ihr kriegt gar nicht weg, wie viel Stimmung, wie viel Wertschöpfung in der Bundesliga und in der zweiten Liga gegenwärtig stattfindet und warum konzentriert ihr euch nicht einfach darauf und lasst die Premier League ihren Zirkus in ein paar Jahren gemeinsam mit der saudischen oder nordamerikanischen Liga abfeiern. Wie interessiert das? Also solche Fragen müsste man jetzt eingestellen.
Wenig überraschend hat Hertha-PC unter Kay Bernstein auch bei beiden Abstimmungen mit Nein gestimmt und das auch aus mehreren Gründen. Also zum einen aus sehr vielen Gründen, die Harald genannt hat, weil das Ganzheitliche nicht gesehen wird, weil die Nachhaltigkeit fehlt, weil es auch wieder dagegen geht, was wir jetzt lange besprochen haben, dass Kay Bernstein immer erst mal die Basis und die Wurzeln stärken wollte, bevor wieder groß geträumt wird. Und zum anderen, weil wir auch da den Hüter der Satzung haben, der bei der ersten Abstimmung auch dagegen gestimmt hatte, weil er gesagt hat, dass eine kommissarische Geschäftsführung gar nicht dazu befähigt ist, diese Abstimmung so durchzuführen und diesen Deal so durchzuführen. Ja, also auch da hat jemand nach den Spielregeln gespielt. Da war er vielleicht nicht der Einzige, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei anderen Vereinen aussah, die Argumentationslage dahingehend, aber ja.
Und zeigt aber ja schon genau die Ambivalenz, in der auch Kay Bernstein gefangen war. Denn der Verein, der das beste Beispiel für wildgewordene Investoren ist, stimmt gegen den Einstieg eines Investoren beim Liga-Verband. Und da sind wir ja schon beim, ich glaube, 98. Tag seiner Amtszeit angekommen. Also wirklich, die Termine waren schon gemacht zum 100. Amtstag. Da hätte er Presserunden gegeben, es hätte Podcastaufnahmen gegeben. Aber dann wurde veröffentlicht, dass es vor einem israelischen Gericht eine Anklage gibt. Und ohne jetzt den ganzen Fall nochmal aufzurollen. Es gab Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass Lars Windhorst eine Detektei damit beauftragt hatte, gegen Werner Gegenbauer Stimmung zu machen. Und das sollte dann aber das Ende von Lars Windhorst bei Hertha BSC sein. Und jetzt stand Kay Bernstein noch mehr als sonst inhaltlich unter Beobachtung der Öffentlichkeit, weil die Frage war eben, wie würde er sich jetzt verhalten? Man hat dann eine eigene Anwaltskanzlei beauftragt, eben erst mal nachzuprüfen, ob diese Anklagepunkte nachvollziehbar sind und was jetzt eigentlich die Optionen von Hertha BSC sind. Später hat er gesagt, es war für ihn eine Erleichterung, weil er wusste, jetzt werden wir Lars Windhorst los. Lars Windhorst, der sowieso schon – das kam dann auch alles erst dann so langsam raus – im Grunde mit der Wahl von Kay Bernstein hat Islas Windhorst auf dem Kapitalmarkt herumgelaufen, hat gesagt, also ich will Hertha nicht mehr haben, wer möchte es bitte haben? Und es gab dann jemand, der wollte Hertha BSC haben, Triple Seven, eine Private-Equity-Firma, die in vielen anderen Fußballvereinen auch involviert ist. Und Kay Bernstein hatte jetzt dann die Aufgabe, diesen Übergang zu moderieren und auch die Bedingungen mit Triple Seven auszuhandeln. Obwohl ja gleichzeitig Lars Windhorst, derjenige war, dessen Anteile verkauft wurden. Und das ist natürlich eine interessante Doppelrolle, die natürlich auch dann thematisiert wurde auf der Pressekonferenz, in der das Ganze, auf der das Ganze dann bekannt gegeben wurde. Und da war natürlich eine der Fragen an Kay Bernstein. Ja, mussten sie denn jetzt dann über ihren Ultraschatten springen? Ich formuliere es jetzt mal bewusst populistisch bei Um mit Triple Seven ins Geschäft zu kommen. Und das hat er dazu gesagt.
Also ich musste nicht über den Schatten springen, weil meine aktive Zeit natürlich in ein paar Jahre zurückliegt. Aber ich kann die Ängste und die Sorgen der jeweiligen Leute verstehen. Und das macht es mir ein Stück einfacher, mit ihnen zu reden. Und letztendlich, das habe ich vor neun Monaten schon gesagt, das wird ein Marathon. Und habe ich gesagt, dass wir alle ein bisschen mehr verzeihen müssen, dass wir alle ein bisschen mehr zusammenrücken müssen, dass wir alle ein bisschen mehr diesem Verein helfen müssen. Und von daher sehe ich das genauso, dass es nur miteinander geht, dass es jetzt damit ein wenig die Möglichkeit gibt, in ruhigere Fahrwasser zu kommen und das miteinander. Von daher habe ich keine Ängste, keine Sorgen, sondern mir macht eher viel mehr Hoffnung und es ist viel positiver im Miteinander. Von daher, ich sehe die Ängste, wir kriegen sie nur über Kommunikation abgebaut.
Marc, das ist natürlich richtig, dass man Ängste nur über Kommunikation abgebaut bekommt. Man konnte auch sehen, er ist kein Dogmatiker, sondern Pragmatiker. Er hat die Gelegenheit beim Schopfel gepackt. Und dennoch hat sich ja aber an der Situation von Hertha-PSC nicht verbessert, im Zweifel sogar eher verschlechtert. Wir wissen nicht genau, was in den Vertragen drin steht. Ich habe aus verschiedenen Quellen gehört. Also so arg viel weniger als seine Seele muss der Hertha-PSC nicht verkaufen, weil natürlich… Der Investor ist ein Investor und wird immer ein Investor bleiben. Aber der ursprüngliche Sündenfall war der Einstieg von KKR und nicht, dass jetzt an Tribüseppen verkauft wurde. Aber ich finde dieses Spannungsfeld, in dem da Kay Bernstein stand, das fand ich extrem interessant. Wie denkst du darüber?
Du hast schon ganz viel vorweggegriffen, würde ich sagen. Es hat sich eben gezeigt, dass da nicht nur ein Idealist sitzt, sondern jemand, der wirklich auch seinem Verein dient. Weil wenn es um Kay Bernstein gegangen wäre, dann hätte er sicherlich anders handeln können. Er hätte auch beim Fall des neuen Hauptsponsors anders handeln können und anders kommunizieren können. Aber wie Paldada nach seinem Tod sagte, Kay Bernstein hat die gefragt, was ist gut für Kay Bernstein, sondern was ist gut für Hertha-PSC. Und in dem Fall war das Kind ja schon in den Brunnen gefallen, aller, aller spätestens mit dem Einstieg von Lars Vintos und dem dann auch abrupten Ende. Und Hertha hatte nun mal nicht die finanziellen Mittel, um kurz zu sagen, ne klar, jetzt holen wir uns einfach die Anteile zurück. Das ging nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass am Anfang es eine Überlegung gab, es irgendwie hinzubekommen mit einem Art Fonds, den es beispielsweise auch bei Eintracht Frankfurt gibt oder bei dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern, einem Fonds von Hertha nahen finanzkräftigen Personen etwas aufzubauen, um sich diese Anteile quasi so nahe zu sich zurückzuholen, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Das war in der kürzeste Zeit vor allen Dingen einfach nicht zu machen. Und dann ging es darum, mit einem neuen Investor, mit einem möglichen Käufer diese Anteile einen möglichst guten Deal hinzubekommen. Und man muss ja sagen, die Verhandlung zwischen den neuen Verantwortlichen von Hertha und Triple Seven haben ja Monate gedauert. Genau. Es war ja kein Schnellschuss. Wir waren alle nicht dabei. Ich würde aber sagen, dass sich da beide Seiten versucht haben, einen besseren und klügeren Deal auszuarbeiten, als beim letzten Mal. Triple Seven hat gesehen, dass Lars Fintos, verzeiht mir, aber den dümmsten Deal aller Zeiten abgeschlossen hat. Das muss man so sagen. Also Hertha mit 375 Millionen Euro zu übergießen, was ein absurder Wert war. Ich weiß, dass lange Zeit Angebote im gleichen Maße der Anteile 200 Millionen Euro gebracht haben. Plötzlich kam Lars Fintos um die Ecke und meinte, ich lege euch das hier übrigens auf den Tisch. Gleichzeitig vertragte ich so wenig Kompetenzen, für sich selber eingebaut zu haben. Das war schon krass. Das heißt, Triple Seven wollte klüger sein als Lars Fintos und Hertha wollte klüger sein als das alte Hertha und wollte auch 50 plus 1 so gut waren, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Ich glaube, da gab es sicherlich Spannungspunkte in den Verhandlungen, weshalb es lange gedauert hat. Aber ja, es ist ja offensichtlich, dass Kay Bernstein einen ganz anderen Fußball haben möchte, dass er, wenn es nach ihm ginge, gar keine Investoren im Fußball gäbe. Das steht ja außer Frage. Aber was wäre die Alternative gewesen? Man kommt immer bei der Antwort heraus, es hätte keine gegeben, egal wie man es dreht und wendet. Und dann musste man für die eine Alternative, die man hatte, den bestmöglichen Weg finden. Und wir werden über Triple Seven vielleicht noch ein bisschen reden. Aber was man ja jetzt schon mal festhalten kann, es ist deutlich ruhiger als vorher.
Das definitiv. Wir hören mal kurz, was eine mögliche Alternative gewesen wäre, denn das hatte nämlich bei euch im Podcast auf Nachfrage erzählt.
Na, es gab schon die Gedanken – lasst uns mal den Genossenschaftsgedanken konsequenter durchspielen. Und dann waren wir aber wieder ganz schnell darauf, dass unsere kreativen Lösungsmodelle immer wieder davon abhängig gewesen wären, spielt da Lars Bintors mit Ja oder Nein? Weil es seine Anteile sind. Dann sind wir ganz schnell zu dem Entschluss gekommen, egal was wir hier aufbieten, egal ob wir sagen, unsere aktuelle Bewertung und das und das Angebot wird es geben, wird er nicht machen. Lars wird den, die ihn machen, den Lars machen möchte. Und von daher waren wir eigentlich eher in einer komfortablen Situation, dass wir sagen, okay, das sind ja gar nicht unsere Anteile, sondern es sind seine Anteile. Wir haben andere Hausaufgaben, lasst uns auf unsere Hausaufgaben konzentrieren und weiterhin ruhig, besonnen, gewissenhaft den Verein restrukturieren.
Und in dieser Machtlosigkeit, die da letztlich Kay Bernstein hatte, die er hier positiv geframet hat, also er hat gesagt, wir waren in der komfortablen Position, dass wir sagen konnten, es sind ja Lars Anteile. Ich würde sagen, uns waren die Hände gebunden, denn es sind Lars Anteile gewesen. Ich glaube, das ist Harald etwas, dass diese Erinnerungen müssen wir uns bewahren. Wenn Investoren einmal wo reingehen, dann sind die drin. Und dann kann eben genau eine solche Situation passieren. Und das könnte zum Beispiel, egal was man so alles vertraglich aufsetzt, ich weiß, da gibt es due diligence Prozesse und anderes, was man machen kann, aber das könnte zum Beispiel auch mit einem Investor bei der DFL passieren. Wenn er zum Beispiel nur einen Teil seiner Firma an Saudi-Arabien abgibt, wie es übrigens bei CWC mal diskutiert wurde, dann ist das so. Dann kann die Liga jetzt auch nicht sagen, jetzt haben wir aber das Recht, uns rauszukaufen. Ach so, und wir hätten ja das Geld gar nicht uns rauszukaufen, weil wir haben ja schon wieder alles ausgegeben. Also ich glaube, das ist doch vielleicht das, was man aus dieser Ambivalenz – Kay Bernstein, der Investorenkritiker, ist Präsident eines Investorenvereins, mitnehmen sollte. Sind Investoren einmal drin? Gehen sie mutmaßlich eigentlich nie wieder raus?
Weil ein Investor ist eben kein Mäzen. Ein Mäzen, es gibt zwar noch eine gewisse Schnittmenge zwischen manchen Investoren und ein bisschen Mäzen. Aber an sich ist ein Investor, gerade wenn er aus der Private Equity Richtung kommt, ist es ein Investor, der sein Geldgeber gegenüber in der Verpflichtung steht. Und das heißt, das Allerwichtigste und Allererste, jenseits jeder sportlichen Romantik, ist für ihn der Return of Invest. Und zwar nicht nur, dass es am Ende Nullsummenspiel wird, dafür bewegt er sich nicht aus irgendeiner Börsenstadt nach Berlin zu Hertha, sondern am Ende muss ein sattes Gewinn dabei rausspringen. Da weiß man, beim Sport, wenn du da investierst, ist ein gewisses Risiko dabei. Das heißt, der Gewinn muss entsprechend hoch sein. Und das heißt, wenn man das ökonomisch durchdenkt, für diejenigen, die an der anderen Seite des Verhandlungstisches sitzen, sprich bei eins oder DFL-Vertreter, die müssen schon wüsseln, dass sie etwas verkaufen, was dann weg ist. Und das kommt dann nicht irgendwann mal wieder zurück, sondern es ist dann weg, gehört einem anderen, und der andere will damit wirtschaften als Wirtschaftsgut. Und das ist auch sein gutes Recht. Da darf man auch nicht sonderlich dran kritisieren. Wenn er es hat, dann hat er es, und dann müssen wir uns demgegenüber auch fair verhalten. Dann gibt es einen Vertrag dazu, und dann macht er damit Geld. Deshalb hat er ja das Geld zur Verfügung gestellt und damit Lücken gefüllt bzw. Finanzlücken ausgeglichen, die die Fußballverhandlungspartner am anderen Ende des Tisches offensichtlich meinten gehabt zu haben. So, und da kommt das Thema Verantwortung für den Spiel. Das heißt, kann die jetzige Generation an Fußballmanagern, an Fußballbossen, kann die tatsächlich diese Beantwortung auf ihre Schultern laden, dass sie die Zukunft der Bundesliga aufbaut und damit den Handlungsspielraum künftiger Vereine, künftiger Vereinsbosse, künftiger Manager extremst einengt. Und das ist durchaus eine Grundsatzfrage, von der ich meine, es müsste dann auch in so einem Gremium, wie die Task Force mal angedacht war oder wie sie uns verkauft wurde, auf breiter Ebene diskutiert werden, und zwar nicht nur auf DFL-Ebene, sondern im gesamten deutschen Fußball. Deshalb finde ich es eigentlich beschämend, dass der DFB, was diesen Prozess betrifft, null, null dazu gesagt hat. Der hat dann quasi das, die DFL ganz alleine machen lassen, obwohl natürlich von solchen Entscheidungen die gesamte Fußballstruktur im Spitzenbereich betroffen ist, also auch die dritte, vierte Liga mit den Traditionsvereinen, die vielleicht in 15 Jahren mal wieder aufsteigen in die zweite oder erste Liga. Das ist alles wirklich mit heißer Nadel gestrickt gewesen. Da würde ich sagen, da habe ich einige Fragen an das Thema Verantwortung, denen sich da diese Manager auf die Schultern geladen haben. Denn Fußball ist eben nicht so ein Wirtschaftsbrut wie ein Chemieunternehmen, wie ein Autokonzern oder eine Immobilienfirma. Fußball ist etwas, was kulturell gewachsen ist, eine kulturelle Errungenschaft, was von der Mehrheit einer Gesellschaft dann auch letztendlich nutzverantwortet werden will, mitgetragen werden will. Und da darf man solche Grundsatzentscheidungen nicht so dilettantisch vorbereiten, wie es die DFL gemacht hat. Stichwort Aki Watzke nach der ersten Abstimmung sagen, okay, das ist Demokratie. Nun ist das Thema vom Tisch. Und dann, wenige Wochen später, die zweite Abstimmung auf den Plan ringt. Das ist völlig, völlig unreflektiert. Egal, welche Zwänge dahinterstehen. Dann hätte man das erstens besser vorbereiten müssen beim ersten Mal. Oder hätte zweitens den Plan B so lange diskutieren müssen, bis man den Plan A auf die Belüste von Publika gewinnen kann. Und da hat man aus meiner Sicht die durchaus vielversprechend ausschauenden Pflänzchen, die wir so im Rahmen der Pandemie, auf sportpolitischer, ökonomischer Seite der DFL gesehen haben, die hätte man weiter pflegen müssen. Man hätte eine ernsthaft gedachte Task Force über längeren Zeitraum laufen lassen können. Man hätte den Fan-Dialog, Stichwort Zukunft Fußball, da haben ja Fans in einem gigantischen Ausmaß Unterschriften gesammelt, Konzepte ausgearbeitet, die dann alle in Schubladen bei der DFL und beim DFL verschwunden sind. Und all diese ganze Arbeit, dieses ganze Fruchtbare, ist quasi nichts mehr wert, ist verloren gegangen. Das finde ich extrem bedauernd.
Und Hertha, muss man ja sagen, ist ja auch die Geschichte einer permanenten finanziellen Abhängigkeit. Sei es die finanzielle Verzweiflung, die Hertha damals dazu gebracht hat, das eigene Stadion, die Plumpe zu verkaufen, seien es die Ufer-Deals in den 90er Jahren, sei es der KKA-Deal, sei es das Schmeißen an einen Investor wie Lars Windhorst. Das ist historisch gewachsen bei Hertha. Und Kay Bernstein nach 100 Tagen im Amt, 100 Jahre, das wäre beeindruckend. Aber selbst nach 100 Jahren hätte er dieses Problem wahrscheinlich kaum gelöst bekommen. Und besonders nach 100 Tagen, wo man überhaupt erst mal in diesem Amt ankommt, also er war ja eigentlich immer noch in der Bestandsaufnahme, in dem was passiert denn hier gerade, und dann wird ihm dieser erste riesige Klotz in die Speichen geworfen, war nicht in der Lage, diese über Jahrzehnte gewachsene finanzielle Notlage zu lösen, besonders wenn es um verkaufte Anteile geht, wo du eben sowieso, bis auf gewisse vielleicht Matching Rights oder ähnliches, eh keine Handhabe hast. Und das war in der Form nicht zu lösen, und das wusste er, aber es wird ihn sehr wahrscheinlich ideologisch zerrissen haben, diese Situation.
Eine Sache würde ich da gerne noch ergänzen. Die ersten 100 Tage, dann kommt es plötzlich zu solchen, zu so einer Konstellation mit den dann ins Laufen gekommenen Verhandlungen. Man muss sich mal vorstellen, bei der Hertha wäre dann zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht Kay Bernstein Präsident gewesen, sondern ein anderer.
Vielleicht jemand, der mit Lars Windhorst Essen gegangen ist nach der Mitgliederversammlung.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht. Oder wie auch immer. Dann wäre die Ausgangsposition im Verhandeln mit den neuen Investoren eine völlig andere gewesen. Sodass man sagen kann, das ist für die Hertha schon ein Riesenplus, dass so jemand am Verhandlungstisch saß, der dann auch in öffentlichen Interviews eine Haltung transportiert hat, hochprofessionell nach dem Motto, wir sind ausgelassen. Es ist jetzt nicht unsere Aufgabe, das Zeug zu kaufen. Lass sie doch mal kommen. Der will doch sein Zeug verkaufen. Dann schauen wir mal, welchen Deal wir so hinbekommen. Dann wusste der gegenüber, der Investor, ganz genau, mit wem man da am Tisch sitzt. Das hat die Konstellation der Verhandlung auf ein Niveau gestellt, was für die Hertha, auch wenn es jetzt letztlich nicht rosig ist, aber was für die Hertha schon mal eine ganz gute Ausgangsposition in diesem schlechten Kontext gewesen ist. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Also da meine ich, die Ausgangssituation war allein durch Kay Bernstein für die Hertha schon mal eine richtig gute. Und das schätze ich jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal zu.
Ja, das sieht man ja auch. Alles Positive, was wir besprochen haben, was mit Kay Bernstein – es muss ja nicht alles durch Kay Bernstein passiert sein – aber eben Mitgliederzuwachs, Stimmungsumschwung im Umfeld, Zuschauerzahlen – fantastisch! Sowohl in der Abstiegssaison als auch jetzt in der Zweitligasaison. Das alles plus eben auch das Aufbauen einer gemeinsamen Identität, die sich dann auch in Marketing usw. durchsetzt. Also das ist ja nicht nur seine blaue Jacke, die ikonische, die sich ja viel verkauft hat. Das sind ja auch alles Dinge, wo auch ein Investor sagt, das finden wir gar nicht so schlecht, lieber Kay, mach mal weiter so. Denn das ist gut für das Produkt. Also auch das kommt ja mit dazu, auch diese Nebeneffekte. Nicht nur die Verhandlungsposition, sondern auch, dass man gesehen hat, Hertha war schon in einem Wandel begriffen. Wir greifen jetzt natürlich ein bisschen aus der Zukunft zurück in die Vergangenheit. Alles sichtbar war noch nicht, aber vieles davon schon, dass da etwas im Wandel war. Und das macht natürlich Hertha auch nochmal Interessante für einen Investor. Und dann hat Hertha wiederum auf der anderen Seite eine Verhandlungsmasse, ist in einer besseren Position zu sagen, nun ja, ihr seht ja gerade, was wir hier machen. Ihr seht aber, das ist unser Weg. Deswegen unseren Weg, den wollen wir so weitermachen. Ihr könnt dann euch daran beteiligen. Aber dieser Weg wird nicht geändert. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein interessanter Punkt. Und macht es dann auch, glaube ich, auch einfacher zu verstehen, wie Kay Bernstein das alles kommuniziert hat. Ich habe hier noch zwei O-Töne nochmal von der Pressekonferenz. Das eine ist, da wird er auf den Umgang mit Investoren generell angesprochen. Und das andere, und das ist natürlich hochinteressant, ist dann, wie er auf die Kritik der Szene von Hertha BSC reagiert hat, die es natürlich gab. Aber wir hören uns erstmal kurz an, was er zum Umgang mit Investoren gesagt hat.
Wir haben mit KKA eigentlich unter Beweis gestellt, dass wir vernünftig mit Investoren umgehen können. Wir haben mit Lars Windhorst unter Beweis gestellt, dass wir das nicht ganz so gut händeln können. Jetzt haben wir die dritte Partnerschaft und wir haben doch auch ein bisschen aus den Fehlern der Vergangenheit gelernt. Und das hat viel mit dem Erwartungsmanagement zu tun. Das hat viel mit Kommunikation zu tun. Und das hat viel mit dem Miteinander, wie Thomas gesagt hat, auf Augenhöhe zu tun. Und wir wollen von dem Netzwerk profitieren. Wir wollen von den Expertisen profitieren im Reflektieren, der Blickwinkel im Überlegen. Sind wir mit unserer Entscheidung, mit unserer Idee auf dem richtigen Weg? Und was sagt die Expertise dazu? Von daher ist es im Prozess-Sinne immer ein Abgleichen. Haben wir das Beste für Hartha BSC entschieden.
Der angesprochene Tom, das ist Tom Herrich, der war im Lead bei den Verhandlungen mit Triple Seven. Aber das ist ja interessant, Marc, dass da jemand davon spricht, na ja, wir – also eigentlich kann es ja gar nicht er gewesen sein, er war ja noch nicht da – aber wir als Hertha BSC haben jetzt nach zwei Investoren-Modellen, die wir schon mal hatten, haben wir aus den Fehlern gelernt. Und es geht vor allem um Kommunikation und um Erwartungsmanagement.
Total, total. Also wir können – Lars Winthaus und sein Investment würden ein eigentliches Tribünengespräch verdienen, da könnte man ewig drüber reden. Und Lars Winthaus hat so ziemlich alles falsch gemacht, was man falsch machen kann, würde ich behaupten. Gleichzeitig hat – befreit das aber nicht Hertha von einer Schuld. Denn du kannst als Werner Gegenbauer und Co. auch nicht sagen, ja ist schön, dass du jetzt übrigens deine 300 Millionen hier investiert hast, 400 Millionen, aber jetzt außerhalb von irgendwelchen Quartalsberichten jetzt mit dir groß reden, boah, nö. Also man hat jetzt also auch wirklich sich nicht unbemüht, ein gutes und gesundes Verhältnis zum Investor und seinen Beratern aufzubauen. Es waren ja dann auch unterschiedliche Beraterkonstellationen, ob Jürgen Klinsmann oder Jens Lehmann. Es fühlt sich auch sehr unwirklich an, diese Namen auszusprechen, ich weiß.
Also aus unterhaltungstechnischer Sicht hat Lars Winters alles richtig gemacht. Man konnte so gut über Hartha sprechen wie selten in dieser Zeit.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtig.
Haru he euer Jürgen.
So ist es nämlich, so ist es nämlich. Aber ich kann verstehen, also es gab schon Leute, die gesagt haben, dass Kay jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen den Marktschreier macht und ein bisschen zu positiv verkauft, als das, was es eigentlich ist. Es ist wieder das Eingehen einer Abhängigkeit, jetzt sogar vielleicht in einem finanziellen Rahmen, der so schlecht war wie noch nie zuvor, weil du finanziell so verzweifelt warst. Wir sprechen darüber, dass wohl quasi alle ausschüttbaren Gewinne in Zukunft an Triple Seven gehen würden, wobei ich da immer anfüge, wann wurden im Fußball das letzte Mal Gewinne ausgeschüttet. Das würde ich auch mal kritisch hinterfragen. In der Regel gibt es die nicht oder sie werden wieder investiert. Man investiert das Geld eher, bevor man es ausschüttet. Es gibt da schon Konstellationen, ohne jetzt die Verträge im Detail zu kennen, wo man sagt, wie Hertha sich davon lossagen soll. Irgendwann wird es schwierig. Denn ich sprach ja auch schon über die finanzielle Abhängigkeit der vergangenen Jahrzehnte, in denen Hertha nie eigene Werte aufgebaut hat. Hertha besitzt kein Stadion. Hertha ist eigentlich nur Gast auf diesem Olympiagelände. Es gibt keine eigenen Werte, die man dagegen halten könnte, um zu sagen, wir bürgen jetzt damit und damit, um dann wieder uns die Anteile zurückzuwenden. Das gibt es nicht. Da ist man sehr, sehr leicht auf der Brust. Aber das war jetzt, wie gesagt, davon, Bernstein und Co. nicht zu lösen in der kurzen Zeit. Jetzt haben wir ja schon sehr viel über Kay Bernstein und seine Kommunikation gesprochen. Daraus geht ja schon hervor, dass er ein besserer Kommunikator ist als seinen Vorgänger. Und so ruhig, wie es jetzt seitdem ja auch zwischen Hertha und Triple Seven ist, also es wird ja eigentlich nicht übereinander gesprochen, kann man ja schon sagen, dass anscheinend da kommunikativ einiges richtig gemacht wird. gleichzeitig erkennt man aber mit der Zeit jetzt auch mehr, wie man sich da eigentlich ins Haus geholt hat. Also Triple Seven ist schon ein Investor, der zwar nicht wie die Citigroup gefühlt Logos verändern möchte und alles standardisieren möchte, aber man hat mit Johannes Sporz, jemandem, der auch am Netzwerk der TSG Hoffmann beteiligt war, du hast mit, vorne weiß ich nicht, Edwards, jemanden, der die Citigroup mit aufgebaut hat, also eigenes Kompetenznetzwerk haben sie aufgebaut und die schon versuchen, in den Vereinen das Vakuum, was es teilweise gibt, mit eigenen Leuten zu schließen. Das war genua jetzt zu sehen mit Sportdirektor und Trainer. Und es gilt als Verbrieft, dass, wenn es nach Triple Seven geht, Werpaldada nicht mehr Trainer von Hertha Bessey. Das wäre nach Triple Sevens Meinung eigentlich auch nie geworden nochmal. Aber er ist es geworden und das spricht ja auch schon dafür, dass offensichtlich Hertha sich seinen Handlungsspielraum weiterhin erkämpft und da nicht in irgendwelche Hinterzimmerdeals oder ähnliches abdriftet, sondern das entscheidet immer noch Benny Weber, das entscheidet immer noch Tom Herrich und das hat bis zuletzt auch immer noch Kay Bernstein entschieden. Und es gibt schon diese Angst unter Hertha-Fans, was passiert jetzt ohne den Hüter von 50 plus 1 Kay Bernstein mit diesem Deal? Wird es krassere Einflussnahme seitens Triple Seven geben, die ja auch Druck haben? Also Triple Seven ist finanziell selber sehr eigenartig aufgebaut. Man weiß überhaupt nicht, wie langlebig das ist. Das wirkt sehr wackelig und man hat das Gefühl, sie wollten sich irgendwie in diesem Premier League Deal mit dem FC Everton jetzt retten und von dort aus versuchen, das irgendwie wieder zu gesunden. Ob das klappt, boah, schwierig. Dementsprechend versuchen sie aber natürlich, je enger sich die Schnalle um ihren Hals windet, umso mehr versuchen sie natürlich bei jedem einzelnen Verein, dann auch Einfluss zu nehmen nach ihrem Gusto. Das wird auch eine Aufgabe sein, die Kay Bernstein überdauert und wo man aber auch den eingeschlagenen Berliner Weg, über den wir noch reden werden, dem man da weiter für ihn ehren wird.
Ja, so Triple Seven ist sowieso nochmal ein ganz interessantes Thema. Stand der Aufnahme 3. Februar und 2. Februar ist die Übernahme oder der Einstieg bei Everton immer noch nicht von der Premier League geprüft und gestartet worden. Und da gibt es ganz offensichtlich Gründe für, habe ich hier im Rasenfunk auch schon häufiger darüber gesprochen. Jetzt wollte ich aber noch auf diesen einen Teil eingehen, nämlich die Kritik der Ultras am Investoreneinstieg. Nicht nur an Triple Seven, sondern es ging da auch um die DFL. Und auch hier haben wir wieder das übergeordnete Thema Kay Bernstein, der Kommunikator. So hat er auf der Pressekonferenz darauf reagiert.
Noch habe ich nicht mit den Jungs gesprochen. Ich würde denken, dass es in zweierlei Richtungen geht. Das geht zum einen in unsere Richtung, von wegen wir haben Sorge, dass dieses neue Commitment, dass diese neue Partnerschaft ähnlich grandios scheitert, wie die vorher liegende. Natürlich haben die Jungs Ängste und Sorgen. Spielt aber mit Sicherheit auch ein bisschen der DFL-Prozess damit rein. Auch dafür war es genannt. Wir nehmen die Sorgen und die Nöte ernst, sehen aber die Verantwortung allen gegenüber. Von daher Kommunikation, Dialog und mit den Leuten reden und Ängste abbauen.
So kann es doch funktionieren, Harald, wenn man miteinander spricht. Und ich fand es interessant, dass du gesagt hast, wir sehen die Sorgen und Ängste aller. Das war nämlich zum Beispiel auch etwas, da habe ich jetzt keine Schnipsel mitgebracht. Aber wenn wir uns erinnern, Auslöser für seine Kandidatur war ein Livestream mit Lars Vintors nach dem ersten Sieg seit dem 30-jährigen Krieg. Und dennoch, die Art und Weise, wie er über Lars Vintors dann nach seiner erfolgreichen Kandidatur gesprochen hat, die habe ich als wohlwollend und wertschätzend empfunden. Er hat immer wieder fast schon Werbung gemacht für die Perspektive von Lars Vintors. Er hat immer wieder Dinge gesagt in Interviews, wie es ist doch völlig klar, dass Lars mitgenommen werden möchte. Der hat so viel Geld reingesteckt. Wir können dem doch nicht nur einmal im Quartal Zahlen schicken, das, was du auch schon angedeutet hast, Marc, was offenbar in der Zeit davor passiert ist. Sondern natürlich müssen wir hören, was sagt er dazu? Er muss mitgenommen werden. Und das finde ich interessant, weil das nämlich sogar in diesem Oto drin steckte, obwohl es ja eigentlich um die Kritik der Ultras ging. Aber er hat gesagt, wir müssen die Perspektiven aller sehen. Und das scheint offenbar eine Stärke von ihm gewesen zu sein, denn er hat das auf der Geschäftsstelle genauso geschafft, wie er auch zum Beispiel mit der organisierten Szene und offensichtlich auch wie mit den neuen Investoren.
Ja, die Perspektive aller ist immer dann relevant, wenn man mit mehreren Leuten eine gemeinsame Sache machen will. Und man kann nur dann auf die Perspektive aller verzichten, wenn man Sachen alleine machen will, aber auch alleine machen kann. Dann ist man in der luxuriösen Situation vielleicht ein bisschen einsam, aber man macht sein Ding. Und in so einem komplexen Gebilde wie dem Profifußball ist das Illusion. Da kannst du dein Ding nicht machen, aber du hast deine Meinung. Du sagst, ich würde es so machen, ich würde auf Investoren verzichten, ich würde an dieser Stelle drehen und an der Schraube ein bisschen anders einstellen und dann würde das ganze Schiff Hertha wesentlich besser fahren. Das kann ich alleine sagen, als jemand, der aus der Kurve kommt, als jemand, der das aus der Straßenbahn heraus beobachtet, beurteilt oder auch als jemand, der dem Ganzen als Präsident vorsteht. Wenn man allerdings in der Verantwortung ist, weiß man, dass es viele Experten im Fußball gibt, dass es auch viele Möglichkeiten gibt, viele Lösungen gibt und dass man irgendwann so etwas wie einen Kurs braucht, wo man hin will und dieser Kurs ist mit Werten ausgestattet, an denen man sich orientiert. Der Kurs ist in einer Satzung idealerweise hinterlegt und da muss man hin und dann ist es tatsächlich uns, die die Führungsverantwortung übernehmen, dass sie dann eben die verschiedenen Perspektiven berücksichtigen können und idealerweise sogar, dass sie noch ein Stückchen mehr machen, dass sie sich nämlich von den unterschiedlichsten Perspektiven noch einen Plus besprechen. Dass man jemanden nicht einfach nur mitnimmt, sondern dass man jemanden in seiner Position dazu anschiebt, noch einen draufzusetzen, einen neuen Impuls zu setzen, der das ganze Kommunikationsgebilde nochmal ganz neu bereichert, nochmal ganz neu belegt. Also das ist so für das Thema Leadership, für das Thema Führung eines so komplexen Gebildes, wie einem traditionellen Fußballverein. Ein absolutes Ausrufezeichen und das können tatsächlich nur wenige, weil eben die typische Sozialisation derer, die im Fußball Verantwortung übernehmen oder übernehmen sollen, meistens so eine einseitige Perspektive ist. So nach dem Motto, ich weiß, wie es geht, lauft alle hinter mir her und dann wirft es auch schon gut. Und von diesem Ross müssten eigentlich so manche Fußballanführer mal runtersteigen, absteigen, sich selbst in ihre Person zurücknehmen und das ganze Gebilde wachsen lassen. Das ist die hohe Kunst und das ist auch ein wahrscheinliches Erfolgsrezept, was auch alle anderen Flugs mal auf dich wirken lassen sollten, weil da kann man enorm viel auslernen. Also ich finde, es liegt in der Natur des Fußballs es nicht zu tun und es ist die große Besonderheit bei der Hertha, dass man es in den letzten zwei Jahren dort genauso gelernt hat. Und das ist wirklich ein absolutes Ausrichtungsfeld.
Ich fand es in der Phase halt sehr spannend, als er kandidiert hat und wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass er in den ersten 100 Tagen ja gefühlt gar nicht selber reden musste, weil ja schon trotzdem die Artikel produziert wurden und gewisse Kampagnen liefen. Da wurde ja das Bild gezeichnet des Pyro-Präsidenten, der ihm wahrscheinlich eine Engstöhnigkeit attestiert, ohne dass er überhaupt etwas beweisen durfte. Ihm wurde ja schon gesagt, der wird viel zu idealistisch für dieses Geschäft sein. Wie soll der Professionalität in so einen Verein bringen? Und auf der einen Seite haben wir schon über die Wärme geredet, die dieser Verein wieder ausstrahlt. Aber der Verein kommuniziert auch so professionell wie seit Jahren nicht mehr. Also das ist ja das Lustige daran, dass das offensichtlich auch Kommunikation und Professionalität anders gelebt werden kann, als es die Etablierten dieses Sports für sich definieren und für sich quasi auch schon exklusiv halten, dass es ja nur diesen einen Weg gäbe. Und dass dann jemand kommt, der damit gar nichts zu tun hat, aber halt eine Event- und Kommunikationsagentur für zwölf Jahre geleitet hat und kurzerhand beweisen kann, ne, funktioniert auch so. Und da ist plötzlich der Ex-Ultra sehr viel pragmatischer und professioneller und transparenter in seiner Kommunikation, als es die vielen langjährigen Manager in ihrer Zeit sind und waren. Das finde ich irgendwie einen interessanten Punkt.
Ja, und das ist ja schon aufgefallen vorhin, als er gesagt hat, wir wollen die Hertha für alle sein. Da hat er nicht nur den Gaswasser-Installateur genannt, sondern er hat auch – da bin ich kurz zusammengezogen – den Immobilienmakler und den Finanzunglör genannt. Und das ist aber genau das, dass man eben quasi nicht aufhört bei der eigenen Bubble, die man so erlebt hat, sondern eben auch in dem Fall das Unternehmertum mitdenkt. Und ich glaube, da können wir nochmal zurückgehen in seine Sozialisation. Denn wenn er über Fußball spricht, dann hat er da sowohl im Kleinen als auch im Großen immer wieder über dieses Verbindende gesprochen. Und dazu habe ich jetzt zwei O-Töne, die wir an der Stelle mal hören können. Weil ich glaube, daher kommt das und ich glaube, das ist etwas, eine Perspektive, die manchem anderen Entscheidungsträger im Fußball einfach fehlt.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn man keine Bindung zum Fußball hat. Aber für mich gibt es nichts Vergleichbares auf dieser Welt, wo sich fremde Menschen natürlich mit der Einstellung, natürlich mit der Begeisterung für dieselbe Sache, nämlich die Mannschaft und den Verein, aber wildfremde Menschen sich bei einem Tor, bei einem Ereignis, was sie glücklich macht, in den Armen liegen. Also das hat man nicht mal im Kreißsaal, obwohl es auch der glücklichste und wahrhaftigste Moment ist. Aber im Fußballstadion hast du diesen Moment Wochenende für Wochenende, wo sich wildfremde Menschen in den Arm fallen, weil sie glückselig sind. Das ist ja, finde ich, so die große Macht des Fußballs. Weil nennen wir mal was Vergleichbares, wo wir – also wir können ja Stand heute sagen, dass unsere Gesellschaft leicht auseinander differenziert ist, dass wir nicht mehr andere Meinungen zulassen, dass wir zunehmend uns in unterschiedlichsten Bubbles bewegen. Der eine mit dem, der andere mit dem, der andere mit dem. Und dann kommen an einem Samstag 50.000 Leute zusammen, die relativ unterschiedlich geprägt, unterschiedlich in ihren Bubbles sind. Und das lassen sie aber völlig außen vor und wären zu einem.
Dass Homogene in Heterogenen und daraus dann wieder abgeleitet, Harald, eben eine angehende andere Sichtweise, glaube ich, auf den Fußball insgesamt als Industrie, in dem Emotionen eine Rolle spielen, aber – und in dem dann in der Emotion löst sich alles auf, was identitätsstiftend ist, Herkunft, Sozialität und so weiter und so fort. Und man wird zu einer homogenen Masse, aber man bleibt ja dennoch, wenn man aus dem Stadion herausgeht, wieder etwas Heterogenes. Was sind deine Gedanken dazu, wenn Kay Bernstein so über Fußball spricht?
Ja, und das, was du jetzt so quasi anmoderiert hast, um da gleich drauf einzugehen, das ist ja an sich ein genialer Widerspruch. Die Heterogenität und die Homogenität, die sich in einem Augenblick plötzlich beschmelzt. Und da fragt man sich, ja woran liegt das? Dieser Augenblick wird einzig und allein getragen von dem Phänomen des Fußballspiels, was dort unten auf dem Rasen gerade stattfindet. Und dieses Fußballspiel ist grundsätzlich offen. Sepp Hermberger hat mal gesagt, die Menschen gehen deshalb zum Fußball, weil sie nicht wissen, wie es ausgeht. Das ist auch heute noch so, selbst wenn Bayern München kommt, man hofft darauf, heute ist es soweit, heute lassen sie Punkte liegen, und zwar bei uns, in unserem Stadion. Das ist die Faszination, die Offenheit des Spiels, die Offenheit der Ereignisse und die wiederum liegt an der Struktur dieses Spiels, so wie das organisiert ist. Das Spiel wird mit den Füßen gespielt, was jetzt einerseits eine Selbstverständlichkeit ist, aber was rein technisch gesehen enorm viele Unwägbarkeiten in dieses Spiel mit reinbringen. Unsere Top-Fußballer spielen mit ihren Füßen ziemlich gut. Sie schießen den Ball ab und treffen auch dorthin, wo sie hin treffen wollen. Aber das Kuriose ist, denen stehen elf andere Fußballer gegenüber, die annähernd genauso gut sind wie unsere Hertha-Spieler, die das Gleiche versuchen. Dadurch kommt eine Konstellation zustande, wo permanent Abpraller vorkommen, wo permanent Flanken auch mal abrutschen und jemanden treffen, den keiner auf dem Schirm hatte, und plötzlich wird ein Tor gemacht, was eigentlich gar nicht möglich gewesen wäre. Aber es ist nun mal da und eine neue Realität geschaffen. Und deshalb ist das Fußball auch aus unterhaltungsbezogener Sicht das beste Drama, was man sich nur vorstellen kann. Und wir wissen ganz genau, dass jedes Spiel seine eigene Dramaturgie hat. Es gibt zwar ein Drehbuch, es gibt eine große Geschichte, wie das alles so organisiert ist und abläuft, aber ich kann mir sicher sein, irgendwas passiert und irgendwas wird diesen Punkt des Verschmelzens zwischen Heterogenität, Max, wie du das vorhin genannt hast, und Homogenität wird das auslösen. Und das ist kein inflationäres Auslösen. Das passiert nicht in jedem Spiel. Und das passiert schon gar nicht 10, 12 Mal in einem Spiel. Das ist was Exklusives. Und ich brauche auch eine gewisse Reife, um nicht dem in geben zu können. Deshalb ist Fußball nach meinem Dafürhalt auch kein Unterhaltungs-Instant-Produkt. So wie es jetzt die Baller League auf den Weg bringen will, die damit wirkt oder von dem Vorurteil ausgeht, die nachwachsende Generation ist nicht mehr in der Lage, 90 Minuten im Fußballspiel zu verarbeiten und zu begreifen. Und da sage ich ja, das kann gut sein. Aber die sind in der Lage, sich das zu erwerben, das irgendwann zu lernen. Und irgendwann ist es so weit, dann kommen sie in den Genuss, sich darauf einzulassen, auf diese genialische Dramaturgie. Und wer das nicht macht, hat selber Schuld. Der kann dann irgendwo anders hingehen und kann Instant-Produkte sich anschauen, kann sich das Dschungelcamp, die Baller League oder sonst was anschauen, um kurzweilige Unterhaltung zu haben. Fußball hat – Max, da finde ich deine Metapher richtig – Fußball hat diesen Moment, wo Heterogenität und Homogenität plötzlich auf einen Punkt zusammenkommen. Und das ist etwas, was uns erfüllt und was uns auch anzieht. Man könnte fast sagen, ein bisschen süchtig macht. Wer das einmal erlebt hat, der möchte da immer wieder hingehen. Und das kann man aus allen Schilderungen rauslesen, wo Menschen über ihre Stage und Erlebnisse sprechen, die sie dann als 12- 13- 14-Jährige erlebt haben, gehabt haben. Da sind sie anfangs nur aus Neugierde auf das Spektakel mal mitgekommen und plötzlich haben sie das erlebt. Plötzlich hat das gebunden. Plötzlich sagen sie, okay, es dauert vielleicht, aber irgendwann kommt es wieder, ich gehe wieder hin. Und wenn es mal in einem Spiel nicht stattgefunden hat oder vielleicht auch in drei Spielen miteinander nicht, man weiß, irgendwann kommt es. Ich will dabei sein. Und wenn du mal krank warst und dein Verein hat ein geniales Spiel, und du warst nicht dabei, da hast du richtig lange dran zu knabbern. Und du bist so richtig, du bist dann Fan zweiter Klasse, wenn du mit deinen Kumpels darüber gehst. Du denkst mal, die sind so explosiv. Aber ich bin froh, dass ich die als Freunde habe. Sie können es mir immer wieder erzählen, auch wenn es mit einer gewissen Häme. Und da kommt noch ein weiterer Aspekt dahin zu, die Leichtigkeit. Es ist ja nur als ob dieser Moment, der für uns dann so wichtig ist, wenn Heterogenität, Homogenität da in Peins verschmelzen, ist für diesen Moment das Wichtigste, was auf der Welt passiert. Obwohl wir gleichzeitig wissen, objektiv gesehen…
Der Kreißsaal wäre wichtiger eigentlich.
An den großen Themen dieser Welt ändert sich dadurch nichts. Aber ich kann mich einfach so zum Spaß darauf einlassen. Und ich kann mich als ganze Person vollends damit identifizieren und darauf einlassen. Und es hat dann objektiv gesehen auch keine wirklichen Konsequenzen für mich. Das heißt, ich leide, wenn mein Druck absteigt. Aber ich verdiene deshalb nicht weniger Geld. Oder bin deshalb privat und glücklicher oder so. Sondern, okay, ich gucke dann in der zweiten Liga. Und auch da finde ich diese Momente, die die gleiche Qualität haben. Wenn Hertha in der zweiten Liga gewinnt, hat sie die gleiche Qualität, als würden sie in der ersten Liga gewinnen. Und das ist das Geniale. Also diese Leichtigkeit und diese Faszination solcher genialischen Momente.
Und jetzt haben wir eben Marc jemanden, der das nicht nur im WIP-Bereich erlebt hat, sondern er hat es im WIP-Bereich erlebt. Denn die werden sich da auch freuen. Ich will es nicht so tun, als ob WIPs nicht auch richtige Fans sein könnten. Das ist, glaube ich, eine große Fehleinschätzung, die man hat. Aber er hat es sowohl dort erlebt auf der Haupttribüne als auch unten in der Kurve. Und er hat es auswärts in Cottbus genauso erlebt wie zu Hause gegen Bayern München. Und das hat einen Wert. Und ich glaube, an der Person Kay Bernstein und an seinem Wirken kann man ablesen, dieser Wert ist dann doch vielleicht mehr als Romantik.
Es ist Lebensinhalt. Und vor allen Dingen kann er nachvollziehen, dass das Lebensinhalt anderer ist. Und wie wichtig das ist. Und wie sie sich eben in der Zeit vor ihm gefühlt haben, dass ihm dieser Verein irgendwie durch die Finger rinnt, dass davon nicht viel übrig ist. Dass da zwar noch ein Stadion steht und da steht irgendwie eine Geschäftsstelle, aber es lebt nicht. Es ist so kalt und tot. Das hat er genauso gespielt wie alle anderen auch und kann dementsprechend nachvollziehen, wie wichtig das ist. Es kann deren Sorgen nachvollziehen und kann dann, um vielleicht den Bogen zu spannen, auch nachvollziehen, warum ihnen 50 plus 1 so wichtig ist. Warum sie Angst vor Triple Seven haben. Warum sie Angst vor der Zukunft haben. Und kann versuchen, durch Kommunikation diese Dinge zu lösen. Und da muss er nicht mal irgendeine Rolle spielen, wenn er auf Augenhöhe sein möchte, sondern er muss sich einfach nur daran erinnern, wie es für ihn war, als er an der Kurve stand.
Und das führt eben zu einem Verständnis und eben zu dem Verantwortungsgefühl, was wir vorhin hatten. Also Thorsten Lieberknecht hat mal diesen wunderbaren Satz gesagt bei Dammstadt 98. Ich habe ihn schon zwei- dreimal zitiert, aber er ist einfach so gut. Er hat gesagt, wir, wir Spieler und wir Trainer, wir sind nur zu Gast bei diesem Verein. Der Verein, er gehört den Fans und den Mitgliedern. Und ich glaube, Kay Bernstein hat ähnlich gedacht eben in seinem Verantwortungsgefühl und musste dabei dann eben auch Dinge tun, die vielleicht seiner inneren Überzeugung widersprochen haben oder wo er auch wusste, das widerspricht jetzt vielleicht einem Teil der Fanstruktur, aus dem er herkommt. Und da gibt es noch ein zweites Beispiel. Da ist es nicht so der Einstieg von Triple Seven bei Hertha BSC, sondern wir hören uns mal etwas an, was er vor seiner Wahl gesagt hat. Und Marc, du darfst uns dann erklären, warum das dann danach nochmal Thema wurde.
Und natürlich kann man über Alkohol wie Kaffee oder andere Dinge genauso reden. Also man könnte sogar noch den Spagat hinbekommen zu sagen, okay, Wett-Sponsoring ist nur eine reine Präsenzfläche auf einer Bande, aber nicht ein Aktivierungskanal, wo wir von Facebook, Instagram bewusst unsere jungen User sozusagen in die Hände der Wettpaten sozusagen spülen. Und wenn die Wettpaten dann auch noch das Image haben, dass sie ja eigentlich, nicht nur eigentlich, sondern alle Wettanbieter haben gegen das Gesetz geklagt, von wegen macht euch mal frei, reglementiert das wirklich, achtet darauf, dass der Wettspieler sozusagen maximal 1000 Euro im Monat verliert. Dagegen haben aber alle geklagt, weil sie das gar nicht wollen. Und am Ende gewinnt sozusagen immer die Bank. Und es ist nicht nur für das Erlebnis im Stadion, für das Erlebnis, also wie viele Fußballspieler wetten, um Siegprämie zu egalisieren. Wie viele Leute sitzen im Stadion da und gucken, ob der Schein kommt oder nicht. Wie viele Leute kommen wirklich weg von der eigentlichen Faszination Fußball, über den es geht nur noch um Geld und wetten, wetten, wetten. Da sage ich, es ist Gift. Und wenn ich mir sozusagen und deswegen die Vision etwas wünschen dürfte, dann geht es ohne Wett-Bonsoring. Und natürlich ist es – bei Hertha ist das Bonsoring-Agreement eine knappe Million. Eine Million ist ganz viel Geld. Glaube aber, dass du meinetwegen mit dem Krankenkassenverband sozusagen eine Suchtpräventionskampagne aufsetzen könntest, um stattdessen sozusagen auf die Fläche zu gehen und für Suchtprävention und für einen Wertegerüst zu werben und kriegst das damit kompensiert. Glaube auch, dass wenn du als Verein eine Haltung hast, wenn du für etwas stehst, wo dich Sponsoren sozusagen dein Image wählen buchen, also bei Hertha sind wir uns einig, da bucht kein Bonsoor unsere Markenvielfalt aufgrund unserer Images, sondern nur aufgrund der Reichweite und der TKB-Bewertung über die Ausspielung im Fernsehen und sonst irgendwo. Wenn wir aber Haltung und ein wirkliches Image haben, kommen doch aber auch ganz wieder andere Partner dazu, die sagen, geil, von dem Image will ich profitieren, da will ich das ein bisschen was abfärbt, also gehe ich da rein, will sagen, wenn wir unseren Markenkern und unsere DNA nach außen auch wertebasiert darstellen, kriegen wir auch wiederum andere Sponsoren. Und bei den Wettanbietern ist es so, es ist das Gift dieses schönen Sportes.
Es ist das Gift dieses schönen Sportes, Sportwettanbieter. Und dann, Marc, muss genau Jena, Kay Bernstein, ein Sportwettanbieter als neuen Hauptsponsor präsentieren. Was war da los?
Ja, ich musste gerade dran denken, dass er über all das spricht und über das Aktivieren dieser Sucht und Ähnliches. Und Hertha in der Pressemitteilung zum neuen Hauptsponsor einen Direktlink eingebettet hatte, wo man dann schön ins Online-Casino weitergehen kann. Und ich fand, es war damals sehr zynisch auf jeden Fall.
Wann war das nochmal?
Das war zur neuen Saison im vergangenen Sommer. Richtig. Was war passiert? Na ja, wir haben schon über Hertha's finanzielle Notlage gesprochen. Wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass Hertha alles andere als attraktiv war damals. Das Blatt hat sich ein bisschen gewendet. Aber in den letzten Jahren war Hertha's Hauptsponsorsuche immer ein Krampf. Das muss man sagen. Jedes Mal hat es ewig gedauert. Und es war ja nun auch nicht der erste Wetterendieter auf Hertha's Brust. Das muss man auch sagen. Aber natürlich war der Aufschrei jetzt besonders groß, weil du so einen idealistischen Präsidenten dort hattest, der in seiner damaligen Wahlkampagne noch geschrieben hatte, stell dir vor, Hertha nimmt keine dreckige Wettanbieterkohle mehr an. So, jetzt hat er sich damals, als der Deal dann durch war, damit verteidigt, dass er gesagt hatte, das war ja nur eine Vision. Das war kein konkreter Wahlprogrammspunkt. Und trotzdem habe ich damals auch einen Kommentar dazu geschrieben, habe ich mir gesagt, naja, aber Leute haben dich trotzdem aufgrund dieser Vision gewählt. Dann denkt ihr das aber stellt nicht Sch- Du wirst schriftlich ins Netz, denn dann wirst du darauf angesprochen werden und darauf festgenagelt werden und Leute werden damit Hoffnung verbinden. So, was war passiert? Hertha hatte keine anderen Möglichkeiten. Hertha saß lange an einem anderen Hauptsponsoring-Deal mit einer Trainer-Trainings-App aus Deutschland, aus Karlsruhe, um genau zu sein. Und dann hätte da Train-R auf der Brust gestanden, was natürlich auch rein themenverwandt nicht besser hätte sein können. Also ein Fußballclub wirbt für eine Fußball-Trainings-App, klingt erst mal sehr logisch, sehr unverfänglich. Das Problem war, das war ein Start-up und denen ist eine Investition weggebrochen, weshalb sie dieses Sponsoring nicht stemmen konnten. Und plötzlich stand ein Verein, der um die Lizenz bangen musste im vergangenen Sommer, ohne Hauptsponsor-Deal da. Und diese Chance hat besagter Wettanbieter – und es ist ja nicht nur Wettanbieter, sondern wie gesagt auch Online-Casino, es ist beides in einem – diese Verzweiflung gesehen oder ein Angebot gemacht, das Hertha nicht ablehnen konnte. Die sind mittlerweile ja auch bei Potsdam drin, also beim Frauenfußballverein Potsdam, die sind bei Waldhof Mannheim drin und überall sehr spät auf die Brust gekommen, weil bei allen die finanzielle Not extrem gegeben war. Und auch da, so wie wir über den neuen Investoreinstieg gesprochen haben, musste da der Pragmatiker, Kay Bernstein, zustimmen. Zumal man da auch sagen muss, rein kompetent, da sind wir wieder bei Satzungen und Kompetenzen.
Der Präsident hat eigentlich da auch nichts zu sagen.
Der hat da überhaupt nichts zu sagen. Natürlich könnte der sein Veto einlegen, aber das ist Teil der Geschäftsführung, diesen Hauptsondering hier abzuschließen. Natürlich wird es aber dann auf ihn, weil er in dieser Zeit auch sehr präsent war, auf ihn dann wird auf ihn das Scheinwerferlicht gerückt. Aber auch da hat er damals erklärt, natürlich finde ich das nicht geil, aber es ging jetzt nicht anders. Und der Deal ist auf ein Jahr beschränkt und dann mit Hertha's neuem Image, mit Hertha's neuer Attraktivität, mit wieder tausenden Mitgliedern mehr, könnte es auch sein, dass man im kommenden Sommer wieder ein deutlich ethisch saubereres Investment oder einen besseren Deal hinbekommt. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es schlichtweg nichts anderes und Hertha waren wie bei Triple Seven die Hände gebunden.
Und gleichzeitig eine verlorene Chance, oder Harald? Hätte man nicht an diesem Beispiel sehr gut mal über Sportwetten im Fußball sprechen können und eben die Frage, was machen denn Sportwetten, wenn wir mal gesellschaftlich draufblicken und was würden wir uns vielleicht wünschen, wo man sein Geld hingebt?
Ja, das Thema Sportwetten könnte das neue Thema für einen ganz neuen Podcast sein, weil darüber lässt sich trefflich nachdenken, theoretisieren und philosophieren, aber es lässt sich auch ganz handfest historisch nachvollziehen, wo das eigentlich so herkommt, denn Sportwetten ist ganz eng an den Ursprung des modernen Sports und des Fußballs an sich gebunden. Der Begriff Wettkampf hängt mit Wetten und mit Sportwetten ganz unmittelbar zusammen, denn dieser Kampf ist ein Wettkampf nur deshalb, weil man im Ergebnis, also im Mitblick auf das Ergebnis, von einem offenen Wettkampf ausgeht. Das heißt, man weiß vorher nicht, wie es ausgeht und nur deshalb macht Wetten Sinn, weil dieser Wettkampf eben ein Stück weit auch vom Zufall bestimmt ist. Das kann man dann mit einer Wettquote hinterlegen. Das heißt, die Affinität des Sports im Allgemeinen und des Fußballs, im Besonderen übrigens auch des Boxens und der Leichtathletik, im Hinblick auf das Thema Wetten, Sportwetten, die es gegeben. Und deshalb werden Wettanbieter den Sport als geniales Feld, als geniales Geschäftsfeld immer wieder suchen, immer wieder aufsuchen und auch immer wieder extrem hohe Summen zahlen können, weil er tatsächlich für diese Branche ein richtig tolles Geschäftsfeld ist. Damit muss sich dann allerdings der organisierte Sport auch systematisch auseinandersetzen. Man muss diesen Zusammenhang, diesen historisch gewachsenen Zusammenhängen anerkennen und begreifen. Und da ist Wettanbieter nicht bloß nur eine Sucht, sondern das ist etwas, das hängt ein Stück weit auch in der Geschichte des Sports mit zusammen. Und wie gesagt, das müssen die Verantwortlichen wissen. Und jetzt nach dem Statement von Kay Bernstein, da fand ich bemerkenswert, dass er es macht, aber dass er nicht versucht, das irgendwie schön zu reden, so nach dem Motto, an einer Stelle hatte ich so ein bisschen den Verdacht, naja, da könnte er in so eine Richtung abriffen, als es dann in die Krankenkassen ging und man Bilder kamen angemachend, so ein krasses Motto, naja, das ist so eine Art Ablasshandel. Wir machen das mit dem Wettanbieter und nebenher machen wir sowas wie Prävention mit Krankenkassen und dann gleicht sich das wieder aus. Das hat aber zum Glück nur angedeutet, da hoffe ich, dass er sowas nicht im Hinterkopf hatte, weil das ist wiederum so ein gängiges Muster, was wir im Sport sehen können, dass man das eine macht und versucht es dann durch so ein Alibiprojekt so ein bisschen zu kassieren. Er hat es unmissverständlich angesprochen und auch auf den Begriff gebracht. Er spricht dann vom Tiefsport, ist sich also der Problemlage bewusst, übernimmt diese Verantwortung und hat – und das ist das Bemerkenswerte, das ist das Bute und dem Ganzen – hat eine Visur. Er weiß ganz genau, vielleicht jetzt aus einem anderen Zugang heraus als ich den habe, weiß ganz genau, dass er um diesen Deal nicht mehr umkommt und dass das jetzt zu der Hertha, ich sage das mal in Anführungszeichen, passt, weil Sponsoren die Reichweite suchen. Das heißt, es passt genau zu so einem Sponsor, der aus dieser Branche kommt. Aber seine Vision ist, irgendwann ein anderes Gerüst aufgebaut zu haben mit der Hertha, dass man für bestimmte Werte steht. Und das hat er ja ganz offensichtlich innerhalb weniger Monate, weniger Jahre seiner Amtszeit ja schon richtig auf den Weg gebracht. Jetzt, jetzt nach seinem Tod, steht Hertha wertebezogen als Modell, als Projekt des Kay Bernsteins wertemäßig völlig anders da. Und jetzt schon wären für die Verhandlungen, für den Nachfolgesponsor ganz andere Möglichkeiten drin als noch vor einem Jahr oder da vor zwei Jahren. Und das ist eine Perspektive für den Sport insgesamt, dass wir daran denken muss, müssen, womit identifizieren sich Sponsoren oder womit können sie sich nicht mehr identifizieren. Das ist eine ethisch bezogene Debatte um Sponsoring, die wir vor wenigen Jahren in dieser Breite noch gar nicht hatten. Höhepunkt solcher ethischen Debatten, den haben wir dann bei der WM in Katha erlebt, wo ja auch ganz viele Sponsoren des Turniers auf ihre Rechte verzichtet haben. Sie wollten da gar nicht großartig gezeigt werden. Man wollte dann so Fernsehbilder vermeiden, wo dann auf der einen Seite Mitsubishi-Berbung oder eine andere Automatik-Marke beworben wird und dann plötzlich so ein Scheich mit irgendwelchen Zeichen dieses Landes dann in einer Nähe zu diesem Produkt kommt. Man hat dann auf Sponsorrechte verzichtet oder wie bei REWE, man hat sie öffentliche wirksam mit noch mehr Effekt zurückgegeben, weil man sie sowieso zurückgeben wollte und dann hat man die günstige Stunde genutzt und im DFB nach diesem Japanspiel gezeigt, was man davon hält. Also diese Werte-Debakelspiele im Sponsoring eine große Rolle und das ist eine Aufgabe, an die sich viele Sponsoring-Abteilungen der Vereine dran machen müssen. Neben dem Plastik-Image, was viele Vereine haben, gibt es tatsächlich beim Anshin-Clubs so eine Werte-Image und das ist für die Industrie eine große Unternehmen hoch spannend, hoch interessant, dann mit bestimmten Vereinen ins Gespräch zu kommen, denn gerade in der deutschen Fan- und Fußballkultur ist die Dominanz der Sponsoring-Partner, die immer gewinnen, die ist zwar immer noch da, aber die ist mächtig angekratzt, weil diese Werte-Ebene durchaus anfängt, Konkurrenz zu machen. Und das ist jetzt für den Nachfolger von Kay Bernstein, bei der Hertha und denjenigen, die das Projekt weiter tragen wollen, eine große Herausforderung, die Spur weiter zu ziehen. Und da bin ich, wenn das so weiter läuft, auch sehr zuversichtlich, dass das klingen wird. Wie gesagt, mit Blick auf seine Leistung unterstreiche ich ganz klar, dass es großartig von ihm war, dass er ganz klar am Ende gesagt hat, das ist das Gift des Fußballs und dass er nicht versucht hat, das irgendwie auszugleichen, wo wir hinzureden, wo wir irgendeinen Alibi-Projekt machen, so nach dem Motto, wir machen uns noch ein Respekt-Button, hier auch, und dann ist doch alles wieder gut. Oder wir hissen noch mal eine Regenbohne-Bahn, wo alle Alibis, Symbolpolitik, die abwärts sind.
Apropos Politik, er hat auch in Bezug auf der Kampf zwischen Realpolitik und Idealen, hat er auch öfter mal den Vergleich mit den Grünen bemüht. Wir hatten ja diesen Vergleich jetzt schon öfter, und auch da spricht er davon, sobald man dann in Regierungsverantwortung kommt und feststellt, Dinge sind historisch gewachsen, Abhängigkeiten wurden geschaffen, Dinge sind jetzt nun mal gerade so, und man kann sie nicht von einem Schlag von einem Tag auf dem anderen auch schlagartig verändern. Muss man Entscheidungen treffen, die einem überhaupt nicht naheliegen und die einem teilweise sogar richtig wehtun, die aber erst mal den Fortbestand der Mission sichern, und man hofft dann halt mit jedem Tag stückweise sukzessive etwas dafür zu tun, dass das Image sich des Vereins verändert und dass man Abhängigkeiten abbaut und dass man dann Entscheidungen treffen kann, die einen dann von solchen Abhängigkeiten lösen.
Und ob man da wirklich so weit ist, da würde ich auch noch so leichte Zweifel sehen. Also natürlich muss das Ziel sein, wenn dein Sponsor noch bei Waldhof Mannheim und Turbine Potsdam einsteigt, dann hast du einen Fehler gemacht. Also dann hast du noch nicht dieses klare Image. Damit will ich nichts über Mannheim und über die Turbine sagen, aber dann ist es ja beliebig. Also zeig mir was, was diese drei miteinander verbindet, außer dass sie eine Reichweite haben in einem Segment, in das der Sponsor dann hinein will. Also sprich, man hat es noch nicht geschafft. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass diese Abhängigkeit, aber selbst, wenn jetzt Hertha BSC ein Image hätte wie der FC St. Pauli, zu dem ja auch nur gewisse Sponsoren passen sollten, bei denen es aber auch immer wieder Fälle gab, wo man gesehen hat, jetzt knirscht es aber ein bisschen und ist da der Sportartikel-Hersteller aus den USA wirklich die beste Möglichkeit, ja oder nein. Aber aus den gewissen Abhängigkeiten wird man nicht rauskommen, denn zwei realpolitische Bedingungen sind bei Hertha immer gegeben. Eine Geldknappheit und das Interesse eines Investors, dass die KGAA, dass eben die Kapitalgesellschaft, die auf Fußball spielt, nebenher, dass die Rendite abwirft. Und wie man sich da positioniert in Zukunft, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so optimistisch wie du, Harald, weil ich da dann doch realpolitische Zwänge sehe und es wäre so spannend gewesen, Kay Bernstein diesen Drahtseilakt ihm weiter dabei zuzusehen, wie er das ausbalanciert und wie er das kommuniziert. Ich weiß nicht, Marc, du bist jetzt für mich schon die Hertha offenbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich davon jetzt beleidigt oder geerrt fühlen soll, aber ich nehme es mal hin.
Es ist die Bernstein-Hertha. Es ist schon die mit der besseren Image. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie du darüber denkst, dass das ja auch eine Realität ist. Also wir wollen jetzt nicht so tun, als ob Hertha BSC am Eingang zum Paradies steht, zum Fußball-Paradies, in dem alles möglich sein wird. Die Zwänge sind ja immer noch groß, unter denen man abgehen muss.
Ich kann das eigentlich alles unterstreichen, was du gesagt hast. Ich hatte die Tage auch für den LBB einen Artikel geschrieben, wo ich die Frage gestellt habe, wie es nach Kay Bernstein weitergeht und in einige Wunden auch mein Finger gelegt. Denn es gibt Fragezeichen. Es gibt die Frage, versucht Triple Seven mehr Einfluss zu nehmen. Es gibt die Frage, kann man 50 plus 1 weiter so hüten? Es gibt die Frage, wie schafft man es, die wirtschaftliche Konsolidierung weiterzugehen? Wie schafft man es, die Grabenkämpfe in den Gremien weiterhin zu verhindern oder zumindest weiterhin auf Eis zu legen? Und wer soll das alles überhaupt machen? Das ist die ganz große Frage, die wir sicherlich auch gleich noch beantworten werden. Oder wir werden es nicht beantworten können. Wir werden uns der Antwort nur nähern können. Aber ja, natürlich gibt es all diese Zweifel. Und als ich auf dem Trauermarsch war zum Olympiastadion beim Büsseldorf-Spiel, war das eines der ganz großen beherrschenden Themen, die man so zwischen… Also man hört ja immer wieder in Konversationen rein mit den Leuten, die neben einem stehen oder so. Und die Frage, wie es weitergeht und die Ängste davor, was ohne Kay Bernstein passieren könnte, die sind eindeutig vorhanden. Also da guckt keiner in die Zukunft und denkt sich, ah nee, jetzt ist das Feld schon bestellt.
Da werden wir gleich im letzten Teil dann dieses Tribünengesprächs noch drüber sprechen. Vorher würde ich gerne noch drei große Themen ansprechen, beziehungsweise ein kleineres Thema, aber da hat er einen interessanten Gedanken. Und dann noch zwei große Themen des Fußballs generell und die Haltung zu Kay Bernstein dazu, bevor wir uns dann mit der Frage befassen nach seinem Tod, was wird denn jetzt davon bleiben? Vielleicht fangen wir mit der kleinen Idee an, Harald. Dazu würde mich sehr interessieren, was du dazu sagst. Ich bin gespannt, ob du ähnlich reagierst wie Felicio, bei dem im Stream hat Kay Bernstein diese Idee erstmals platziert. Und der musste einmal herzhaft lachen beim Gedanken an das hier.
Wenn das auch kommt, es gibt aktuell auch keine Geschäftsbeziehungen mit meiner Firma und dem Verein.
Das gab es mal.
Dann darf es das auch nicht geben, sondern in meiner Welt führen wir dann irgendwann mal auch ein Transparenzregister ein, um zu sagen, wer ist hier mit wem wie verwogen, wer macht welche Geschäfte mit wem, warum macht Thorsten Manske ein Geschäft mit Mike Franz und versucht ihn sozusagen als Spieler aus dem Verein kommend in ein Investment zu bringen. Wir müssen doch mal sagen, okay, das ist hier Fußball und dann kommt die komplette Konzentration. Also dürfen wir doch jetzt nicht den Klügel und das von da an und da an schieben. Das war in den 80er Jahren so. Da haben die Präsidenten Bürgschaften unterschrieben, haben Andreas Schmidt noch den Führerschein bezahlt und so weiter. Da sind wir ja lange nicht mehr. Von daher gar keine Verzahnung, gar keine Vernetzung. Zwei getrennte Geschichten.
Ja Harald, wann kommt das Transparenzregister bei allen Vereinen?
Nie, also das wird niemals kommen. Es wird oft darüber geredet werden und wir werden uns das auch wünschen, weil es auch absolut Sinn macht, aber der Fußball ist für Intransparenz, für Hinterzimmer so attraktiv, da können diejenigen, die da auf der Werteebene drauf achten, dass sie den Fußball davor schützen, die können gar nicht so viel Zeit, Kraft und Arbeit aufwenden, um den Fußball davor zu schützen, weil es immer wieder neue Schlucklöcherlege geben wird und weil es immer wieder neue Verlockungen geben wird, an dieser Konstellation zu arbeiten. Und das ist zum Teil sogar schon in Beton gegossen, dass das so läuft, dass ich im Selbstverständnis des Fußballs ganz selbstverständlich drin, weil man kann sich natürlich auch fragen, aus welchem Grund gibt es diese Logiken, diese WIP-Bereiche beim Fußball, die dienen doch vor allem dem Zweck, dass dort Netzwerkarbeit stattfindet. Und wenn eine Fußballgröße von dem einen Verein oder aus der Arbeitslosigkeit heraus zu einem neuen Verein in eine wichtige Managementposition gebracht wird, nicht nur bei Vereinen, inzwischen auch bei den Verbänden, dann kommt die Philosophie wie selbstverständlich hinterher, der bringt ein gutes Netzwerk mit. Tja, was versteht er von Management, was versteht er von Fußball, welche Biografie hat er? Das ist nebensächlich, bringt ein gutes Netzwerk mit. Und was ist Netzwerk anderes als Transparenz oder Transparenz? Je nachdem, und dieses Netzwerk, diese WIP-Logel und all sowas, das ist dafür gemacht, dass man Hinterzimmergeschichten lanciert. Das ist ein Spiel, was neben dem eigentlichen Spiel stattfindet und was ganz eng an den Fußball rangebunden ist. Ich habe das jetzt in meinem Statement ein bisschen negativ konnotiert dargestellt. Das Netzwerk hat natürlich auch ganz, ganz viele positive Aspekte, die dann natürlich auch transparent gemacht werden, weil sie eben dem Image überförderlich wirken und so weiter. Aber diese Struktur, die macht den Fußball eben auch anfällig für diese Intransforms, für dieses Hinterzimmer. Und da bin ich nach allem, was ich bislang gesehen habe, analysiert habe, gemessen habe, und ich sehe sehr, sehr pessimistisch und würde mich da zu dieser These noch mal den Beißen lassen, es zu unterstreichen. Das werden wir niemals hier. Dieses Transparenzregister vielleicht kommt, aber es wird ab hier tiefer werden, wenn es dann kommt.
Auch da gibt es natürlich wieder Anekdoten, sollten es Härt dazu, wenn wir daran denken, mit was für einer Entourage Friedi Bobic damals in den Verein kam, wo so viele entweder neue Posten geschaffen wurden oder Leute aus Ämtern gedrängt wurden, um Bobic Leute zu platzieren. Pablo Tiamen, plötzlich neue Akademieleiter, Andy Menger, der neue Torwarttrainer, Thomas Breuch wurde dazugeholt, es gab Leitermethodik, es gab technische Leiter, es gab Mannschaftsbetreuer, alle plötzlich dazugeholt, alle Leute, bei denen Fredi Bobic sagte, man kennt sich halt. Das ist sehr schwierig und viele Leute davon sind auch nicht mehr da, nahezu alle. Thomas Breuch ist noch da, leistet wohl auch sehr, sehr gute Arbeit und auch da. Das war ganz interessant. Es war nicht so, dass Kay Bernstein kam, Fredi Bobic ging und daraufhin alle gegangen sind, sondern alle haben ja auch noch eine Zeit bekommen, um sich im neuen Umfeld außerhalb von Fredi Bobic zu beweisen. Und dann wurde erst ein Fazit unternommen, ergibt das noch Sinn? Und vor allen Dingen seid ihr finanziell auch zu halten. Also ein Beispiel ist Pablo Tiam, der soll als Akademieleiter gute Arbeit gemacht haben, hat aber als Bobic-Freund ein so horrendes Gehalt bekommen, dass man das nicht, das konnte man nicht weiter bezahlen, egal wie gut er war. So und das hat sich auch bei anderen Stellen durchgezogen. Und Kay Bernstein hatte sich ja aufgemacht, den alten Filz aufzuräumen. Und das wäre jetzt halt ein Thema für die Zukunft gewesen, zu dem ich ihn sehr gerne weiter befragt hätte. Denn das Problem ist, dass auch unter ihm teilweise Personalentscheidungen getroffen wurden, die nicht ganz nachvollziehbar waren. Sei es ein Kolonian, der mittlerweile Marketing-Chef quasi bei Hertha ist, das ist ein alter Kurvenfreund von Kay Bernstein, der hat das auch schon in seiner Firma gemacht und der kann ja sehr gut sein. Hertha's Marketing-Abteilung läuft so gut wie lange nicht mehr. So und er und auch die Bernstein-Vertrauten sollen auch insgesamt weniger Geld kassieren als Leute, die man von extern geholt hat, weil diese Hertha-Identifikation quasi die Differenz ausmacht zwischen diesen Gehältern. Also für den Verein kriegt man ein bisschen weniger, um das Ding mit zu retten. Und trotzdem waren die Einstellungsprozesse teilweise nicht ganz transparent, auch das Onboarding nicht. Also es wird teilweise auf der Geschäftsstelle wohl kritisiert, dass man erst Wochen später erfährt, ach, der arbeitet jetzt bei uns interessant. Das funktioniert natürlich dann auch teilweise nicht so gut. Das gibt es auch im Jugendbereich, dass Akademieleiter Andreas Zecke-Neuendorf Leuten Jobs gibt, wie beispielsweise George Boateng, einem der drei Boateng-Brüder, der ja nachweislich keine Kompetenzen im Profisport hat. Er soll auch ein sehr talentierter Fußballer gewesen sein, ist jetzt aber in der Akademie angestellt. Man weiß aber nicht so ganz genau, was er da tut. Er soll Ansprechpartner für die Eltern sein, da eine Schnittstelle sein. Da gibt es einen Benni Köhler, den kennt man ja auch noch von früher, Ex-Frankfurter, Ex-Unioner, aber auch mal bei der Hertha-Jugend gespielt. Er und Zecke-Neuendorf kennen sich sehr gut. Er ist jetzt Individualtrainer im Jugendbereich. Also es gibt auch da Geschichten, wo man sehr aufpassen muss, dass sich nicht auch eben neuer Filz bildet. Das Ding ist, wir können es jetzt nicht sagen, weil diese Prozesse jetzt erst gestartet wurden und vielleicht gucken wir in zehn Jahren drauf und sagen, das waren alles Glücksgriffe und Hertha geht so gut wie seit langem nicht. Und dann war es ja gut, dass man auf Leute gesetzt hat, die man von früher kennt und denen man vertraut. Denn wie Harald sagte, Netzwerke sind ja nicht immer schlecht und nur, weil jemand eingestellt wird, weil man ihn von früher kennt, muss er ja keine schlechte Arbeit machen. Und doch sieht man das, glaube ich, Verlockende in dieser Position, kurzen Prozess zu machen und dann Prozesse dadurch aber auch intransparent zu machen.
Ja, sehr interessante Details, die du dazu noch mal genannt hast. Es ist ein interessantes Thema – Transparenz im Sport. Sie wird immer bemüht, sogar die DFL entblödet sich nicht und sagt, na, wir haben doch jetzt viel transparenter kommuniziert, jetzt in der zweiten Runde um den DFL-Investor, aber haben dann geheim abstimmen lassen. Also das ist ja wirklich so. Also ja, also wirklich, sie haben sich nicht entblödet, es anders darzustellen, aber ich will es gar nicht immer auf die DFL umschwenken. Aber interessant, was ihr dabei gesagt habt, es gibt noch zwei große Themen, zu denen sich Kay Bernstein geäußert hat. Und das eine ist mit Pyrotechnik ein sehr, sehr emotionales Thema. Und auch hier ist aber interessant, welche Perspektive er reinbringt. Auch das hat er gesagt, bevor er zum Präsident gewählt wurde.
Finde ich, gehört jetzt seit einem Vierteljahrhundert zu unserer Kultur dazu. Wir müssen nicht über Pyrotechnik reden. Die gibt es im Stadion, die gibt es bei einer Vier-Schanzen-Tournee, die gibt es bei einer großen Osterfeuer-Nummer. Wir müssen eher über einen verantwortungsvollen Umgang sprechen. Wie klappt das, dass da keiner verletzt wird? Wie kann das eigenverantwortlich gut funktionieren? Aber die Debatte über Pyrotechnik – ja oder nein? Nach einem Vierteljahrhundert, nach 25 Jahren Dasein? Sehen wir doch jetzt, vor der Pandemie war es eher so, dass der Konflikt sich zugespitzt hat. Da waren die Fankurven, Krieg gegen den DFB. Da war sozusagen der Konflikt am Überschwappen gegeneinander. Der DFB hat jedes Bengalo gezählt, die Vereine mit Strafen belegt. Dann kam die Pandemie. Dann waren alle Kurven danach wieder voll. Und es hat geraucht, gezündet, gequämmt, so viel wie noch nie. Es gab aber keine Empörung, kein Aufschreien, keine Debatte, weil es für die Leute in einem gewissen Rahmen dazugehört.
Ein bisschen ist dieser O-Ton gealtert, denn inzwischen werden wieder Pyro-Fackeln gezählt, bis auf die einzelne Facke hinab. Und es werden auch Rekordstrafen verhängt. Ich habe schon gehört, dass DFB und DFL selber nicht mehr so ganz happy damit sind, wie teuer sie jede einzelne Pyro-Fackel in ihrem Strafmaß festgelegt haben. Aber man wollte es ja objektivieren. Und jetzt zahlen eben Vereine über 500.000 Euro zum Teil für Pyrovergehen. Aber Harald, es ist ja interessant, dass hier jemand mal sagt, was viele im Fußball schon leben, nicht alle gut finden. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, jeder muss für Pyrotechnik sein. Aber der Fakt, dass es da ist, obwohl es verboten ist schon seit immer, und der Fakt, dass das Wichtige bei Pyrotechnik dann vielleicht sein könnte, vielleicht, dass man über den Umgang damit spricht und den reglementiert und nicht versucht, ein Verbot durchzusetzen, das nicht durchzusetzen zu sein scheint, das ist doch mal ein interessanter Neuansatz, würde ich fast schon sagen.
Und es war allerhöchste Zeit, dass das mal endlich jemand auch so deutlich ausspricht. Jemand, der so einen Verein führt, beziehungsweise das hat er ja vor seiner Wahl schon gesagt, aber das ist dann auch ein Statement dahingehend, ja er wurde dann auch gewählt mit so einem Statement. Was wir bei der Pyrotechnik-Sache ganz gut sehen können, ist, das ist ein sehr ambivalentes Thema, an dem sich auch manche Geister so scheiden, aber das ist ein Thema, wo ich auch sagen würde, ja da kommen wir nicht von rum. Das ist aus dem Fußball nicht mehr wegzudenken, das gehört dazu und wir müssen über das Wie reden. Wie inszeniert man das, wie geht man damit um und da bin ich voll bei Kay Bernstein und seinem Statement dazu, was die Zukunft vom Büro im Fußball anbetrifft und was man sagen kann. Die Bemühungen des DFB, das ist eine Nulltonalanz, ich meinte, nur der Ungebrich zu drücken, sind schräglich geschautert und wirken jetzt gerade in den letzten Monaten auf extremem Hinfluss, also spätestens seit der Büro-Strafe gegen den 1. FC Köln. Ich meine, es waren fast 600.000 Euro beim Spiel gegen Gladbach. Da hat man eben doch wirklich deutlich gezeigt, ja wir sind am Ende mit unserer Strategie, aber bedauerlicherweise sehe ich beim DFB, im Präsidium und beim Präsidenten niemanden, der rein kachlich aufgrund seines Erfahrungshubizonts in der Lage wäre, sich dieses Themas nochmal neu und etwas offener anzunehmen. Da hatte der DFB übrigens noch nie jemanden in Verantwortung, abgesehen von seinem ehemaligen Sicherheitsbeauftragten, Emmen Spahn, der danach auch mal Präsident von Offenbach gewesen ist. Der hatte in seiner Funktion als DFB-Sicherheitsbeauftragter, ich meine 2009, 10, 11, so um diesen Dreh, hatte tatsächlich mal eine Debatte mit den Fans, Fanvertretern angefangen, die genau das gemacht haben, was Kay Bernstein da in diesen O-Tonen auf den Punkt gebracht hat, nämlich über das Wie zu reden. Also nicht über das Ob, sondern über das Wie. Und da, meine ich, war man schon enorm weit. Und hätte man den Helmut Spahn das damals weiter verantwortlich führen lassen können, dann hätten wir jetzt eine ganz andere Situation. Und dann würden wir weiter an dem Wie arbeiten und das ausgestalten und hätten diese Debatte nicht wieder haben. Und erst durch diese Null-Toleranz-Politik, die damals von Zwanziger und Rauball bei einem Pokalspiel oder nach einem Pokalspiel Dortmund und Dresden auf den Weg gebracht wurde, die wieder in so einer Gutsherren-Mentalität von oben nach unten durchdekliniert werden sollte, seitdem ist das Pyrotechnik ein Symbolthema für die Fan-Kultur und ein wirklich wunderbares Symbolthema, weil man damit die Machtfrage quasi auf einer anderen Ebene aushandelt, wem gehört das Stadion, wem gehört der Fußball. Und wir zeigen euch an diesem Beispiel, ihr kriegt uns hier nicht weg. Also man brummt sich auf Seiten des DFB das Thema selbst hoch und groß und man hat keine Idee, wirklich keine Idee, wie man in dieses neue Fahrwasser kommen könnte. Man hätte die Chance gehabt, nachdem Rainer Koff als fiese Vizepräsident geschasst wurde, abgewählt wurde beim DFB. Der war ja immer dieser Hardliner-Vertreter mit Null Toleranz, der da Recht und Ordnung durchsetzen wollte in den Endkurven, damit er auch glücklich gescheitert ist. Und nachdem der weg war, war ein Vakuum da, was nach meiner Beobachtung heute immer noch da ist. Ist niemand, der da laut hier schreit, wenn es um solche Fankänen geht. Und dieses Vakuum müsste man jetzt irgendwann mal füllen mit Leuten, damit ich sehe, und dann im Sinne von Kay Bernstein über das Mii nicht nur der Nouveau-Thematik, sondern auch andere Thematiken ins Gespräch kommen. Und das wäre für unsere Kunst und Kultur ein absoluter Gewinn. Aber ich sehe bei Bernd Neuendorf, sehe ich bislang, in allen Rennenbelannen, sportpolitischen Belannen eher so, die den Hang, so ein bisschen die Symbolpolitik bedienen zu wollen. Aber überhaupt nicht die Fähigkeit, weitere wirkliche echte Kunstwaldprobleme als solche anzupülen. Also dann müsste er endlich mal so irgendwie mal wehtun können. Und das ist eben die U-Boot-Tipp-Abdecknis so eine. Wobei die auch nicht wirklich wehtut, weil wenn man auch diejenigen anschaut, die von der Haupttribüne oder aus dem Blickbereich kommt, dann so die Nase runterfügt, schon wieder Pyrotechnik. Da ist mindestens die Hälfte, wenn in der Kurve gezündet wird, mindestens die Hälfte. Die Elis nimmt das auf und Kay das auf Social Media, um der Welt zu zeigen, ich sitze ganz nah dran.
Ja, aber doch die Liga selbst auch. Also wenn wir uns Werbeclips und Fotos auf den Bundesliga-Kanälen angucken, dann wird genau das ja abgebildet. Das ist ja das Paradoxe daran, zumal Kay Bernstein ja auch nichts, auch da wieder, er hat ja nichts Utopisches geäußert. Es gibt doch Pilotprojekte. Ich meine, in Dänemark gibt es beispielsweise Pilotprojekte, dass geschaut wird. Gibt es vielleicht abgesperrte, klar lokalisierte Areale in der Kurve, wo dann das abgebrannt wird. Es gibt doch Ideen dazu. Ist ja nicht so, dass man da plötzlich irgendwas neu erfinden müsste. Wenn auf dem Weg einem was einfällt, okay. Aber auch da ist es ja wieder nicht so, dass der Hardliner Ex-Ultra Kay Bernstein das freie Zündeln fordert, sondern ja einfach nur darüber redet, lasst uns darüber reden.
Ja, und das kann ich vielleicht dann doch sagen aus dem, was ich so gehört habe, aus der DFL heraus. Da hätte es den Plan gegeben, mit jemandem wie Kay Bernstein und noch durchaus anderen Beteiligten da nochmal einen neuen Ausschlag zu wagen. Denn du brauchst auch manchmal denjenigen, der diesen verbalen Ausschlag macht und der sich dann vielleicht auch an die Front der Kritik stellt. Denn natürlich werden die entsprechenden Artikel gekommen. Wir wissen ja, wie über Ultras gesprochen wird. Die werden ja dargestellt wie Schwerverbrecher von manchen Medienvertretern. Und natürlich hätten die gesagt, jetzt ist er total durchgedreht. Jetzt wissen wir, warum er Präsident werden wollte.
Es gab doch von einem Kommentar in… Oh, ich will kein Medium verunglimpfen, deswegen sage ich jetzt keine Namen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, nämlich welches, vielleicht Schranke zwischen zwei. Da gab es ein völlig verkorksene Kommentar zu Kay Bernsteins Anstoß bezüglich der Pyro-Debatte, der genau in die Richtung gegangen ist, die du gerade angedeutet hast, Max.
Genau. Und was ich aber eben gehört habe, wäre, dass der Neuansatz dieser Debatte wäre gestützt gewesen von zwei, drei anderen Personen, die gesagt hätten, ja, lasst uns das Thema noch mal gemeinsam mit den Fans besprechen, weil diese völlig aus dem Ruder laufenden Strafen helfen ja auch niemandem weiter und machen niemanden glücklich. Und das führt zu der wunderbaren Situation, dass der DFB, der beim DFB-Pokalfinale der Veranstalter der Veranstaltung ist, es auch nicht schafft, Pyro zu verhindern. Ganz im Gegenteil, die Ultras machen sich einen besonderen Spaß daraus, da noch mal so richtig zu zünden. Also da weißt du, dass aus beiden Kurven definitiv etwas kommt. Die einen wahrscheinlich vorm Spiel und die anderen dann in der Halbzeit, wenn wieder gerade angepfiffen werden sollte. Und dann der DFB aber, weil er es selber nicht geschafft hat, Pyro zu verhindern, die Vereine mit Geldstrafen belegt. Also es ist völlig absurd. Und vielleicht hilft dir dann dieser Schnipse, den ich hier rausgesucht habe, dann doch nochmal, dass uns das allen klar wird und das dann vielleicht da nochmal eine neue Debatte ansetzt. Und dann haben wir noch ein ganz großes Thema. Und dieses Thema wurde während der Pandemie – ja, ich weiß, ihr guckt auf die Uhr, dann sind wir aber auch durch. Ich kann noch nichts dafür, dass Kay Bernstein sich an die großen Themen herangewagt hat.
Das ist richtig.
Und ich glaube aber, auch das ist nochmal wichtig zu besprechen, weil es schon interessant ist, dass hier mal ein späterer Vereinfertreter über den ganz großen Zusammenhang über Wirtschaft und Sport spricht. Wir hören uns mal an. Kay Bernstein stellt da nämlich eine Frage, die während der Pandemie hochrelevant war und die jetzt gerne wieder so in den Hintergrund gedrängt wird, die aber vielleicht die alle Entscheidende ist. Alles Entscheidende.
Aber da ist doch die Frage, wie hoch dreht sich die Spirale und wann implodiert das? Wann ist sozusagen dieser Markt endlich? Und wenn wir nach England, nach Spanien, nach Italien gucken, England ist ja nochmal ein krasseres Beispiel sozusagen. Die Frage ist doch, wie gesund ist das und wann ist der Markt endlich und wann implodiert das? Und man merkt doch jetzt schon, die Zuschauerzahlen gehen zurück an den PAY-TV-Kanälen. Die verdienen damit weniger Geld. Die TV-Ausschüttung wird weniger. Also wir sehen doch jetzt schon, dass der Fußball aufgrund des immer höher, schneller, weiter auch verstärkt durch die Pandemie letztendlich an Rückschritten macht, sowohl in den Zuschauerzahlen im Stadion, wie auch in den PAY-TV-Kanälen, was sich dann auf die Vermarktungserlöse auswirken wird, weil gar nicht mehr so viele Leute Fernsehen gucken und die Werbekunden sagen, okay, früher habe ich hier eine Million bezahlt, bei dir gucken aber bloß noch 500.000, also zahle ich jetzt die Hälfte. Da merken wir doch schon einen Abwärtstrend. Und die Frage ist doch, wofür soll dieser Fußball da sein? Ist der für die Gesellschaft da? Ist der für uns Menschen da? Oder ist er sozusagen die Unterhaltungsindustrie 2.0, wo wir irgendwann sozusagen in irgendwelchen Stadien sind, irgendwelchen Leuten zusammengekauft hinterhergucken, dann verliert dieser Fußball seine Seele und dann wird das Produkt nicht mehr vermarktbar sein und dann wird es nicht mehr funktionieren.
Es tut mir selber ein bisschen leid, dass ich jetzt noch über vier Stunden die große Sinnfrage stelle. Die große Sinnfrage. Ja, aber wir können ja nicht mit der Sinnfrage anfangen und danach dann irgendwie Übersatzungen und so weiter sprechen. Harald, was sind deine Gedanken dazu?
Ja, also ich finde diese Frage zum Schluss, die gerundet jetzt unser Gespräch wahrscheinlich für die nächste, also mindestens halbe Stunde werden wir dafür brauchen. Ich würde noch einmal so richtig schön abfragen, weil da stellt er die Frage, welchen Fußball wollen wir, wofür steht der Fußball und wie soll die Allianz mit der Wirtschaft, mit dem Kommerz dann letztlich auch aussehen und ausgestaltet werden. Und wie sieht das Spannungsfeld zwischen Fußball als Sport mit sportbezogenen Werten auf der einen Seite und den Verlockungen des Fußballs als Format der sportbezogenen Unterhaltung im Stream, im Fernsehen, in den Medien? Wie genau soll das Ganze aussehen? Ab wann wird der Fußball dann zum Klamauk, wie bei der sogenannten Baller League oder anderen Formaten, die wir demnächst da noch sehen können? Und ab wann wird der Fußball oder ist der Fußball im Kern so etwas wie ein Bildungsthema, ein Thema der Akkulturation, der Sozialisation, ein Thema für die nachwachsende Generation, ein Kulturthema, das wir bewahren müssen? Und wer schickt sich an, Verantwortung zu übernehmen? Für das eine Klamauk oder für das andere? Bewahrung von Werten, Traditionen und eben auch Sozialisationsinstanz. Ja, und das ist eine Frage, die stellen wir seit der Pandemie häufiger. Da gibt es auch Debatten dazu und da gibt es auch Entwicklungen dazu. Und da meine ich, hat sich der Fußball, insbesondere in den Kurven, bei den Mitgliedern tatsächlich in seiner Haltung ein Stück weit verändert. Da ist jetzt was Neues aufgekommen, eine neue Debatte, die den Fußball insgesamt verändert. Was man auch daran sehen kann, dass diese Investoren-Debatte bei der DFL nicht einfach so durchgegangen ist, sondern die wird von jetzt gerade von Protesten begleitet und die ist mit den Vereinen sehr kontrovers diskutiert worden. Da hat auch die zweite Liga, ein ganz anderes Selbstbewusstsein, mitgewickelt. So nach dem Motto, wir machen nicht das, so war es ja früher, was Rummenigge unter der FC Bayern dann vorgick, da laufen wir hinterher und wir lassen uns auch nicht davon beeindrucken, dass wir da irgendwelche Sanktionen zu fürchten haben, sondern wir sind auch unseren Mitgliedern gegenüber in der Pflicht und unseren Fans gegenüber in der Pflicht. Also ich denke, diese Debatte, die wir jetzt nur so anreißen können, die wird den Fußball der nächsten Jahre ganz, ganz maßgeblich regen. Und zwar nicht nur auf der nationalen Ebene, sondern insbesondere auch auf der internationalen Ebene, wo jetzt der DFB-Präsident ja gerade gesagt hat, Saudi-Arabien ist ein echtes Fußballland. Über solche Statements werden wir reden müssen und werden wir uns verhalten müssen, vor allem, weil die WM 2034 dann auch in Saudi-Arabien ausgespielt wird. Aber auch bei uns in der Bundesliga werden wir darüber reden müssen, welchen Fußball wollen wir, wofür ist der da und was interessiert uns. Und wir lernen am Beispiel zweite Liga, es muss nicht der Spitzenfußball sein, der die Massen anzieht. Es kann auch ein Traditionsverein sein, wie Schalke 04, die Kaiserslautern, wie Magdeburg und andere, die eben nicht in der Bundesliga spielen, sondern in der zweiten, manchmal auch dritten Liga ganz hervorragenden Fußball inszenieren und dann eben dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl inszenieren. Und da sehe ich bei diesem Gemeinschaftsgefühl, bei dieser kulturellen Errungenschaft Fußball, da sehe ich ein richtig großes Potenzial auch für die Vermarktung, auch für das Thema Geld verdienen, wenn man es nur richtig in Szene zu setzen weiß. Das einfachste, was man als Sportmanager machen kann, man guckt nach Saudi-Arabien, man guckt in die nordamerikanische Profi-Liga oder man guckt in die Firmen, die man liebt und sagt, oh guck mal, da läuft so ein einfaches Vermarktungsmodell vom Fußball, machen wir genauso. Das kann jetzt nicht sagen kann jeder, aber das ist für Sportmarketing einfach. Hier ist das. Aber eine richtige Herausforderung sehe ich dahingehend. Wie hole ich Geld in einen wertbasierten Fußball? Wer identifiziert sich damit? Wer ist deshalb bereit, auch Geld zu geben? Und wer hat von diesem wertbasierten Fußball auch einen Mehrwert? Und wer ist bereit, da Verantwortung zu übernehmen? Das sind für mich so die Fragen der Zukunft und da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, was wird denn Fußball, das wird die Bundesliga in den nächsten Jahren ganz, ganz, ganz nachhaltig reden und beeinflussen? Und da sehe ich dieses neue Selbstbewusstsein in der Kurve, und zwar durch alle Liegen durch. Dieses neue Selbstbewusstsein wird dafür garantieren, dass wir diese Debatten in allen Clubs beeinführen werden. Und das Beispiel Hertha wird aus meiner Sicht dahingehend wirken, dass sich in vielen Vereinen Fans und Mitglieder aufmachen und sagen, Mensch, haben wir nicht auch jemanden in unserem Reihen, der sowas kann? Haben wir nicht auch jemanden, den wir in dieser Richtung unterstützen können? Und da suchen wir keine Kopie von Kay Bernstein. Das kann auch jemand sein, der keine Ultra-Biografie hat. Aber es kann jemand sein, der von seinem Wertkompass her den Vereinsmitgliedern gequält. Sie sagen, ja, den möchten wir gern als Landführer oder als Vorsitzender, als Präsidenten unseres Vereins haben. Und da bin ich mir sicher, werden wir bis runter in die zweite, dritte, vierte Liga, da werden wir jetzt, will ich nicht sagen, Merch-Amer-Modelle finden, aber da werden wir Vereinskulturen haben, die jetzt möglicherweise auch auf die Hertha schaut, die jetzt nicht nur den Podcast von uns hier anhören, sondern auch links und rechts recherchieren. Wer war Kay Bernstein? Was hat er gemacht? Darauf bin ich gespannt. Da werden wir in den nächsten Jahren unendlich viel besprechen.
Ich will nicht so tun, als hätte ich noch sehr viel mehr zuzufügen nach Bernstein und Harald. Aber natürlich ist unendlicher Wachstum in einer endlichen Welt völliger Schwachsinn. Das sehen wir ja gerade sehr gut. Der Klimawandel ist das beste Beispiel dafür. Auch da sehen wir, wie schwer ein Umdenken anscheinend stattfinden kann. Diese Sinnfrage müssen wir uns aber überall stellen. Aber sie ist natürlich so grundsätzlich, dass sich nur wenige trauen, diese Frage zu stellen. Und Karl Bernstein war derjenige. Karl Bernstein war der Erste seit langer Zeit. Hätte Harald es nicht gesagt, hätte ich es eben gesagt. Ich glaube, dass sein Vermächtnis ist, dass er einen Weg geebnet hat, den jetzt andere gehen können. Es ist nicht mehr unmöglich. Kay Bernsteins Weg wirkte unmöglich und nachahmer wird es weniger unmöglich sein. In anderen Vereinen, bei Hertha selbst – und Hertha ist in zweierlei Hinsicht ein Beispiel – es ist auf der einen Seite ein warnendes Beispiel, wohin ein Investoreinstieg und das Streben nach der gefühlten Weltherrschaft führen kann, dass du deine Wurzeln verlierst, dass du völlig zielos umher und mehr anders, dass du Personalwechsel hast wie noch und nöcher und dass sich jeder dazu berufen fühlt, zu wissen, was du brauchst und jeder das Gefühl hat, bei deinem Verein Einfluss nehmen zu können. Aus Profilierung, aus Gier, aus allen möglichen Gründen, nur nicht den Gründen, die wichtig sind. Da angeht das Hertha ein wahrendes Beispiel des Tobu-Kapitalismus im Fußball. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es ein löbliches Beispiel für 50 plus 1, für Mitgestaltung, für Basisarbeit, für Basisdemokratie und dafür, was ein aus den Fans heraus gewählter Mensch für einen Verein tun kann und wie er das Gesicht und die Stimmung grundsätzlich verändern kann. Denn ohne Kay Bernstein hätte es auch die Trennung von Friedi Bobic nicht gegeben, hätte es die Installation von Benni Weber und Zeke Neuendorf nicht gegeben, hätte es das Zurückkommen von Pall Dada nicht gegeben. Wir werden sehen, wie sich das alles letztendlich sportlich manifestiert. Aber dass damit eine Stimmungsumkehr möglich war, dass damit eine finanzielle Konsolidierung einherging und dass man mit dem Berliner Weg einen zukunftsfähigen, nachhaltigen Weg gefunden hat, mit dem sich alle identifizieren können, das ist mit der Wahl passiert im Sommer 2022. Und dahingehend ist Hertha wiederum ein positives Beispiel. Und diese beiden Beispiele werden sich die Leute, glaube ich, zu Herzen nehmen bzw. man kann es ja eigentlich für den Fußball nur hoffen, dass sie es sich zu Herzen nehmen, die richtigen Schlüsse daraus ziehen und wir vielleicht in den nächsten Jahren dahingehend die Entwicklung sehen, die Harald eben schon beschrieben hat.
Ich bin mir nicht gerade sicher, ob du gerade verklausuliert gesagt hast, die Zukunft gehört Berlin, aber du musst nicht darauf antworten.
Hertha ist immerhin das älteste Start-up Berlins.
Es ist einfach so, sie tryn, failn und winnen immer better. Aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Ich glaube, dem anschließend – wir sind jetzt schon ein bisschen bei der Frage, eben was ist das Vermächtnis von Kay Bernstein – ich glaube, dass man noch einen weiteren Aspekt hinzufügen kann, nämlich, was die Kurve oder so Fan-Romantiker wie wir drei in Kay Bernstein sehen, das ist relativ einfach und das ist auch klar, warum uns dann auch sein Werdegang Hoffnung gibt. Ich glaube, dass aber auch diejenigen, die auf der Haupttribüne sitzen und ihn vielleicht kritischer gesehen haben, vielleicht auch etwas mitnehmen können. Denn du siehst eben zum einen, wie sehr jemand einen Verein einigen kann und wie wichtig dabei Verantwortung und Kommunikation sind. Diese beiden Themen, auf die sind wir immer wieder zurückgekommen bei ganz, ganz vielen Aspekten, über die wir heute gesprochen haben. Und du siehst aber auch, dass du bei Menschen auf den Mensch gucken musst und nicht auf die Schublade, in die er gesteckt wird. Die Schublade zu Kay Bernstein war der Vorsänger, der Ultra, der Pyro-Präsident. Das, was er aber eigentlich in seinem Leben gezeigt hat, war, er war Ultra und Vorsänger und ich fürchte, er hatte auch mal eine Pyro-Fackel in der Hand. Und er hatte ein Stadionverbot, aber er war eben auch Unternehmer. Er hat sich eine zweite Karriere aufgebaut. Er war eben auch ein Haupttribünenbesucher und er konnte eben sehr, sehr viele Dinge über das hinaus, was er vorher getan hat. Und das hätte man, glaube ich, vorher schon sehen können. Es gab natürlich auch Menschen, die das so gesehen haben, die ihn auch deswegen gewählt haben. Also deswegen war für mich dieses lange drei Stunden Interview bei Felicio vor seiner Präsidentschaft so interessant, weil ich eben sehen wollte, was hat er da gesagt? Weil danach habe ich auch sehr, sehr viel von ihm gehört. Aber ich wollte wissen, wie offen war er in all den kritischen Punkten schon da? Und ich finde bemerkenswert offen. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, Mensch, Kay, da hast du uns aber was verschwiegen oder da fehlt doch noch eine Ebene. Ich finde, er hat auf jede Frage dann doch sehr, sehr offen geantwortet. Und dann aber zu sehen, dass so jemand den Verein schon ein Stück weit übernimmt, denn er führt eine neue Kultur ein. Es werden auch Positionen – nicht jeder ist damit glücklich. Nicht jeder ist bei Hertha BSC geblieben. Aber an gewisse Spielregeln hat sich auch Kay Bernstein gehalten und halten müssen. Und in den Zwängen hat er eben dann nicht – er ist nicht durchgedreht und hat gesagt, wir lehnen jetzt Triple Seven ab und wir fahren diesen Verein lieber – lieber starten wir jetzt nochmal in der Bezirksliga neu als mit Triple Seven ein Investor zu nehmen. Das wäre doch die Radikal-Lösung gewesen, die auch möglich gewesen wäre. Das hat er nicht getan. Er hat sich an die Realpolitik angepasst und dementsprechend diesen Verein auch professionell geführt. Ich denke, das kann man sagen, selbst bei allen Kritikpunkten, die man da auch sehen kann. Marc, du hast es ja sehr schön beschrieben, dass er logischerweise auch dann sein Netzwerk gestärkt hat in diesem Verein. Und das ist ja, glaube ich, aber auch ein Teil seines Vermächtnisses. Lasst uns auf den Menschen blicken und nicht auf die Schublade, versuchen Schubladendenken aufzubrechen. Und das zweite Realpolitik wird immer der Fußball sein. Wir werden immer aus Idealherr auf den Fußball blicken und die Leute auf dem Spobis, die werden immer aus Sicht von Renditen auf den Fußball blicken. Und beides kann aber miteinander gehen. Es schließt sich manchmal in Bereichen aus, aber im operativen Geschäft gibt es Wege, immer wieder, um neue Kompromisse zu ringen. Und darum geht es ja letztlich im Fußball.
Es geht auch. Ich habe mit Kay viel über das Thema Fehlerkultur gesprochen, weil das auch ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Aspekt in seinem Leben war und auch in seinem Wirken. Nicht zuletzt in der moralischen Frage, wie mit Marius Gersberg umzugehen ist. Das Thema will ich hier nicht komplett aufmachen. Auch da positiv aber erwähnen, wie viel Kay sich hat Dinge spiegeln lassen. Und auch da gab es keinen Alleingang. Er hatte eine Meinung dazu, die hat er in den Verein getragen. Und dann ging es wieder um Gremienarbeit. Diese Entscheidung wurde nur zusammengetroffen. Aber es ging um Fehlerkultur. Das kann man nämlich auch auf sein Leben beziehen, auf zweite Chancen. Wenn es Kay Bernstein auch nicht gegeben hätte, dann wäre beispielsweise auch ein Paldada nicht jeder bei Hertha BSC. Das vergessen viele. Vor ein paar Stunden habe ich erwähnt, dass sich Paldada von Balaton meldete und eine Wahlempfehlung für Frank Schleffel aussprach. Der hatte nach dem bitteren Ende bei Hertha in der Bobic-Zeit, als er von Bobic rausgeschmissen wurde, einen Hass auf diesen Verein, den er, glaube ich, noch nie hatte. Paldada und Hertha BSC kann man sich eigentlich auch gar nicht getrennt vorstellen. Aber in dem Moment waren sie so entzweit wie noch nie. Wer hat die Hand gereicht? Wer hat das Gespräch gesucht? Kay Bernstein. Wir können da ganz viele Beispiele mitnehmen, wo er Leuten wieder die Hand gereicht hat und ein Gespräch gezeigt hat und auch öffentlich darüber gesprochen hat, dass man lernen muss, zu verzeihen. Und im Fußball ist es oft so, du machst einen Fehler und du bist verbrannt. Auch in der Gesellschaft ist das oft so. Oder du kommst aus einer gewissen Schublade, wie du es eben erwähnt hast, Max, und du bist für einige Leute nicht erwünscht. Warum du in dieser Schublade vielleicht gelandet bist und warum du diesen Fehler gemacht hast, wird dabei gar nicht oft gesehen. Und das Thema Fehlerkultur und wie gehen wir damit um, war ein ganz großer Aspekt von Kay Bernstein. Ich glaube, auch das hat man in den letzten Jahren bei Hertha gesehen, dass Leuten verziehen wurde, dass man Fehler gemacht hat, aber auch erklären konnte, warum man sie gemacht hat. Und dass dann man plötzlich merkt, ach, guck an, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Und das kriegt man doch irgendwie alles immer ganz gut hin, wenn man das nur zusammen macht.
Und da finde ich ganz großartig, Marc, wie du das jetzt so zusammengefasst hast. Mir ist da dann quasi etwas kürzerer Satz noch eingefallen, weil ich jetzt ja auch die ganze Zeit nach einer Bilanz zu unserem Gespräch suche und auch nach einer Bilanz, wie ich Kay Bernstein sehe. Und diese Bilanz ist bei mir von jemand, als jemand, der da von außen so draufguckt und versucht, das zu analysieren, ist hier entsprechend so geprägt. Und für mich ist das so eine Formel, also viele dachten, es kommt der Ultra oder der ehemalige Ultra und es kam aber ein visionärer Präsident mit der Fähigkeit zu kommunizieren und mit dem Anspruch, auch alle Mitglieder und relevanten Persönlichkeiten im Umfeld der Hertha zuzugehen, ins Gespräch zu kommen. Das ist so für mich so eine Quintessenz, die ich jetzt auch aus unserem Gespräch und diesen vielen wirklich genial ausgesuchten Ohrtönen vom Max, von Kay Bernstein, nicht da so ziehe und dass ich dann für mich jetzt das Thema gerade durch unser Gespräch nochmal ganz neu sehe und noch wichtiger empfinde als noch wichtiger empfinde als ich das vorhin schon empfunden habe. Sodass ich da auch sage, es wäre jetzt super spannend, mal so eine Forschungsarbeit dazu anzustrengen, aber jetzt keine abgehobene Forschungsarbeit, sondern durchaus als Feldforschung verstanden, wo wir mal uns bemühen, so die Struktur des Fußballs mit all den Grundlegbarkeiten, also die Struktur des Spiels, uns anzuschauen, zu vergleichen mit der Struktur in der Fankultur und dann aber auch, zu vergleichen mit der Biografie eines Kay Bernsteins. Nichts anderes haben wir letztlich in unserem Gespräch gestern und heute auch gemacht. Diese drei Säulen so übereinander, nebeneinander zu bringen, das finde ich super spannend, weil dann kann man einerseits über den Fußball, über den Sport viel lernen, über die Fan-Kultur viel lernen und auch über unsere Gesellschaft viel lernen und über einen Mann viel lernen, der eine Biografie hat, eine der Bühnen und Tiefen hatte, der sich verändert hat, der eine Entwicklung durchlaufen hat, die in gewisser Weise atemberaubend faszinierend ist, was er da alles so geschafft hat. Und das ist auch Vorbild für andere junge Männer, junge Frauen in unserer Gesellschaft, die irgendwann mal in der Kurve stehen, irgendwann auf der Flischwände stehen und dafür ihr Leben auch wie Singen brauchen, Vorbilder brauchen und Geschichten brauchen, die ihnen zeigen, was alles so in einer Biografie passieren kann. Aber was dann letztlich am Ende des Tages auch wichtig ist, das ist tatsächlich so etwas wie das Herausleben einerseits eines persönlichen Wertekompass, das man seine Normen hat, seine Werte hat, an dem man sein Leben und seine Leistungen messen lassen will und gleichzeitig, und das finde ich absolut wunderbar, dass man den Anspruch für sich entwickelt, die Menschen in seinem Endfeld zuzudehen, zu hören und auch neugierig und interessiert ist an den wenigen, die eine ganz andere Position vertreten als man selbst. Weil auch diese andere Position gehört irgendem dazu und es ist meine Aufgabe, egal wo ich wirke, diese andere Position verstehen zu wollen und in demokratischen Kontexten gedacht zu müssen, andere Positionen respektieren lernen. Nur dann kommt das System als Ganzes wirklich in seiner Vielfalt und Leistungsfähigkeit voran.
Ich kann es vielleicht noch ergänzen. Ich hatte ja immer ein Tribünengespräch mit Kay Bernstein geplant. Da gab es jetzt noch keine konkreten Planungen, aber irgendwann wäre das gekommen. Und nachdem ich mich jetzt dann durch so viele Stunden Interviews durchgehört hatte und so viel gelesen hatte, hatte ich ein neues Traum-Tribünengespräch, das nie zustande gekommen wäre. Also zwei Ideen waren da. Das eine, ich hätte gerne Uli Hoeneß und Kay Bernstein an einen Tisch gebracht. Denn das ist genau das, wovor Uli Hoeneß immer Angst hatte, dass die durchgedrehten Ultras irgendwann mal einen von ihnen zum Präsident wählen. Dagegen hat sich der FC Bayern ganz systematisch gewehrt. Und das kann man auch gut nachvollziehen in der Geschichte des FC Bayern. Und die zweite Konstellation, die mich aber sehr interessiert hätte, wäre Robert Habeck und Kay Bernstein miteinander zusammenbringen, weil sie von ihrer Art der Kommunikation sehr ähnlich sind, weil sie aus derselben Richtung auf die Fresse bekommen. Aber der eine dann doch ein bisschen weniger als der andere. Und das hätte mich einfach interessiert, den beiden zuzuhören, wenn sie das – also hätte natürlich nie geklappt, völlig klar – aber da mal drüber zu sprechen, wie geht man mit Öffentlichkeit um, wie geht man mit Kritik um und wie verliert man sich selbst nicht in der Realpolitik? Denn man muss sich anpassen an die Realpolitik. Aber man kam ja mit Überzeugung. Und wie verhindert man vielleicht auch, dass man verbogen wird? Oder kann man das vielleicht gar nicht verhindern? Kommt man vielleicht als anderer Mensch hinten aus dem System raus, als man vorne reingegangen ist? Es wird nicht mehr dazu kommen, denn Kay Bernstein ist natürlich, wie so viele Menschen, viel zu früh verstorben. Und wir haben ganz am Anfang im Intro haben wir gehört, da hat er gesagt, er möchte ein Präsident für alle bei Hertha BSC sein. Und er möchte aber eine Abschiedskultur einführen. Er möchte – und da hat er damals schon ein paar Namen genannt, von denen er sich verabschieden wollte, unter anderem seinen Vorgänger, nämlich Werner Gegenbauer. Und deswegen glaube ich, es ist auch noch mal relevant, dass wir jetzt auf den Abschied blicken, den Hertha BSC ihm beschert hat. Wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal drüber sprechen, Marc, wie du dich gefühlt hast und so weiter und so fort, denn es ist doch völlig klar, dass es sehr viele Menschen geschockt hat. Und da, finde ich, muss man jetzt auch gar nicht so reinführen. Das gibt es auch an anderen Orten, kann man da drüber hören. Ihr habt dem Hertha-Base-Podcast zum Beispiel eine Folge zugemacht. Aber zwei Dinge fand ich bemerkenswert an der Abschiedskultur, die jetzt Hertha BSC für Kay Bernstein geleistet hat. Das eine war, dass es nicht nur Hertha BSC war, die eine Abschiedskultur etabliert haben. Es war der KSC, der natürlich auch eine Fan-Freundschaft mit Hertha BSC hat. Aber es waren ganz, ganz viele Kurven. Ich fand das sehr interessant. Nennen wir ein Thema, außer Investorenkritik, bei dem sich die Kurven so einig waren, wie eben am ersten Wochenende nach dem Tod von Kay Bernstein. Es gab sehr, sehr, sehr viele Transparente. Und das zweite war dann aber die Art und Weise, wie Hertha BSC sich verabschiedet hat, mit einem Trauermarsch rund um das Heimspiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf und mit einer Rede von Fabian von Wachsmann, die ich jetzt gerne hier als letztes noch mal einspielen würde, in der ganz, ganz viel steckt, über das wir gesprochen haben und in dem aber auch eine Abschiedskultur drinsteckt. Wir hören Fabian von Wachsmann.
Lieber Kay, es bricht uns das Herz. Die Lücke, die du hinterlässt, als Mensch, als Vater, als Ehemann, als Sohn, als Freund, als Herr Thana und natürlich als unser Präsident wird nicht zu schließen sein. Mit deiner unvergleichlichen positiven Energie hast du unserem Verein seine wahre Identität zurückgegeben. Du hast vereint, statt zu spalten. Du hast uns daran erinnert, warum wir unseren Club lieben. So warst du ein Präsident für alle Herr Thanerinnen und Herr Thana, naber und leidenschaftlich, mit Demut und blau-weißem Herzblut. Du hast uns einen Berliner Weg in die Zukunft gezeigt, an den wir alle glauben und den wir nun ohne dich weitergehen müssen. Wir werden unsere Gemeinschaft pflegen und stärken, diesen Weg, deine Vision gemeinsam fortführen. Für dich, für Hertha BSC. Lieber Kay, du wirst für immer in unserem Herzen weiterleben.
Mich berührt das und ich kannte Kay Bernstein nicht persönlich und ich bin kein Hartha-BSC-Fan. Marc, du musst jetzt nicht über deine Gefühle sprechen, aber kann man vielleicht abschließend festhalten, zum einen, dass das ganz fantastisch war, dass Fabian von Wachsmann hätte er dieses Tribünengespräch gemacht, da für fünf Minuten gebraucht hätte und wir brauchen fast fünf Stunden um Dinge so gut auf den Punkt zu bringen und dass das auf jeden Fall auch bleiben wird von Kay Bernstein. Zumindest aktuell hat man eine sehr gute Art, sich zu verabschieden.
Das war ein unglaublich würdiger Rahmen. Und was mir wirklich in Erinnerung bleiben wird, ist die wohl stillste Schweigeminute, die ich je erlebt habe. So still, dass man die eine Fackel, die für Kay Bernstein in der Kurve leuchtete, hörte. Und als sie dann ausging, plötzlich der Anpfiff war und man, ich glaube, Stefan Herrmann zum Tagesspiegel hatte beim ersten Training nach Kays Tod den Satz benutzt, die Simulierung der Normalität. Und so ein bisschen was hatte, hatte das davon was. So schlimm und tragisch dieser Tod ist, so sehr hat die erste Reaktion von Umfeldvereinen, aber auch Fußballdeutschland gezeigt, dass die Saat oder der Samenkalm ja schon ein Stück weit aufgegangen ist. Würde ich so beschreiben, das war unglaublich menschlich, unglaublich würdig, unglaublich einend, was in den Tagen passiert ist. Ich erinnere mich daran, dass an dem Tag seines Todes, ohne dass der Verein das in irgendeiner Weise vorher kommuniziert hätte, die Leute zur Geschäftsstelle geströmt sind, weil das für sie eine natürliche Reaktion war, dorthin zu kommen, um gemeinsam zu trauern. Ich erinnere mich an Fabian Reese, der bei diesem Trauermarsch dabei ist. Wo passiert das? Ich erinnere mich an einen völlig aufgelösten Kurvenvorsänger, der an der Stelle steht, wo Kay Bernstein einst stand. Ich erinnere mich an einen geschmückten, sowohl an den geschmückten Tritt, den Kay als Ultravorsänger benutzt hatte in der Kurve, als auch seinen Platz auf der Tribüne. Ich erinnere mich an ganz viele ganz würdige Momente. Ich erinnere mich daran, wie viele Anekdoten die Menschen geteilt haben in den Tagen. Und ich glaube, wenn wir über den Berliner Weg reden, was ist der Berliner Weg? Der wurde kommuniziert, als man sich von Friedrich Bobitsch getrennt hat. Und Leute fanden ihn ein bisschen diffus, fanden ihn nicht greifbar. Was soll das bedeuten? Und ich glaube, nach Kay Bernsteins Tod ist er so offensichtlich, wie noch nie ist. Es geht um die Stärkung der Gemeinsamkeiten. Es geht um die Stärkung der Gemeinschaft. Es geht um Solidarität. Es geht um Brücken bauen, die handreichen. Es geht darum, worüber wir schon gesprochen haben, immer erst den Menschen zu sehen und nicht die Schublade oder den Fehler. Und genau das habe ich in diesen Tagen erlebt. Und Hertha trauert. Aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass Hertha gerade eine Stärke aus all dem zieht und eine Motivation, diesen Weg weiterzugehen. Und es war ein besonderer Tag und es sind nach wie vor besondere Tage.
Es erinnert auch daran, Abschiede haben wir viele im Leben. Und es sind auch schon andere Menschen gestorben als Kay Bernstein. Aber es hilft einem vielleicht auch nochmal mit persönlichen Verlusten, über sie anders zu denken, über den Abschied, den wir von Menschen nehmen. Und das ist ja nicht immer mit einer Ansprache vor 70.000 Menschen in einem Olympiastadion, sondern oft ist das im Gespräch mit sich selbst, in der Erinnerung mit sich selbst, die Art und Weise, wie man die Erinnerung hochhält, die das ist, das was bleibt. Und man sorgt quasi dafür, dass auch auf diese Art und Weise der Mensch, den man verloren hat, in Erinnerung bleibt. Ich glaube, da kann man am Beispiel des Fußballs vielleicht auch für die eigene Biografie etwas mitnehmen, für das eigene Erleben etwas mitnehmen. Harald, du hast geschrieben in einem Text in deiner Kolumne auf wotzen.de, der Fußball verliert mit Kay Bernstein einen wirklich großen und mutigen Visionär. Ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt alles herausgearbeitet in diesem Gespräch. Und du schließt aber dann damit, dass ja auch eine Botschaft damit verbunden bleibt. Du schreibst, traut euch, gesendet an Fans anderer Vereine, traut euch, packt an und wählt in den Clubs der Bundesliga eure Präsidenten. Und das wäre doch dann das perfekte Vermächtnis von Kay Bernstein.
Ja, also du hast es ja jetzt formuliert. Ich könnte es nochmal wiederholen. Das ist meine Botschaft, das ist mein Learning, was ich aus dieser Biografie für mich rausziehe, in dem Blick auf eine lebendige, verantwortungsbewusste Fan-Kultur, die in der Lage ist, anderen zuzuhören, aber gleichzeitig in der Lage ist, Partei für die eigene Mannschaft zu ergreifen, rivalisieren, mit anderen Fan-Kulturen umzugehen, aber dann im Kern, sich immer wieder über die Frage verständigen zu wollen, worum es eigentlich geht, bei diesem Sport, bei diesem Spiel, bei diesem Drumherum, weshalb wir das so gerne anschauen, weshalb wir gerne Teil des Ganzen sind und weshalb wir jetzt diesen Verlust so schmerzlich betrauern, diesen Verlust eines Präsidenten, der da wirklich ein Leuchtturm gewesen ist, so wie wir das jetzt in den letzten fünf Stunden ausführlich gesprochen haben. Und da meine ich, sollte jeder Verein mit Blick auf seine Region, seine Stadt, sein Entfeld, seine Mitgliederstruktur, seine Fan-Kultur schauen. Ja, wir wählen unseren Präsidenten, wir wählen unsere Gremien und wir wählen letztlich auch die Sätze unserer Satzung genau aus, weil wir darin fest schreiben möchten, welchen Fußball wir haben wollen. Und das kann ein anderer Fußball sein als der, der bei der Hertha gespielt wird. Es ist auch gut, wenn wir Unterschiede in der Bundesliga haben, wenn wir Unterschiede in unserer Vereinskultur haben, denn aus den Unterschieden wächst dann stetig irgendetwas Neues, ganz anders als in einer Einheitskultur. Aber in unserer Fußballkultur hat Kay Bernstein in den Jahren seiner Zeit wirklich in kurzer Zeit ein ganz, ganz großes Ausrufezeichen gesetzt, was man gerne eins zu eins kopieren möchte, aber durch das man sich auch sehr gern einfach nur installieren muss mit Blick auf die Struktur vor Ort. Und das ist so das, was ich daraus ziehe und wo ich auch in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren sehr neugierig hinschauen werde, nachfragen werde, darüber nachdenken werde, was das wird da weiterhin in diesem faszinierenden Sport, in dieser faszinierenden Fan-Kultur und in den Debatten dahinter.
Und dann wird vielleicht auch diese Sendung ein Teil dieses Vermächtnisses sein, weil man sich hoffentlich dann immer wieder an die Ideen von Kay Bernstein und an seine Person erinnern wird. Und das wäre nicht möglich gewesen ohne euch beiden. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Marc Schwitzky von hertha-base.de. Du schreibst auch viel beim RBB. Ich werde natürlich alles verlinken, wo man dich finden kann. Es wird sowieso ausführliche Show-Notes geben. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, noch mit weiteren Artikeln, mit den Quellen der ganzen O-Töne und so weiter und so fort. Marc, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du in einer privaten Phase des Umbruchs diese Mammut-Sendung mit reingepasst hast. Ich möchte Angehörige deines persönlichen Umfelds grüßen und herzlich danken, dass sie dich ausgeliehen haben. Das ist wirklich nicht selbstverständlich. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es auch hinbekommen, weil es mir einfach ein dringendes Bedürfnis war. Ich hatte ein bisschen Bammel vor der Sendung, einfach nur weil ich dachte, ich möchte nichts wiederkeuern, was in den letzten Tagen und Wochen ohnehin schon gesagt wurde. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, dass wir aus der Mischung von uns dreien doch etwas sehr Originäres hinbekommen haben. Das erfüllt mich und deswegen war es mir eine ganz große Ehre, dabei zu sein und ich werde selber, glaube ich, irgendwann nochmal hören und denken, ach doch, das haben wir ganz gut hinbekommen.
Hoffentlich ist dem so. Und ich hatte auch Bammel vor der Sendung, aber den Gedanken ein bisschen leichter gemacht, diese Sendung aufzunehmen, hat, dass ich wusste, Harald Lange wird mit dabei sein. Harald, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du hier nicht nur mit dabei warst, sondern eben deine Perspektive immer wieder gezeigt hast. Ich habe das als unfassbar wertvoll empfunden. Es war noch viel besser, als ich es mir vorgestellt hätte. Danke, dass du mal im Rasenfunk warst. Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, es wird nicht das letzte Mal gewesen sein.
Ja, ich sage auch herzlichen Dankeschön, Max und Marc. Das hat mir richtig Spaß gemacht. Ich schaue jetzt gerade auf die Uhr. Da läuft ja oben die Uhr mit, wie lange die Aufzeiten und von Wolf. Und wenn selbst überrascht, welche Zeife wir jetzt miteinander verbracht haben. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass das Thema, wie wir jetzt darüber gesprochen haben, nicht unterhaltsam war. Wir waren ja permanent gefordert, welchen Proton hat Max da ausgesucht und wo bringt er uns hin in unsere Analyse. Da fand ich das total bereichernd. Wie war ich dann quasi intern auch als jemand, der ganz nah dran war an Kay Bernstein, das dann immer wieder noch in einem anderen Kontext sitzen konnte, mit noch mehr Hintergrund aufbauen konnte, sodass ich dann immer wieder neu mich hinterfragt habe, welchen anderen Rahmen kann ich dem jetzt da nochmal aufsetzen oder was macht das mit mir, mit meinen Gedanken, welche Ideen bringt mich das Ganze. Und wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, ich hätte jetzt also nichts dagegen, wenn wir morgen noch mal zwei Stunden haben. Weil ich glaube, irgendwie ist das auch ein endlos Thema, wo man sich immer weiter vertiefen kann. Also ich bin mir sehr dankbar, dass ich hier mitmachen würde.
Danke schön, Harald. Du kannst das Tribünengespräch – Die Zukunft des Fußballs hören. Ich glaube, das knüpft an ganz vielen Themen an, die wir jetzt so aufgerissen haben. Aber das ist dann für einen anderen Tag geplankt. Danke euch beiden und ich danke natürlich auch allen da draußen, die diese Sendung möglich gemacht haben. Ihr wisst, auch der Rasenfunk hat quasi eine Satzung, nämlich wir sind per Werbe payable und sponsorenfrei. Und warum wir das sind, Gründe dafür hat man in dieser Sendung indirekt gehört. Deswegen ganz am Schluss dieser Sendung auch nochmal Danke an alle, die uns finanziell unterstützen. Adrian SVW, Brille, Basti Schwarzfischer, Miriam, Arne, Philipp und JV11 möchte ich hier herausheben, denn sie haben sich auch als Supporterinnen und Supporter registriert. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, das erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club und dort findet ihr auch auf rasenfunk.de alle anderen Sendungen, die wir gemacht haben. Es gibt viele, in denen wir Themen, die wir hier angerissen haben, auch schon mit besprochen haben. Die Zukunft des Fußballs wäre, glaube ich, das Tribünengespräch, was ich euch als nächstes ans Herz legen würde. Dann danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ohne diese Aufmerksamkeit würden wir es nicht tun. Wir sind auch ein Unterhaltungsprodukt. Bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk und vor allem bleibt gesund. Macht's gut. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.
Also Rasenmäher, MML, Rasenfunk. Rasenfunk oder also was es da alles gibt, das brauche ich nicht.